e
okay and then
it's
good morning everyone good morning
everyone uh this is the New Hampshire
house election law standing committee we
have today is a day filled with a number
of public hearings we are starting at
9:30 I expect that we are actually going
to go most of the day today there are
some housekeeping matters um that we
will need to take uh spend some time on
but I would like to get going because I
am a few minutes late to start this 9:30
hearing um and before we conduct our
business I'm I'm going to ask that you
all rise and join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all thank you everyone um I
want to welcome some members who were
here for the first time representative
if you could grab a name tag please and
have a
seat
um and uh we have some things as I said
that we're going to take care of so new
members for some members this is really
their one of their first meeting
meetings here we had some final meetings
at the end of the first year of the
session but here we are in
2022 the first bill that we have a
hearing scheduled on is
cac1 17 this is a ballot measure and
this is provides that upon petition by
voters a question may be placed on the
ballot of a Statewide election uh so
everybody is aware all committee members
have a folder which has all bills in it
um bills are available online at the
website for the standing committee you
can go in and see bills that are before
the committee um and we have with us to
introduce this bill to the committee the
agitant
welcome
thank you m thank you and representative
um I have just been informed and I need
to be reminded myself that the mics that
you have in front of you are designed to
help with the streaming that goes on um
but please turn them off when you're
finished speaking so when you see my red
light on after I've stopped talking
remind me thank
you thank you madam chair and thank you
members of the election law committee
for having me today happy to be here uh
today I'm here to introduce cicr 17 a
constitutional amendment to create a
ballot initiative process in the state
of New Hampshire I'd kind of like to
begin by telling you where this idea
came from um I remember specifically um
when I thought of putting this in it was
uh spring of 2021 and the senate had
voted 15 to nine to kill a cannabis bill
that had come before it that had already
passed the house by nearly a veto proof
margin uh we've seen seen a cycle like
this over the years where a bill on that
topic will come out of the house with a
pretty solid veto proof margin go over
to the Senate and die uh an issue with
broad bipartisan support in the state of
New Hampshire clears a large hurdle in
the house the body that is closest to
the people takes one step into the
Senate and stops uh I was frustrated by
this as many Granite Staters were likely
frustrated by it and so I thought you
know this is a decent idea to put into
cacr for but expanding beyond that um
there issues that I probably wouldn't
think of that have similar bip broad
bipartisan support so I felt like um
having a ballot measure initiative as
some other states do um you've likely
seen them in prop a prop B those kind of
things um would be a good thing to have
in the state of New Hampshire so um for
the presentation I would just like to go
over uh line three and talk about some
of the uh specifics I tried my absolute
hardest because a lot of people have
different opinions on what should be um
the standards to get something on the
ballot um I did my best to try to strike
a balance between restrictive and
reasonable um so not having a bar that's
so high that it can't be surmounted um
but having a bar that's high enough so
five people in the state of New
Hampshire can't get like joke items on
the ballot um I felt like that was an
important distinction um on the first uh
on line five when it says when 5% of the
total registered voters petition the
Secretary of State uh this is how it
happens in uh the recall process that
California has uh where it's 12% of the
voters um there was discussion about
making it a percentage of the previous
election attendance um but I felt 5% of
the total registered voters was more
appropriate given that elections can
have pretty wide disparities between
turnout um you can have a 2010 level uh
where the turnout is lower and you can
have a 2020 level uh where turnout is a
record high I don't think it's fair to
have um distinctions and different bars
for items to cross depending on which
year you're filing it um so 5% of the
total registered voters um that also
makes it a percentage and not a number
um which I think is helpful um I think
putting a specific number in the
Constitution um over time as population
increased would make it dramatically uh
easier like I said to get certain joke
items on the ballot uh that we'd want to
try to
avoid
um if the question receives a majority
of the vote in favor the law the
question shall become law in the state
of New Hampshire within a year of the
election in which it was asked the
purpose of that line um in my research a
lot of ballot measure and ballot
initiative processes and other other
states um they'll have the question on
the ballot that is more vague Maine is a
perfect example of this um a couple
years ago Maine through ballot
initiative uh affirmed a Medicaid
expansion um the legislature was still
required to act on that the legislature
was still required to put it in their
version of an RSA you know there's not
just a law in Maine that says the
complicated program of Medicaid is now
law and that's the end of that sentence
um it provides a legislative route for
some of the details to be hammered out
but it does provide a constitutional
imperative that the body acts if the uh
vote does receive a majority in favor um
and the last line um it's a little vague
but part of this is going to be what I
thought the rulemaking power of the
Secretary of State's office um May
establish a process to ensure the intent
of the question is carried out um almost
like an OS process uh is what I was
envisioning on there where um to make
sure that the question on the ballot is
the intent of the party petitioning um
with the authenticated signatures and
the 5% of the registered voters so um I
guess at the end of the day I'm not
married to the guard rails there um if
you know if folks feel like an amendment
might be NE necessary or warranted to
alter those um I'm ultimately fine with
that um My ultimate goal here is just to
have um a process with
which almost uncontested principles um
that have 70 80% support within the
state of New Hampshire have an easier
process of becoming law um than you know
as other states have um so that's where
I'm at on that um I can take any
to thank you representative does do any
members of the committee have questions
Bill thank you I'm representative
Lane thank you um I'm sorry I blank out
when you said what's the percentage in
California that has to be did you say
12% yeah my understanding is that it's
12% of Voters
um I believe it's 12% of the voters in
the previous election okay um yeah which
again I don't love that because um I
think it creates unfair bars for issues
to uh compete with in different years
based on the turnout of the previous
election so just to solid 5% of
registered voters I think is uh more
fair for each question can I have a
followup one other question was what
would uh prevent say getting 10 or 15 of
these on a ballot and really making it
difficult or do you just think it's that
would be my question can I ask can staff
is Staff here in the room can you te is
representative Lane being picked up
because I'm having a hard time hearing
much um is there any pre way to prevent
saying getting 10 or 15 of these on a
ballot because I know some people
complain that there's so many of them on
a ballot it kind of clutters the ballot
and it makes it difficult to get
anything
past um technically there isn't um as I
said I tried really hard to uh find a
decent what I thought balance between uh
restrictive and reasonable um my guess
if I had to estimate was that you know
in any given election you wouldn't see
uh more than two or three of these uh it
would be similar to uh the
Constitutional amendment process we have
now only it wouldn't require the
two-thirds of each body um I really
can't see this being you know 10 or 15
items on each ballot because you know
there is a 90-day window to get 5% of
the registered voters in the state
authenticated and it is a process it is
um a process intended to um stop some
sillier ones uh but also provide you
know a very reasonable voice within the
Affairs of the
state other questions representative
Barry um yes
so for the Constitutional Amendment part
of this is it just a simple majority of
the voters to change the New Hampshire
Constitution is that it correct
okay
and oh I had a follow follow and um on
the excuse me on the um legislative side
the enaction of laws not the
Constitution what's to stop the
legislature from coming in and
immediately
undoing what the uh what the voters have
just
passed um so I'm doing everybody's
favorite thing of uh reading into the
word shall on that um there are states
where things have passed on the ballot
and they don't have specific text in
their constitution or rsas that say you
have to do this thing
um theoretically um if you want to play
games with the word shall that could be
ignored um I think it would
representative if you're talking about
the word shall are we talking about line
six correct okay uh yeah the the purpose
of that line is to create a
constitutional imperative for the
legislature to act on that my suspicion
is that there if something were to uh
pass by going through this process and
creating that broad uh of demonstration
of support uh there would be fairly
decent backlash to just ignoring that um
or reversing that um it's not a great
answer but it it's you know what I would
suspect would be
there thank you further questions from
the committee representative prome O
Brien good morning
uh do you think that the ability of the
citizens to contact their
representatives and ask them to address
these issues that you think would be
addressed this way that when there's one
representative for every 3,000 citizens
in our state do you think that that's
insufficient it's not necessarily that I
think it's insufficient but I think um
especially in a more um partisan
environment that we feel now uh some
folks in legislative capacities may be
less likely to uh feel the need to
engage on some of those more broad
bipartisan uh issues I I keep going back
to uh the Cannabis issue polling
suggests that that specific issue uh
does 70 plus perc in the state of New
Hampshire um and just struggles to get
through the legislative process uh each
time it's
um so that that speaks to um one of the
filing I'm just gonna leave this on
further questions representative
Alexander um thank you madam chair um so
my question
is
if if the for the Cannabis situation if
it's not an issue that voters
necessarily care about they wouldn't
necessarily petition and only vote for
candidates that support legalization of
cannabis I guess what my point is is
that it's if it doesn't pass a legisla
process it might just not be an issue
that voters are petitioning as much as
like you know taxes or gun control or
things like that so I guess what I'm
wondering is
like why put it on the ballot if it
doesn't even pass the muster of like
priority for the
legislature so I think I can answer that
um with the Liberty um in um expanding
upon the point that I think I was trying
to make just a minute ago
um as a member of a specific party I am
extremely unlikely in any circumstance
given the broad scope of issues that
each of the two parties represent to
vote for a member of a different party
based on one specific issue so if I
admittedly late I'm a Democrat and um I
agree with the Democratic candidate 90%
of the time um on issues of uh climate
uh the economy but my Republican
candidate for State Rep is better on the
issue of cannabis and that is an issue
that I care about am I as a voter going
to sacrifice 90% of the issues that I
agree with to vote for a candidate who
I'm going to loath most of the time
because they were decent on one issue or
is there an Avenue to say I still want
to vote for this person because I agree
with them on 90% of the things and I'm
going to take this one issue out of
political consideration by trying to get
it on the ballot so that uh it's devoid
questions thank you and representative I
appreciate the dance on the head of a
pin you just did because I came close
when you started talking about loathing
people of certain
parties so I tried to make the point the
best I could
okay anybody
else all right thank you very much for
coming and introducing the
bill all right our next bill is
scheduled to go forward at 10 o'clock it
is HB
1482 followed by
1264 followed by CAC R22 these all deal
with rank Choice voting um we have
various materials for the committee to
pass out along with um if there are
written materials for this these
particular presentations we're going to
recess right now until 10 o'clock and
of sorry excuse me thank you for that
procedural i i before I close the
hearing oh all right I don't have a pink
card sorry you were co-sponsor pass down
um and we do have a few people signed up
both in favor and opposed to this Bill
thank you I apologize representative
Reed I was so anxious to get on to the
10 o'clock I missed as am I and just for
the record uh we do have some prints
coming in that apparently there was a
printing snafu that's all right we'll
take a re we'll take a brief recess
thank you mad it's all the same thing I
wasn't planning on testifying on this
bill oh just for the record my name is
Ellen Reed uh I represent New Market and
Newfield that's Rockingham
17 uh and I am a co-sponsor of this um
cacr uh I wasn't planning on testifying
I did hear a few Concepts in the
discussion that I wanted to speak
briefly to some of you know that I teach
American government at Community College
um and just for definition sake I want
to talk a little bit about democracy I
know a lot of times people will say we
have a republic not a democracy so for
definition because I'm going to use the
word democracy a little bit um there are
two kinds of democracies there 's direct
democracy and representative democracy
we are in a representative democracy
which is also known as a republic so a
republic is a style of democracy a
flavor uh one of two flavors now having
said that direct democracies are where
everyone votes on every issue and that
would be very unwieldy and and um
problematic so there aren't too many
however amongst republics there are
republics that lean a little bit more
towards the direct style and a little
bit more towards the more like kind of I
don't know what you want to say
separated from the people style here in
New Hampshire we very proudly as
representative pban pointed out are very
connected to our people and I'm very
proud um that we are kind of a more
direct style uh Republic in that sense
and along those lines I think that
having a ballot initiative as I've
supported in the past helps connect us
directly now in terms of why would we
need about an initiative since we are so
connected well I think maybe every
single member in this room might have
had the same experience as me and not
being able to reach a fellow member and
if I can't reach a fellow member and get
an answer on an issue what hope does a
constituent have sometimes of reaching a
member and getting an answer on an issue
or getting them to act in their favor um
a question about do we limit um how can
we limit uh the number of questions so
it doesn't like clutter up the ballot I
think um you could potentially amend it
to say the first three ballot
initiatives that meet the requirements
would be included any other one that
meets the requirements after that would
cycle also the idea of can't legislators
just reverse something that the people
did yes technically but the reason that
they wouldn't is simply pressure can you
imagine if an overwhelming majority of
people supported something being a
legislator going going no the people are
wrong um I think politically that would
be not advisable for that that
member also issues what kind of issues
would uh be on a ballot initiative other
than the marijuana issue you all are
about to hear about rank Choice voting
coming up in Maine the legislators did
not want to act on this issue and fought
it and the people of Maine overturned
them overturned their own legislators
and it was successful and not only
wasn't successful but you will hear from
a member of the Secretary of State's
office in Maine about how successful it
was so it turns out in that particular
example the people had more wisdom than
their legislators so I just wanted to
touch on those few issues thank you so
much for your time I'm happy to answer
questions but I suspect all the members
answered thank you representative Reed
it occurs to me as I listen to this that
a sort of presented in as article 11a as
actual
petition will go on the local ballots
correct that's my understanding the cacr
process and it would go on a state
election ballot correct
correct
and how do do you determine whether the
issue is one for a general election if
the process is no longer going through
the
legislature um how do you determine if
it's appropriate for a Statewide ballot
right that's a very good question Madam
chair and I do not have the answer to
that
one because is it fair to say let's
say it's not coming to mind but I can I
I given I think the 5% is probably a
pretty high bar so I'm sort of
hypothetically saying okay we can meet
that um I can see where there are issues
that could be brought forward on a local
level that would be traditionally dealt
with at a local level that would now end
up on this state ballot in a general
election because that's the intent but
it doesn't say it right the intent is
for this to go on a Statewide ballot a
Statewide ballot but it's not limited to
that well I presume that the threshold
is high enough that if it were merely a
single town or County issue that you
wouldn't be able to meet the requirement
but it doesn't actually say total
registered voters of the state it just
says total registered voters so could I
argue that it's total registered voters
of my community since I'm going to
petition my Selectmen I would I would
argue that it means that it needs to be
amended to say of the state thank you
repres representative
Barry I appreciate the uh distinction of
Republic and direct democracy um glad to
know you're a American government
teacher um I'm a political science guy
myself um I studied American government
um and I studied the founding fathers
who wrote extensively about the tyranny
of the majority um and that's why we
have this complicated system of
government which as much as people don't
like to admit it is designed not to pass
things it's l designed for gridlock so
that when the legislator is doing things
it's only doing things that are really
important the cooling saucer uh yes um
so what I'm and the reason we have our
the reason we have this system um is
because their direct democracies Tyran
and majority it's not up for debate
right if 50.1% of the people show up and
say they want this and 49.9 show up and
say they don't which this bill allows
for right by the way it's not we're
proposing these issues which are 70 80%
approval but there's nothing that stops
something from passing with 50.1 um the
reason we have this legislative process
reason we're legislators right is that
we're supposed to look into issues dive
into it and make the best decisions for
our constituency right and for me
there's examples of that right where I
break party ranks um just last week I
voted uh to punish St gobain um for
polluting the water because I represent
the town of Lichfield and St gobain has
polluted the water um and they deserve
to be punished and you know I broke
party ranks because that's what I do as
a as a representative my party said send
it did you share and I said no these
people are evil um they deserve to be
punished so how are you not short
changing that process with this right
you're just sending things you know our
job is to look into things our job is to
dig into this if you took me and dumped
me in transportation I wouldn't know
what to do you put me in election law
and I I happen to be
very um good at this so how are we how
process thank you for the question and
the background and as someone who
recently was in the news for uh quite
publicly breaking party ranks um I can
appreciate your comment um and what I
would say is this doesn't overturn that
I mean we have plenty of states that
have valid initiatives that doesn't
overturn it you still elect
representatives they still vote on the
vast majority of technical issues if you
look at all the propositions that come
up in the different states they are
usually propositions that have to do
with they're not very technical issues
like Mar Iana or you know in the past
gay marriage they're more just are the
people ready to move forward from
traditional to something else is it it's
more philosophical and Broad and not um
very technical so you don't have for
example propositions popping up across
the country about how many parts per
million arsonic can we allow should it
be five or six right um so you are
absolutely correct that one of the
dangers of a pure direct democracy is
that the people are not educated enough
on those is issues and end up voting
poorly and I think we can all make
arguments that sometimes that even
happens in our representative process
where people are not educated on the
people they're electing and vote poorly
but to that point when you say tyranny
of the majority it was certainly a
concern of the founders um but it wasn't
the only concern of direct democracy of
the founders but it was one of them but
the problem is that we already have that
potential it only takes 50% plus one to
elect a Tyrant into office or elect
somebody who wants to be a tyrant into
office now right so we still have that
threat all this does is it barely moves
the needle over to if the people want to
put a question they have to overcome
that threshold then the people have to
vote by 51% on a particular question I
think the point that U Madam chair made
earlier about is it appropriate to be on
the Statewide ballot might be uh
something along the lines of what you're
talking about like is this something
that we can really put on a Statewide
ballot does is it appropriate um and and
could that be problematic so I'd like to
kind of explore that issue a little bit
more thank you any further questions for
representative Reed on the bill we are
currently conducting a public hearing on
C 17 representative prto O'Brien you can
stay in your seat I'll get to you I
promise I feel like
horack that a lot of people aren't going
to remember that uh
I'm thinking of what you said when you
said the people in Maine had more wisdom
than their own elected officials when
they pass rank Choice voting this
way but here in New Hampshire I I said
we had one s we
had one representative in the in the
house per
3,000 citizens what are what's that
number in
Maine oh you're you're AB if you don't
know maybe the person that's coming
later to speak on that from the
Secretary of State's office in Maine can
can I I'm I'm almost positive she can
answer that I don't have that it is
larger than than ours obviously because
we are a small state and we have the
largest State Rep um representative body
um but I'm completely with you that I
know there are legislators that support
reducing the size of our body I am
adamantly not one of those I really
appreciate the fact that I am accessible
to my constituents so I'm not at all
suggesting that but you're right that
perhaps that kind of distance does breed
like less understanding of what the
people want or less accountabil
accountability to the people having said
that like I said I may contact someone
on this committee and not hear back or I
may ask another representative to do a
small favor and not hear back so if I'm
having those problems how many how much
more problems are the 3,000 constituents
of that representative possibly
having thank you as a follow followup
I think that question okay would you
believe that I uh I've had a different
experience where as a citizen before I
became in the legislature contacting my
state representative to talk to them
about something was a much different
experience than Representatives
contacting representatives and I had
positive experiences with that would you
believe that I I would believe that both
positive and negative experiences happen
both as a legislator and as a
constituent and I'm sure we all know
people who've had both positive and
negative
experiences thank you further questions
Reed I think that I'll be back all
right all right so this does close the
hearing on
CA CAC
R17 um we I'm going to turn my mic off
and we're going to go through here um
and make sure all the committee members
have handouts that are available for the
next presentations which are all related
to each other that I expect we will be
spending the majority of time on HB
1482 so um hold on we'll get going
officially in a minute and Christina all
I'm going to do is turn off my mic
because I'm assuming that will shut the
vid the sound down and the video will
okay
e
nice
he you okay I
so I'm reconvening the election law
committee it is
10:25 um if you're on this side of the
room and apparently you're five minutes
behind me if you're at the other side of
the room so I hope whatever the space
continuum is working for the audio here
um we are about to open the hearing on
1482 the reality is here in the election
law we have
1482 relative to rank Choice voting
follow followed by
1264 relative to rank Choice voting for
State party primaries and
aacr relating to all
elections um these have been placed in
order on the calendar at the request of
the Prime sponsor so that hopefully as
we go through this in our uh efforts to
understand what is being presented to us
we can sort of get the big picture and
follow the bills through in that regards
I'm also accommodating requests for the
order of speakers because there are
people who have come in with various um
presentation materials to try and um
convey uh the logistics of what this
request would um do so with that um 1482
relative to rank Choice voting the prime
sponsor is representative Reed and she
joins us today to introduce the bill rep
welcome representative Reed thank you
again madam chair and honorable members
for welcoming into me into your
committee which is of course my home
away from home when I'm not in fishing
game you'll be sure to find me across
the hall um for the record once again my
name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 17 New Market and newfields
um and I also did as the uh the chair
mentioned um I have some experts um I
believe that we are really going to try
to focus on answering technical details
of the committee and really diving into
this issue it has been before this
committee not all all of the members
obviously uh before but to that end uh I
do have uh here ready to testify uh
Emily cook from the main Secretary of
State's office Phil Phil steel who
helped head up voter education efforts
in Maine um to talk about the main
experience uh as well as Professor
Charlie wheen uh Dartmouth Professor New
Hampshire resident I also have legal
expert Uh current New Hampshire resident
but former Utah GOP chair uh Tiani
Coleman um so anyway with
that let me take you on a time traveling
Journey back to when we started this
crazy thing called democracy with all
the voting and stuff um it isn't what we
have in terms of you go and vote Whoever
has the most votes wins right that makes
sense it's what we've all grown up with
that started really a long time ago and
it's it's a a simple but kind of
antiquated thing hear me out from old
England when no one thought of more
sophisticated ways to accurately
represent people's wishes so the
philosophy was majority
rule which is great when you have two
people running because whoever gets the
most votes by definition gets 50% Plus
at least one um but when you have more
than two people running in an election
sometimes you don't end up with a winner
that has
the most
support uh you have what's called vote
splitting or spoiler effect so you may
have one candidate that 2third of the
the people do not want in a threers race
the two-thirds get their vote split
between two other candidates none of
them wanted the third person but because
they he the the other two candidates
split that anti- person vote that person
wins with 34% of the vote when you have
more than three people it can get even
Haier you have the potential for people
winning with 20% 12% of the vote are
these people that actually have the most
support we don't know
now because we have this system where
votes can get split and we don't know
where actual um the the actual desire of
the public
is uh we have the spoiler effect and
wasted votes so so people casting their
ballots for any candidate who isn't one
of the major two parties in contention
are essentially wasting their votes in
many elections and what that means is we
get driven into a two-party system and
the two-party system as we know has
become more and more and more divisive
because as those two parties become the
only Power holders in our
democracy um everyone is forced into one
of two camps not because that's
necessarily where their true desires lay
but because fear of the the greater evil
in essence more and more voters are
voting for the lesser of two evils or
the evil of two
lessers but the point is is that we all
recognize the divisiveness in our system
we all recognize that sometimes winners
win when they don't have the most
support or other candidates would have
had more support but we haven't um
necessarily figured out the right way to
get past that now having said that many
States including ours have attempted to
get past this problem mostly by
instituting a majority provision saying
that the winner has to have a majority
the New Hampshire Constitution put that
provision in in place originally
originally the New Hampshire
Constitution demanded that Winners have
a majority 50% plus one
in other states the way they get to this
majority is through runoff elections
however we did not have runoff elections
in New Hampshire and instead we had a
provision in the Constitution that has
since been struck that said if we did
not have a majority the decision would
be made by the legislature and so what
happened is as people started to realize
that they could win through the
legislature if enough people were in the
race we had more and more elections that
didn't have majority winners and more
and more frequently and this is the late
1800s into the early 1900s more and more
frequently the legislature New Hampshire
legislature was deciding election
outcomes and so in 1912 I believe we
amended the Constitution to say just a
plurality just whoever happens to get
the most votes even if that's
12% so that's where we stand today right
now however other states that have this
majority provision that do the runoff
elections um they still do that so they
find a winner in those states that have
majority
support So rank Choice voting is another
way of getting at this and it's not
actually another way the other name for
rank Choice voting is instant runoff
voting if you understand runoff
elections like they have in Georgia and
other states then you understand rank
Choice voting so just in case because we
don't have runoff elections in this
state in case you don't know when they
have a race in
Georgia where they don't have have a
majority winner so they had more than
two people running no one got 50% plus
one what will happen is they will
eliminate everybody but the top two
candidates and they'll have an entirely
new election this actually happened for
both Senate seats this last election
cycle they'll have an entirely new
election at the expense of the
taxpayer now what if instead of holding
a whole new election which takes months
or at least a month and is at Great cost
to the to the people the taxpayer and at
Great cost to them having to turn out
what if we just said hey if this goes to
a runoff election who would you vote for
and that's what rank Choice voting is
it's as simple as that so if you think
runoff elections are good and they help
determine majority outcomes it's the
same thing for rank Choice voting that
is literally instant runoff voting so
how it works is you as a voter put down
your preferences your first preference
if that person gets eliminated because
they got the least number of votes then
your next preference Etc and then we go
in runoff rounds so starting with the
first round we count up the votes just
like normal if someone gets a majority
it's over done just like normal if no
one gets 50% plus one then the person
the candidate who get receives the least
number of votes is eliminated and all of
those ballots that chose that person as
their first preference get reallocated
to their next preference and then we do
an entirely new election a runoff round
so um one of the I guess uh talking
points of opposition tends to be well
isn't this just giving certain people
extra votes is a runoff election giving
people extra votes every single person
who voted in that election still is
voting so if you're if you're B didn't
get eliminated or that that first
preference didn't get eliminated you're
still voting for your first preference
but you're still voting in that runoff
round and in fact and we have a legal
expert that can talk about specific
cases but in fact this has gone before
the court quite a number of times uh on
the idea that it violated one person one
vote and every single time at every
single level of the Judiciary um rank
Choice voting was found not only to not
violate one person one vot but to
actually in some court cases they said
it strengthened one person one vote so
really briefly uh I want to talk about
this cool thing that we have as state
representatives in our district
multi-member districts because when you
do rank Choice voting in a multi-member
district where you have more than one
person that has a seat so you have like
in many of our districts two seats three
seats you get a really cool effect
because not only are you eliminating
those wasted votes that are cast for
candidates that can't win and coalescing
the support from those candidates around
the one that most people support but
you're also eliminating uh the problem
of wasted votes for candidates who have
already won and the effect of that
because the the votes when your
candidate your preferred candidate's
already won you go to your next
preference and the effect of that is
proportional
representation proportional
representation
is when the actual elected
body looks like the electorate and looks
like in terms of politically I don't
mean physically obviously so for example
right now we might have a district that
has three seats let's say the district
is 67%
Democrat and 33% Republican it has three
seats it's 67% Democrat ideally you
would want two of those seats to be
Democrat and one to be Republican repan
right because that would reflect the
body the electorate however what what
happens right now a single party sweep
if you have a district that's 67%
Democrat all three will go to the
Democrats leaving a third of that
district
unrepresented with proportional
representation that is is an outcome of
rank Choice voting in a multi-member
district you end up with the two and one
usually it's not based on party but the
point is is that people's preferences
are taken into effect and taken into
account excuse
me so I'd like to talk about
implementation and I am kind of giving a
30,000 foot view I know I'm going
through details but I'm not delving into
the details that's why I have the
experts behind me so really briefly on
implementation one of the concerns that
I've heard is how does this affect Town
workers absolutely not at all if you are
a municipal worker in an election you do
not do anything differently ranked
Choice voting ballots are not counted
tabulated what have you on the town
level they can't be it wouldn't make any
sense in all of these elections you have
to take into you can't eliminate any
candidates until you know who got the
least number of votes overall so the way
implementation is done and this is how
implementation was done in Maine and we
do have people to speak to that is you
have to send neze all of the data from
all the ballots this can either mean uh
a secure Courier that cers um the actual
memory cards from the election machines
or a a secure Courier that couriers the
ballots themselves so even without
machines whatsoever we can Implement
rank Choice voting this is what they do
in Maine Maine is a geographically
larger State than we are uh the furthest
if we're centralizing everything the
furthest you can get from conquered is
about 3 hours in this state maybe four
so you're talking about maybe a delay of
a of five or six hours on Election night
in terms of results but but not in terms
of the first runoff round reporting Town
workers can still report their first
runoff round numbers just like normal
those are not certified election results
the Secretary of State rarely certifies
on the same night but they can report
what their numbers are they do not have
to run any round in fact they can't run
any rounds because it wouldn't make
sense so anyway the implementation does
nothing changes for the town worker they
process the ballots as normal you have
couriers that either bring memory cards
or ballots to a central location
conquered the secretary state's office
takes over from there if they are
ballots they are run through a
high-speed scanner that are rented for a
very very low cost Maine does this uh if
they are memory cards then they are
simply plugged in and through open-
Source software where everyone can see
how the software works the rounds are
run and everyone can see exactly which
votes went to
whom now if you're using memory cards
the question is do we have machines
compatible currently our our current
machines are not compatible however the
Secretary of State's office is already
looking into machines we have the have a
funds to buy new machines as many of you
already know and every single machine on
the market today is rank Choice voting
compatible without so we have no dog in
the game in terms of which machine does
certify uh all of this
implementation um again they can speak
more in depth about this but it took
Maine a few months and low six figures
to implement so really really um kind of
low barrier to
implementation another question that
gets brought up a lot is voter education
and the voter
experience so this has been implemented
in I believe we're at 27 States on some
level Municipal level uh local elections
military State political parties we have
over half the country in terms of states
that do it on some level um we have exit
polls from those States voters
overwhelmingly understand and are
satisfied with the process even in the
first
iteration of it and really um there is
there are voter education efforts just
to but it's mostly just to prepare them
for the idea of ranking like it's not
just one person you get to you get to
rank so the the the kind of myth that
voters get confused if you understand
how to rank your three favorite flavors
of ice cream then you understand how to
vote on a rank Choice voting ballot
three choices first first second third
simple as
that um it's one of those things that's
really easy to understand when you see
it and it's harder to explain verbally
um I know that you've heard testimony
that there's writing names on on ballots
or something like none of that is the
case it's still filling the bubble just
like our current ballots um and in fact
roughly half of our body um who was
previously skeptical by the way some
members were skeptical at the beginning
of this term about rank Choice voting
but the Democratic caucus elected their
leader for the first time using rank
Choice voting as I mentioned some of the
members were skeptical but we all went
through the process we when I used to be
a member and it took about 15 minutes or
so but only because um some of the
members were having computer
difficulties and everybody understood
the results it just it was very simple
we got to see the different rounds and
how the the votes got reallocated
and uh I think we made a lot of beli
Believers out of out of a lot of the
caucus just through that one experience
having said that there will be
opportunities for you all I wish I could
do it here in testimony but to vote on
flavors of cookie or ice cream once you
do it you understand it um fairly
quickly in fact for those of you who
have been here when we've voted for
speaker when we had more than two people
running um the process is pretty similar
only that we undergo several rounds of
voting instead of just putting our
preferences on one ballot but if you
have more than two people running for
speaker we as legislators and we vote
and nobody gets a majority usually what
happens is the person who got the fewest
votes drops out possibly endorses
another candidate and everybody votes
again that's exactly what happens with
rank Choice
voting so I mentioned that a bunch of
states do this on a local level
obviously main does it on on the
Statewide level AR excuse me Alaska
recently um adopted it for uh
primaries uh Minnesota California
Massachusetts Vermont New York Municipal
level the Virginia GOP recently adopted
it the Utah GOP has been using it for
well over a
decade it's used throughout the
English-speaking world including in
every election in Australia every
election in Ireland New Zealand Northern
Ireland and Scotland it is the voting
method not by name but by description
recommended by Robert's Rules of
Order and as such it's widely used in
corporations it's widely used by
universities um and it's actually used
by the Academy Awards I don't know how
you feel about the Academy Awards but uh
that's how we get best
picture
um that may not be a selling point
depending on what you
like so there's the point is this been
has been done for decades there's a ton
of data on how this works and if this
was a sky is falling situation as some
people say you would you would know
about it you would know about it 27
States using it on all different levels
the military using it corporations
universities you would hear about how
this doesn't work but instead we're
hearing the opposite where more and more
people are adopting it because it does
work because it does allow people it
allows a number of things actually first
of all it allows the voter to vote their
conscience instead of feeling forced
into one or two parties and ultimately
I don't really like this person but at
least they're not that other person
instead of that kind of voting which
feels icky to me if that's a technical
word it feels negative and forced
instead of that it allows them to vote
their conscience without penalizing
their next
preference um and I think we can all
think of uh examples of Elections where
maybe we felt that way where we didn't
really like the person on our side but
the independent really didn't have a
shot so we voted for that person because
at least they weren't you know b elub or
whatever um it also allows third-party
candidates independent candidates
candidates that don't normally get a lot
of um airtime per se low dollar
candidates people with different ideas
it allows them all to compete on an even
playing field not in terms of
advertising and money but in terms of
recognition on the ballot and people
being allowed to vote for them without
penalizing their next preference it also
reduces um negative campaigning because
if you think about it you may be asking
a voter to vote for you as their first
preference but even if they tell you
that someone else is their first
preference you're not going to badmouth
their favorite preference because maybe
you can be their second preference or
their third even so in the places where
this has been instituted um negative
all
right and obviously and most importantly
it does uh help represent people it
actually GES gives us the most accurate
highdefinition picture of the will of
the electorate over any other system and
it is the only system where you can
actually basically through your voting
say anybody but that person yes this
person my first and maybe these people
but definitely never that person there's
no other voting system there are a
number of alternative voting systems but
there's no other system that allows the
voter to do that so it increases
accurate representation and it also
increases voter engagement because in
some of these cases where people feel
like they're being forced into one of
two parties or the lesser of two evils
they feel like their vote doesn't matter
they feel like the only person I really
want is this independent candidate who
doesn't have any chance so why do I even
turn out out in this case they have a
reason to turn
out um and like I said increases the
civility in in
politics so um this
particular uh Bill allows for stepped
implementation so it is implemented in
stages so that at any point the
legislature can pull the plug if there's
any problems it uh starts implementation
in 2023 by allowing uh political parties
and municipalities the opin so parties
would be able to use it for their uh
primaries and municipalities would be
able to use it on the municipal level
then in 2025 it would go to Federal
elections those are the bigname
elections that people would really be
able to see uh how this plays out
certainly some party primaries it would
also be very publicized and people could
start seeing how people start to coales
around certain C candidates and then
2027 which is 5 years from now would be
it would be extended to all Statewide
elections so there's plenty of time to
put on the breaks if any of these uh
stages proves to be problematic and I
have spoken for quite a long time so
with that I will open up to any
questions but I do appreciate this
out thank you representative Reed
questions from committee members keeping
in mind that the people as to the
logistics of this implementation are yet
to be
heard representative ter
roian thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking the question I
heard you say in your presentation that
under rank Choice voting it's still you
just vote get one vote but in reality if
you have a ballot with six people on it
you're actually voting six times with
different choices but you're still
voting six times right I it in I don't
know exactly what sentence you're
referring to I think I what I think you
might be referring to me saying it it
does not violate but in fact strengthens
one person one vote but what I did say
is it literally is as if you are going
through several State several different
elections so you are correct you are
voting every voter who casts a ballot is
voting each time in a different election
so you are voting six times but the
point is everybody in that election is
voting six times if there are six
rounds representative Alexander thank
you madam chair thank you representative
um I'm not sure if you can answer it or
somebody behind you can um my question
is regarding voter like compliance I
guess with the system because if you
have like a large group of Voters like
maybe 30% of Voters that are like I hate
rank Choice voting like I'm voting for
my candidate a and I'm not voting for
any other candidates because that's my
candidate so you're you're still not
going to get like like a majority
because that it doesn't get to the 50
plus is it 50% plus one on the first
round of ballots regardless of if
somebody chooses a second third fourth
fifth preference or can they choose the
same person each round of voting thank
you so much for the question it is a
really interesting question um so the
answer is yes while it is absolutely
true so no you cannot choose um the same
person for more than one preference if
your person hasn't been eliminated and
it goes to a second third round you're
still voting for your first preference
right because that person is still your
favorite um just as if you were to go to
a runoff election if the person you
voted for the first time is in the
runoff election you're still voting for
that person right so yes it's true that
a voter who for some reason is like oh
this rank Choice voting stuff is hooa um
they might only fill in their first
preference and that's it um especially
in the early stages the first couple
times but there's literally no reason to
do that strategically they are it is the
same as if they voted in the first
election and their candidate was
eliminated and then they chose not to
show up to the runoff
election if I could follow up thank you
um so that's just assuming that every
voter is a rational voter and they they
want to make sure their preference is
noted in order but I'm asking the 5% of
Voters that might want to vote for just
that one person and their their person
is eliminated in the runoff so then what
you're going to have is out of the total
majority of votes that 5% of vote base
that doesn't pick somebody else and
their candidate was eliminated that's
still making it so there's no majority
on the first like after there's no
majority that makes sense the of the
original so every election is separate
so just as if you were to go to a second
runoff election and 5% of the electorate
who voted in the first election didn't
show up that is their right to not show
up so they are choosing to not have a
voice in that second election um you're
right that some voters might do that we
call that bullet voting um and whereas
bullet voting is a legitimate strategy
in our current system there's absolutely
no strategic voting no reason to even
think about strategic voting in this
system and yes people might do that
initially because they're you know
whatever they feel negatively but I
think as time goes on second third they
realize there's no reason for me to
Bullet vote so yes you're right not
everybody's rational but it is just as
if each runoff round is a separate
runoff
election further questions from the
growan U representative Reed you my
understanding then is that uh no matter
how many candidates there
are the person ranks all those
candidates is that correct uh not if
they don't want to um so my bill in
particular
let's say you have like a really wacky
District or a w wacky race where you've
got 17 30
candidates uh the studies that have been
done have shown that there's no
statistical difference after the 10th
ranking so mine is the number of
candidates if the candidates are like
three four five or 10 whichever is fewer
so you don't end up with these crazy
ballots with 17 columns or 30 columns
the most columns you'll ever have the
most rankings you'll ever ever have are
10 thank
you representative
qua thank you madam chairman and thank
you representative Reed for speaking
with us today if I understood correctly
a little while
ago uh you said that the uh calculations
required for this system of voting are
done by open soft open source software
and everyone can see how it works what
is your estimate of the percentage of
the population the voters and population
in general that's proficient enough at
reading computer code that they actually
can derive how it works from doing that
oh I I don't suppose very many people
are proficient at reading computer code
but that's that's not the point you can
literally see each ballot and of course
it's not identifiable to the voter but
you can see each ballot had a first
preference and a second preference the
ones that had this first preference when
that person was eliminated went to their
second preference and so on uh of course
open source they will be able to also
those who can read uh computer code will
be able to see that as well um but I
would say that even though that's only a
small number of the population literally
zero can understand how our current
machines work because those are literal
um proprietary black boxes no one's
allowed to see how those machines work
um except the company so even saying
okay we're opening up to everyone who
can read computer code is still a huge
Improvement over the situation we have
now where even experts who are
proficient at computer code don't know
what's going on inside the uh the the
voting machines we currently
questions representative Reed I have one
and then I'm looking forward to moving
on to the people who have come in to
testify on this what's a wasted vote
thank you a wasted vote is not to say
that a vote is like oh this person
doesn't matter we're throwing out that
vote their vote doesn't count it means
that the person voted for someone who
could not win so they could have voted
for someone who had the ability to win
but they voted for someone who ended up
with only 3% of the overall vote and if
you had given them the option and said
okay if you know that this candidate
will not be able to win who would you
pick they would pick somebody else and
everyone every single voter has that
same ability in in rank Choice voting so
that's what a wasted vote is it just
means that their vote ended up not
influencing the outcome it means it
doesn't
win well because of not that it just
doesn't win but they didn't have a
chance to
win I understand but you're identifying
the need for rank Choice voting at least
in part because the current system has
wasted votes so given the current system
not rank Choice what is a wasted vote
right a wasted vote is a vote for a
candidate who had no potential to win
because all the votes ended up going
excuse me not all a significant enough
number of votes ended up going to one of
two candidates that the other candidates
did not influence the outcome does that
mean we are characterizing a certain
percentage of our population is simply
wasting their time at the polls no I'm
not trying to to C verion about them
wasting their time at the polls but I do
know many voters do feel like their vote
doesn't matter because no matter who
they want if they wanted some you know
other third party or an independent they
know that their candidate has no chance
of winning and so they get forced into
one of two parties reminds me of
discussions about when you're the last
kid picked for the team representative
Barry so I have a question about our uh
presidential primary which I guess this
would eventually apply to right indeed
so um the parties systems we don't need
to go into great detail of it but when
you go to vote for your first your pick
for first in the nation you're selecting
delegates you're not actually voting for
the person you're voting for delegates
much like when you vote for president
elect you're vot picking electoral
electors to Electoral College um how
does that work now with with are we
creating a system where somebody's going
to come out of the New Hampshire primary
with all of the delegates because rank
Choice voting is going to get into 50%
or no no no no so each party it's 10%
for the Republic party and 15% am I
backwards I think I might be 10 okay
one's 10 one's 15 I thought but there is
a threshold uh above which the candidate
has to get in order to get any delegates
in their primary system so rank Choice
voting doesn't only work to get
candidates up to the 50% threshold it
can also work just to get candidates up
to the 15 or 10% threshold so you would
just run those runoff rounds until all
candidates remaining are above that
threshold
essentially you're coalescing support
amongst the people if you have 20
candidates you're asking them okay who
who do you support and if this person
cannot get above 10% who would you
support next until they have coalesced
all of their support behind candidates
who who reach over
10% there are people that are probably
better explaining this but that's that's
happen I mean I sort of started this by
asking another question because now I
want to say well aren't we talking about
a caucus so I'm going to stop does
anybody have any further questions for
representative Reed and if not thank you
very much and I believe we talked about
uh Tian Coleman speaking
next and I believe that was the person
with the box is that
that
who
all right who would you let I'm sorry
I'm happy to go in order of preference
next I'm sorry I ordered my pink cards
and
her she needs two actually well that's
all right we can deal with that later
file
who who needs that copy raise your
hand that other side do you have you
do we need to share some does everybody
we we're too short because we're going
to need one for the file too and we have
members missing
so right okay all right for the file we
have it in electronic form okay all
right committee members we have um a
handout which is basically slides that
we're going to go through here today
with our um M Coleman from Amhurst New
Hampshire
welcome thank
you thank you for having me today uh my
name is Tiani Coleman and yes I'm a
resident of Amherst New Hampshire and
I'm also president of New Hampshire rank
Choice voting as well as president of
New Hampshire independent
voters I also am an
attorney I uh am licensed here in New
Hampshire as well as in
New York and I'm on inactive status in
Connecticut and as well as uh Utah so I
not practicing very much law at the
moment but I am licensed here in New
Hampshire um so
anyway I sent this out to all of you
early this morning you all have it on
file have it in PDF as well as a link to
it on the web so it's a presentation I'm
not planning to go through all of this
right now that's not what this is about
but I just wanted you to be aware of it
because it very systematically explains
each thing and there's a table of
contents and so if there's a topic that
you have questions about or something
that you want to understand better it
explains it pretty well it's probably a
little bit better in the slide format
but you know hard copy still explains it
pretty well so I don't plan I didn't
really actually plan to come and talk
about each of these things I did want to
clarify a couple of things the
uh this bill does not actually say
anywhere that doesn't use the word
majority it doesn't say anywhere that
somebody has to get a majority in order
to win it just talks about how you're
going to run all of the rounds until you
get a winner and you're going to
eliminate people if they haven't reached
the threshold
and in a in an election where you have a
single winner the threshold is 50%
because it's the number 50% plus one
because it's the number where if someone
reaches it nobody else has a chance to
win it's a mathematical impossibility
for anyone else to win if someone
reaches that threshold of 50% and so
what what the rank Choice voting really
is is it's saying we want to determine a
winner by going going through the full
rounds we want everyone to be able to
express their preferences and we want to
be able to go through all of the rounds
um but it's not necessarily someone said
oh well you're voting six times you're
actually not you're you're what you're
doing is you're expressing your
preferences in case if you need to go to
one of them just like if you send
someone to the ice cream store and you
say I really want you know pistachio ice
cream but a lot of stores don't have
pistachio and so when they go they say
well if they don't have pistachio what
do you want instead and you say well
then I want you know prings and cream
and they're like well if they don't have
that what do you want you're like well I
guess I'll have rocky road well if you
don't have that what do you want okay
I'll let's have vanilla you know but
maybe maybe you'll go there and but if
your favorite ice cream is vanilla then
you're probably going to always find
you're probably going to always find you
know vanilla at the ice cream store but
you still rank them because maybe they
run out of vanilla and you might want
chocolate so you rank them all just in
case if you need to use that ranking but
you may never fall back on that ranking
so we have an example here in these
slides that show how it works but the
way it works is you know they count
everybody's first choice and if somebody
gets that threshold of 50% after they
count all the first choices it's over
the election's over you don't have to
run any rounds you don't have to send
any ballots to the central counting
place it's over somebody already reached
the threshold no one else can win even
if you count all the rest of the rounds
because someone already already won so
they can win on Election night you don't
even have to count them people just
Express their preference in case if it
was needed and so if you count all of
the ballots that night and nobody gets
that preference then you say okay we're
going to eliminate the person in last
and those people were going to count
their second preference because their
candidates been eliminated but everyone
else we're still going to count their
top preference and you just keep doing
that until someone reaches the threshold
now someone asked the question well what
happens if you know nobody gets a
majority because nobody you know because
maybe maybe 5% of the people chose not
to rank all their candidates because
it's true if every single person ranks
all of their candidates then you will
certainly always get a majority when you
use rank Choice voting if everybody
ranks all their candidates but if
everybody doesn't rank all of their
candidates well you probably will still
get a majority because usually the race
isn't quite that close that it comes
down to the last little percentage but
let's say it is that close well then
there are two different ways that you
can you can do it way is to say we
are going to go by everyone one that
voted on the first round and we're going
to and and you know so you just count
until either a someone reaches the
threshold or B all the ballots have been
exhausted and you know then maybe they
won't win by a majority but they still
you still were able to count everybody's
full preferences until the ballots were
exhausted now in some cases people
choose to do it in such a way that they
count it by you know by having the final
by counting each round separately and so
at the end they say okay well we're only
counting the people that voted in the
last round like a typical runoff and so
it's going to be a majority because you
only have two people so there's two
different ways to do it but it doesn't
have to be any certain way just like
Ellen brought up in presidential
primaries you rank you use rank choice
of
voting and you don't have to come to a
majority it's rank Choice voting is just
a way of expressing preferences it
doesn't mean majority it just means a
way of expressing preferences so you can
have you can use rank Choice voting in a
presidential primary and still only
count until you reach the threshold
which in the case of a presidential
primary the threshold is the 10% or the
15% so once all the candidates have that
much you don't count anymore because
you're you're trying to get to that
threshold and it's not about a majority
so there are different ways to do it you
don't have to do it the same way every
time um I I can't can talk about the
Constitutional issues if you have
questions um I wanted to point out a
couple of things because I know there
are a couple of elephants in the room
sometimes so one thing I want everyone
to know is that I um I was introduced to
rank Choice voting when I was chair of
the it wasn't the Utah GOP it was the
Salt Lake County Republican party I was
chair of that um this was two decades
ago actually it was in the early 2000s
and uh we used it in our conventions out
there and that's how I got to know it
and that's how I got to use it and I
liked it a lot and I am now an
independent and I have also run a
campaign before for a
Democrat um and in all of those cases I
I loved rank Choice voting when I was a
staunch DieHard chair of the County
Republican party total Republican I
loved rank Choice voting when I ran the
campaign for a Democrat a a candidate
for congress who was a Democrat I loved
rank Choice voting and now I'm an
independent and I love rank Choice
voting it has nothing to do with what
party I belong to or you know what it
has nothing to do with that because I
just know that it's the best the best
way of selecting a candidate which by
the way I want everyone to know that you
know in my capacity with president of
New Hampshire rank chice voting it's a
complete volunteer position I don't get
paid this has I am not here at all
because I you know am getting paid to do
this or anything like that I I'm doing
this because it's something I care about
and something I think is very important
and I think it will help help our
country be better and it's just a better
way to do elections um do I think that
rank Choice voting is going to solve all
the problems in our country and it's
suddenly going to make everything just
perfect no it's not the the one all be
all and only only reform that we need
but it is definitely an easy reform that
we can Implement that will make a good
difference and it's good for everyone I
like to call it a non-partisan win-win
for everybody it can help every stripe
of person it can help the people that
are in the
establishment it can help the people who
are non-establishment it can help the
people who are in the major party it can
help the people that are in the minor
party help independent third parties it
really helps everyone because it gives
everybody an equal voice and a More
Level Playing Field and it actually is
just a better system overall so that is
why I support rank Choice voting now I
know one of the other elephants in the
room that I never used to hear I was out
talking about rank Choice voting here in
New Hampshire you know I've lived here
now for almost nine years and I've been
talking about it to people almost that
long um and I used to just talk to
people and they were all excited didn't
matter if they were republican or
democrat or who they were they were
really excited about it but
after Paul Quinn lost all of a sudden I
started hearing a lot of people saying
oh that's that's a rigged that's that's
that's a horrible horrible thing we we
should not do that because somehow
people thought well this is that you
know that's just some liberal Democratic
ploy to try to you know take over or
something I'm thinking are you kidding
me like I've been in favor of rank
choy's voting since forever and I got
introduced to it when I was a Republican
so I wanted to point out that in
Maine and it's in these slides you can
see it but there are different scenarios
that can help it happen in a rank Choice
race I already mentioned one of them you
can have someone win on the very first
ballot when they count everyone's first
choice and they get that 50% threshold
and they are the winner and it's exactly
like it it is now no different you can
have a race where somebody is ahead in
the very first ballot and they have 35%
of the vote this so they don't have the
threshold so you run the rounds but
after you run all the rounds and you're
done that person who had 35% of the vote
still wins by the end so the person that
started with 35 ends up getting past the
50% threshold and they win when they're
done they stayed ahead the whole time or
maybe they fell behind for a minute and
then pulled back up whatever happened
but they won so that can happen and then
you can have the case like the golden
and the poliquin race where it was very
close the whole
time and so yes Paul Quinn was ahead in
the first round and yes he did end up
losing because there were two other
independent candidates who were pretty
strong for independent candidates and
their second
Preference they they preferred golden
over poin and something kind of
interesting that I found sorry I'm
looking over there I should look at all
of you
um something kind of interesting that I
found was that I was out actually kind
of promoting rank Choice voting at a
poll and there was someone that was
going to that someone that was actually
running in that election and they didn't
necessarily support rank shows voting
but they came up to me and they said you
know what I want to tell you I want to
admit to you that I really think that
you know it wasn't that what happened in
Maine was not a rigged election I'm I
know what happened I know that they told
everyone to only express one preference
and I also know that Paquin wasn't out
trying to earn the vote of those
Independents he wasn't out trying to get
them to vote for him he he should have
he should have been appealing more to
The Independents so that when they got
knocked out of the race they would have
wanted to vote for him and support him
but he didn't campaign to them and
golden did but what I want all of you to
know is that that could have been
completely the opposite it could could
have been it could have been golden who
started out ahead and Paquin who pulled
ahead of golden and that could happen in
a lot of races and so the point isn't
that rank Choice voting H helps any
certain kind of candidate it doesn't it
doesn't help any certain kind of
candidate the kind of candidate it helps
is the candidate who can get the most
support and isn't that what we want from
elections we want to elect the people
who have the most support we don't want
want people to win by
fluke um one of the examples I have in
here is the Fall River Race in Fall
River Massachusetts I don't know if you
heard about it but there was a mayor
that was
running and he was indicted for tax
fraud I believe it was he was under
indictment and so they had a recall
election and 61% of the voters I believe
it's close to that I think that was what
is they voted to recall him they didn't
want him and it was one of those
elections where on the same ballot as
the recall they also elected who the new
mayor would be if he was recalled so he
was recalled and on that same ballot
people voted for who they wanted and
they had him as one of the names on the
ballot and so everyone voted again and
65% of the voters voted for someone else
they didn't want
him but 35 or 3 35 I think it was voted
for him
again right but the other but the people
who voted against him they all split
their votes between four or five other
candidates and so the other candidates
got a small percentage of the vote and
kareah was elected again to be the mayor
he had just been recalled and he was
elected back in rank Choice voting would
have never allowed that to happen it
would have never happened with rank
Choice voting because we knew that 65%
of the voters did not want him and they
would have gotten a much better result
had they used rank Choice voting in that
election
and that's the way things would happen
in a lot of different races and so I
think you know people should really give
give it a real look give it you know pay
attention to it because it's something
that really is good for
everybody and I think that you would you
would like it so if anyone has any
questions for me um I I do have a whole
section here on on the Constitutional
issues if you want to look at them
um for sure you know I will say that
rank Choice voting has been brought
before federal courts on article one on
the equal protection clause which is the
one person one vote on due process and
free speech on the Voting Rights Act and
it's been upheld every single time and
it's been clearly upheld it's been
upheld unan unanimously in many
occasions it's it's it's really not even
a question when it comes to the US
Constitution and is definitely
constitutional so you know when it comes
to the New Hampshire Constitution there
are some issues that are a little more
complicated and even though
come out I think I think in favor of
rank Choice voting and I have in here
the citation to a uh recent article that
just came out La review article that
just came out in October from two
professors of uh
NYU who have studied that plurality
provision very extensively and they they
make their case very strongly that you
know rank Choice voting is still
constitutional under the plurality
provision if anyone's aware of what I'm
going talking about but
um but even so you know the plurality
provision is is in the Constitution and
it only applies to the race for a
governor for state senate for house
because it mentions it although if you
were to use it for proportional RCV I'm
not sure it would matter anyway um and
for um executive counsel and anyway I
think there's a really strong case that
rank Choice V if you have any more
questions I'll talk more about that but
that and thank you you did all get an
email which has a link to this handout
that you have which within it has got
links to videos and other information
questions representative prudom Brian
thank you very much Madam chairman um
the Fall River case is interesting to me
it sounds like those were very loyal
supporters of of that mayor who was uh
recalled now if there were rank Choice
voting couldn't they vote for that mayor
uh the recalled mayor for their second
choice as well and we that would be the
same
situation they could vote for that same
person as their second choice is that is
that right no uh no you can only vote
for one person for each choice you
cannot vote for the same person for more
than one choice it's like if you go if
you go to an election
and you vote and then they're going to
have a runoff if your candidate didn't
make it into the runoff you can't vote
for them because they're out they're not
they're not they're not in anymore um
but you know if they're in then yeah you
can vote for if you if you vote for them
and they stay in then in rank Choice
voting your vote will always count for
the person who if that you voted for if
they're still in your vote will always
count for them but if they're out then
you can't I have a followup follow up
thank you so if the person did vote in
that manner would that be a a vote that
was
was not counted because it would be hard
to understand what the voter's intent
was would the would the ballot just be
tossed out on that on that race well I
mean it would it' be like if you go to a
runoff election and you vote for someone
who's not on the ballot they're they're
going to toss it they're not going to
count I mean I mean you can do a write
in and you can do a write in on ring
Choice voting as
well but uh
uh but um yeah so I mean you wouldn't
you wouldn't vote for someone that's
been eliminated that they're bought him
now kareah in this case he was the
winner and so you know
what uh if you made him a second
choice that wouldn't have worked because
he wouldn't have been the first person
eliminated he was up near the top he
would have been one of the very last
people eliminated probably would have
been you know he would have made it to
the final two in that case people that
are eliminated are the people that are
getting 5% % of the vote 3% of the vote
10% of the vote not the people that are
getting 35% of the vote they're usually
going to make it to the last round
usually thank you further questions from
the
committee oh I'm sorry representative
Lane uh thank you madam chair I guess I
would like you to speak to the New
Hampshire Constitution the plurality
issue because it has come up when we
reviewed these bills okay uh the
previous session and just to address
that I know it's in here but sure for
the people listening so if you just want
to turn to it real quick um basically
the point on the plurality provision is
that um there's a few different points
about it but if you look at it first it
shows here what it applies to I've
already said that though so um it only
applies to certain
races and what it says is that the
person elected it just says it just says
in a little line it says the person
elected will be elected by a plurality
of the
vote um and so then the question is what
does plurality mean what does that mean
when you say that someone is elected by
a plurality of the vote and if you look
up the word plurality that means whoever
had the most votes right so some people
say well you know it means you know I
mean yes in the in the New Hampshire con
ution like like representative Reed said
that it used to say that people had to
win by majority the
vote and they also said that the
legislators would be um the legislators
would get to pick the candidate so if
you go back and you read what they were
saying when they made that change to the
Constitution and and turned it into that
you could win by a plurality of the vote
the whole reason why they did it was
because they didn't want the legislature
to make the decision it's not because
they didn't want majority to decide it
was obvious that they wanted the
majority to decide but it was causing so
many
problems that they they didn't want the
legislature to keep making that decision
because then it became a very
legislative body was very political and
they had too much power they didn't want
that and so they changed it um and so
they so what they were saying was we're
not going to have a restriction that
someone can't win with a
plurality but rank Choice voting like I
said doesn't doesn't create that
restriction either either there is a
scenario it is technically possible
depending on how you decide to run it
but there is a a a scenario where
someone could win with less than a
majority and nowhere in the bill does it
say someone has to have a majority
doesn't really say that and like I said
it might say yes the threshold is 50%
but that's based on the the fact that
once someone reaches 50% it's
mathematically impossible for anyone
else to win um but also as as it was as
these people are saying that I linked
their their law review article they have
gone through you know every single state
and a lot of States they might not use
the word plurality but they still say
the person with the most votes wins and
uh that's really what it's kind of
talking about and there are three terms
in which in which plurality is used
sometimes it says the plurality the you
have to win by plurality of the vote
meaning you have to have the most votes
there's also the term that is um
plurality winner plurality winners or um
plurality
systems and that's not necessarily the
same thing these terms keep getting used
and so even I mean I even hear people
say it and it makes me cringe because
people inter they they use these terms
and they intermix them but they don't
always mean the exact same thing for
example if someone wins with the
plurality of the vote mean or not a
plurality of the vote but if someone
wins with just a plurality
percentage you know that then yes if
someone WS at a plurality percentage
that definitely means they won with less
than 50% of the vote but you know we
have elections all the time where people
win with 50% of the vote and that
doesn't mean that you know it's
unconstitutional like obviously you're
trying to get someone that wins with 50%
of the vote um so it's not you know
these terms get used in different ways
um now in the bill it does specifically
say that you know rank Choice voting is
the method by which a plurality will be
determined and um and also you know it's
the idea that in the rank chose election
it's one ballot everyone goes and
everyone votes on one ballot they're not
voting on you know multiple BS yes they
are expressing their
preferences but all of those preferences
aren't going to be counted if your if
your person's still in the race or if
someone wins on the first round and all
that it's just one ballot it's one vote
vote it's one
election and so you're just saying look
we're not going to be at the end of the
election till we finish counting the
rounds or or someone's already reached
the threshold and become the winner and
so it's similar to saying oh we're going
to declare the winner you know before
you've counted all the precincts half
the precincts have come in and we
counted them and they have the most
votes and so they won because they have
the most votes it's like wait a minute
finish the election finish counting all
the other precincts
and that's what this is this is we're
saying wait a minute you can't declare
the winner after the first round you
have to finish the election this is a
rank Choice election you have to finish
it but that doesn't mean it violates the
plurality provision now yes we all maybe
we don't all know but some some of you
know that the Maine Supreme Court did
have a an advisory opinion where Maine
had a similar provision and yes the main
Supreme Court did say in their advisory
opinion that they thought that that was
unconstitutional now um that was an
advisory opinion it was never decided on
the merits the the people from Maine
decided to just drop those races because
you know they had they had an election
to win and they just didn't want to be
dealing with all that so when they they
dropped their state races so in Maine
they elect they use rank Choice voting
for all of their primaries they use it
for their Federal elections meaning
their elections for governor
and US Senate and US Congress and
President they use it for those because
those are under the Federal Constitution
and there's no problem up there but they
don't use it in their general elections
for governor even though they want to
but that's not because that's not
because it was declared unconstitutional
because it was not a final opinion it
was just an advisory but they chose to
take it off of their ballot measure they
chose to take it off of their ballot
measure just to not deal with just so
they didn't have to deal with it
um but nonetheless main opinions are not
binding on us anyway so that advisory
opinion is not actually binding
precedent on Maine and it's certainly
not binding precedent on
the I'm going to ask that answers really
be directed specifically to the
questions and I'm going to ask members
to ask please specific questions I
apologize for my scheduling and and
maybe I the sponsor spoke for very long
time on this but we have people who um
are here to speak and I and I want to
try and make sure that we're getting to
specific points um because I think we
handled the concept initially so are
there other questions for this
witness representative Barry um so I'm
I'm glad you brought up the main um
unanimous decision or advisory opinion
um are you aware that the language in
the main Constitution is identical to
the language in the the New Hampshire
state constitution a by a plurality of
votes it's literally the same language
same language it's not um it's not
exactly the same thing but yes it's very
similar yes it is and and like I said
there is that law review article where
they go through every single state and
all all of the legislative histories and
everything else and they do come out
with the conclusion that Maine was wrong
and I agree with them at least I I think
they should be wrong but yes it is it is
an issue I'm not saying you know it's
not a slam dunk like the US Constitution
the US Constitution is a slam dunk
people who say that rank Choice voting
violates the US Constitution I'm sorry I
I think they're wrong because way too
many decisions have been made that said
it does not on this case there are no op
well actually there is a Massachusetts
opinion that I cite in here where they
said it's fine but it is slightly
different but it's it's pretty similar
and they say it's fine um but in Maine
like I said it's not a binding decision
so the truth is is the courts have hav
haven't toed on it there are a lot of
really good attorneys who think it
really should have been const that it is
constitutional and that main made the
wrong decision but I can't
guarantee that some Court wouldn't say
that it's unconstitutional I don't think
it should be I think the legislative
intent would clearly if the people here
in the legisl the people that made that
amendment that changed it to plurality
if they discovered rank Choice voting
they'd be like oh boom that's exactly
what we should be doing I think because
that's what they wanted but you know
further
questions representative ter Roan thank
you madam speaker thank you man for
taking the question so to just follow up
um it's it's not a foregone conclusion
that our Supreme Court would would not
vote differently than what Maine did we
don't know that answer would that be
correct we don't know positively no we
don't um but also that like Mr Reed said
you know you know this bill does have
the implementation in such a way that it
won't that provision will not affect
this bill clear until 2027 that's a
really long time and it's time to sort
it out and figure it out um and it it
wouldn't affect the other bill but we
won't talk about that but it wouldn't
questions seeing none thank you and I
assume if the committee members
individually reach out to you by email
with questions you'd be happy to answer
yes thank you so much thank you very
much
um next I have Emily
cook I understand that there are people
who are not going to be able to stay to
testify um the sponsor had asked me to
have people who have come here to speak
um in a particular order and I'm
honoring that request um if I do not
reach you before the end of the hearing
and it does happen in in hearings um in
every committee here um I just ask that
you please sign the blue sheet on your
um way out so we know your opinion and
if you have written testimony um that
has not been received yet by the
committee you can give it to someone at
the end of the table on your way out and
we'll pass it up to the clerk and make
sure everybody has it and you can
continue to contact the committee uh via
the the web portal um and email so with
that
welcome thank you um good morning to the
sure is that better okay good morning
I'm Emily cook deputy secretary of state
and director of communications for the
main Secretary of State I've come to
conquer today to speak um about rank
Choice voting I put just one of the bill
numbers on but you can take this for
both um as you miss cook I note that on
the pink card you said you have written
testimony do you have written testimony
yes I I believe that was given out
before when we were so let's I that's
what I thought so so what does it look
like it is mostly black and white with a
little bit of blue on the bottom with
the main seal on the top left okay
everybody got
it the chair doesn't but you should all
it's okay we'll get it there my clerk
has got one I have I have a couple
that's fine and you can leave extras
here okay all right thank you all right
go ahead no problem um as you are
definitely aware um given the last two
uh presentations main recently
instituted rank Choice voting for a
number of our elections all primary
elections general elections for federal
Offices and some Municipal level
elections due to a Supreme Judicial
Court advisory opinion um that was
issued shortly after RCV first became
law it is not used for gubernatorial or
legislative general elections at this
time we first passed RCV through a
citizen initiative process requiring a
Statewide vote in 2016 Main voters again
then stated their preference for RCV in
another Statewide vote in 2018 when at
the same time they were using RCV for
the first time we have found in the
years since that voters appreciate the
option to rank their candidates on their
ballots and that they found it easy to
vote in this manner after all we rank
our choices on all sorts of things every
day what we'll be making for dinner for
our families uh what music to put on on
the radio what to watch on where to go
on vacation what to put on TV um so
implementing that same decision-making
process for voting uh was not very
difficult we also feel that voters
appreciate the option to vote their
heart on their ballots rather than
having to stress and worry that voting
for their favorite candidate in a
plurality election may end up helping
their least favorite candidate win voter
frustration that plal voting doesn't
always reflect the will of the majority
uh who may be split between two similar
candidates who advance to the general
election is one of the reasons that main
voters chose
RCV voters should feel and know that
their vote matters and that the
elections they participate in results in
representation that mirrors the
electorate on the election
Administration side uh we have not found
undue difficulty in conducting elections
voter education and instructions on
ballot markings are always part of any
election uh that's still the case with
RCV it's just that the instructions and
the educations themselves are new um I
know the Secretary of State's office um
when we were first implementing this
worked with nonprofits um the committee
on rank Choice voting and the
nonpartisan League of Women Voters of
Maine to conduct uh more extensive voter
education than is typically done ahead
of an election um but those groups work
together and in a very
nonpartisan uh way to educate voters
about how they would be what they'd be
seeing on their ballots and how they'd
be marking them um as with any election
being upfront and honest with voters
about when they can expect to hear
results um perhaps it's a few days after
election day rather than on Election
night as they might be used to is a
vital part of voter confidence in
elections should New Hampshire choose to
go the route of rank Choice voting um
our elections division staff would be
more than happy to provide assistance
and guidance on best practices and
things we've learned to help with a
smooth
implementation and uh thank you for the
opportunity to be here and I'd be happy
to answer any
questions thank you questions
representative ter roian thank you madam
chair thank you deputy secretary for
taking the question we've heard
testimony today that um rank Choice
voting can often help third party
candidates since you've had it in um use
has M voted in more third party
before I don't have the data in front of
me I know our legislature has a number
of unenrolled um or and a couple Third
Party U members but again our
legislature general elections don't use
um rank Choice voting so that that isn't
um that doesn't have an impact there I'd
be happy to get you any any numbers I
don't think think for the N the for the
elections that we have used it
for we have not seen unenrolled or third
party candidates win in those elections
yet but it's only been a few Cycles
followup um so a followup question would
be so if that's not the case
um has it more than one time flipped um
one party that would have won Under the
plur plurality um wi after you went
through it second or third
round yeah so I think it's good to be
cautious on trying
to figure out what would have happened
in any given election under different
voting roles um we have seen in that
first um second congressional district
race that the results were
flipped or not that they were flipped
but that someone who was not the leading
candidate in the first round ended up
being the winning candidate in the end
because we don't know what voters would
have done under a different electoral
system
um you just can't run a hypothetical in
that way because I think each side would
argue that their candidate would have
won any election that's that's typically
what happens we all want we all would do
that thank you representative Barry what
was the precipice for Maine going with
this system it it wasn't just organic
somebody thought of this there was a
trigger what what what caused it what
was the what was the reason why they
broke you know two nearly 200 years of
of the same system what caused it yeah
so um different bills for rank Choice
voting uh were introduced in the
legislature between 2001 and
2013 um and were repeatedly uh voted
down so in 20 you say 2013 between 2001
and 2013 um it had been introduced a
number of times um and like I said
didn't pass so in 2014 proponents um led
by the committee on rank Choice voting
started Gathering signatures under our
citizen
initiative um constitutional provision
to bring it to the voters themselves and
that was that process was the trigger to
uh get it first passed into law follow
up um what is the um what is the ease of
access for third party or independent
candidates what's the ballot access
Provisions for non- major party
candidates in
main so if you want to run
our our party access numbers are the
same uh we have signature requirements
of different numbers for each uh
depending on the office that you're
running for 25 signatures for a house
race um couple thousand for
um Governor um and then unenrolled
candidates uh have double the number of
signatures but a longer amount of time
um since they are not running in a
primary further questions representative
growan thank you madam chair and thank
you uh Miss cook for taking my question
uh we heard testimony earlier that the
implementation of this cost Main in the
low six figures I believe it was
um that seems very low to me uh how how
do you implement this in Maine and uh
and you know it's done I assume it's
done at the Secretary of State's office
how do you implement it yeah so um I I
looked up the numbers sadly after ID
already printed off my testimony but I'd
be happy to um send them to you all so
you can review we already have
tabulators for most of our towns um some
of them are still hand count towns we
don't think a municipality with five
voters um is incapable of counting those
five votes accurately themselves um so
that was not a cost that we needed to
incur um so our startup costs um
29231 for a highspeed tabulator software
upgrades and some
computers in the June 2018 primary for
Courier Services tabulator and software
use 72,2 200 same number for our
November 2018 General the July 2020
primary Ary um for the same Career
Services tabulator in use was 67
67,800 and the November 2020 General um
no longer needed Courier Service um so
that was 38,000 for the tabulator and
software use so for each of those bullet
points uh we're in the tens of
thousands further questions
representative growan so the in your
case the the votes come in
um do do paper ballots come into the
Secretary of State and then and then you
comp them in a high-s speed tabulator
yeah sorry I forgot to um address the
second part of your question so for the
towns that have a tabulator those uh
memory sticks come to Augusta for the
towns that are hand count the um paper
ballots come in and we run them through
the highspeed tabulator um and then run
the rankings from from there so sounds
like it would have been similar from
what I heard earlier the first rankings
are counted at the Town level um just
like every election if it needs to go to
a rank Choice that's when the ballots
come to ballots or the memory sticks
come to
Augusta thank you further
questions question from the chair how
many polling places does Main have that
are involved in the elections that use
the right choice voting uh so we have
500 or so municipalities um and our
Statewide elections are all and federal
elections are all municipally run so we
have 500 different dat points
municipalities yeah
okay further
questions representative ter Roan thank
you madam chair thanks again for taking
the question since you implemented rank
Choice voting what's the timetable from
when the close of the election to when
you get your
results I believe they've all been run
within that that same week um like I
think someone said me's a large State
especially for New England um so getting
those memory sticks and ballots securely
to Augusta with the um chain of custody
is is important and taking the time to
do that right um but also do it
efficiently for a rank choice tabulation
for a legislative primary I think we've
run those maybe on the Thursday I
believe and I I'll double check on that
I think it was on a Friday for um the
Congressional one but again I can get
that to you further questions
representative prud home
O'Brien thank you madam chair so you say
the results come in in that same week
what was it prior to rank Choice voting
when were the results out uh we count uh
municipalities are required to count the
ballots on Election night um and then
they have two days to report their
results to the Secretary of State's
office
um so I think most of the results are
pretty publicly available on Election
night um but depending
on not everyone transmits their results
to us that night they have the next day
or the day after and the Press isn't
always in the the towns with only 100
voters to to get those numbers out to
their readers follow Madam chair so my
thank you and thank you for being here I
didn't say that at first
but what you're saying then is that with
rank when rank Choice voting was
implemented in your state the amount of
time was extended there's it took longer
to get the results in for the for the
you know the people of the community to
know what the results were it took
longer and would that
be uh you said it went from two days to
the same week so is that up to five days
longer it's
taking I think to get the full results
if there isn't um someone with a a
majority in that first round it can take
a little longer but the same thing
happens if there's the need for a
recount um you don't know what the
result so we have up to five days for
someone to request a recount so if you
have a really close election and
someone's deciding whether or not to
request a recount you wouldn't have the
final results of that election either
for a few days so it's kind of comes out
in the wash I have a followup Madam
follow a follow thank thank you a
recount is totally different a recount
is not the same as what generally is
happening in community so uh in general
for those 500 different municipalities
the length of time has been extended
forget about recounts that's a different
issue so is that correct for me to say
to me to think that this would extend
the time that the results come in am I
correct in
that uh so the initial results still
have to come into US within two days and
that's when we're going and getting the
ballots or having them couriered to
Augusta um our legislators aren't sworn
in until December and members of or
members of Congress aren't sworn in
until January so there is time to make
sure that we get that right and that the
will of the voters is is accurately
documented thank you representative
Lane thank you madam chair and thank you
for coming from Augusta um following up
on um the previous uh Representatives
questions was there any sufficient
backlash or brewhaha because the
elections got delayed a few days
um I think we um were the center of
attention because we were one of the um
outstanding races um especially in 2018
uh which was fun um The Secret secary at
that time and his
staff did a Facebook live which then in
2018 was new and different for everyone
um showing the running of the
tabulation um which I think helped
voters understand really what was
happening because they could from
wherever they were around the state um
watch what was going on in Augusta to to
questions all right I'm not seeing any
thank you very much for coming thank you
me also signed up to speak on this bill
is Phil
steel from Portland Maine welcome Mr
steel and you have handouts right I have
two one for this bill and no both both
on this bill one is from me personally
and other is
from Adam just and
myself okay so I think we have passed
those out right yeah those those those
would have been passed out early all
right there's one that looks like this
that is my name is pH steel right that's
my personal one and there's also one
that starts off representative Barbara
Griff and that looks like this that
right they're both three pages and I'm
going to uh
dwell mostly on mine but there is some
data on the second page which you might
be interested in and uh I'd like to
introduce myself by
saying uh I live in Portland
Maine uh and I have been an advocate and
researcher for rank Choice voting for 10
years and thank you for all the
questions that you have addressed to all
the other people who've testified I
actually have direct answers to almost
all of them if I had the time I would uh
address them but I I did want to before
I get into my stuff I wanted to make one
point that was said earlier and address
the question from over here which is
what has been the effect of rank Choice
voting in terms of Elections
okay and
um Tiana made the point that rank Choice
voting is good for all
parties whether Democrat
Republican or independent green
libertarian or whatever and that is
true and I'd like to explain why it's
true because one of the biggest
criticisms in
Maine was from Democrats and Republicans
that rank Choice voting would be bad for
their parties it would in fact create
more interest in other
parties
so the reason that that's not true that
that criticism is not true is the
following when you have rank Choice
voting
elections nine out of 10 times and this
is all over the world nine out of 10
times the person who gets the most votes
in the first
round wins the election
ultimately right we're not talking about
the times when the person gets more than
50% throw those aside we're talking
about the elections where it goes into
another
round nine out of 10 times the person
who gets the most votes whether they are
Republican or Democrat and they're
always Republican Or
democrats nine out of 10 times they win
the
election so why do you have rank Choice
voting well think about it the reason
it's good for the Republicans and
Democrats is that if they won by
plurality they don't really have a
mandate
they don't have a mandate more people
voted against them than voted for them
in regular plurality election in a rank
Choice voting election they can take
office and do take office with a
mandate they got more than 50% of the
votes so it's good for republicans and
Democrats it's actually better for them
than for The Independents and the greens
to answer the question no The
Independents and the greens have not won
any rank Choice voting elections in
Maine since it
was
implemented what's good for them is that
the depth of
their
support is shown in a rank Choice voting
election because if you're a green
supporter or a libertarian going to vote
in a normal election if you vote you
know your candidate isn't going to win
and so that in theory is a wasted vote
it's not a wasted vote they get to vote
for the party that they they most
support but what will happen is there
will be a number of green people or
Libertarians who go to the polls and say
well wait a minute my my support doesn't
matter so I'll vote vote for a
Republican or Democrat because I think
they you know well in a rank Choice
voting they get to vote for their
Greener libertarian party and that will
show up and I'm going to show you how it
shows up which is your question uh it
will show up in the
results and that's good for the
Libertarians because the Libertarians
who might otherwise get 1% of the vote
in a rank Choice voting election in the
first round that libertarian candidate
who's not going to win but he may get 5%
or 10% and they're going to feel good
and when they go to their supporters
they say look here's our support in the
state so that's why it's good for all
parties the re the the the results show
the depth of support and for
the non- major parties and for the major
parties it will give them a mandate that
they would not not otherwise have to
implement their policies in you know in
the state so that's that's a a critical
thing now if
you and I want to address one other uh
thing uh I should say that I want you to
know I work for the as a volunteer I
have never been paid 10 years time I do
not get paid for my opinions or my work
welcome to the $100 for twoe there you
go uh and uh and I I first got exposed
to rank Choice voting in
2011 when it was implemented for the
mayor's race in Portland there were 15
candidates on the ballot right and I
studied the results in the same way that
I've studied the results in all of the
Statewide
main
elections um and what you see is that
more more candidates on the ballot the
rank more people on the ballot the more
people will rank I say you you know you
think about it it's just makes sense and
that's in fact what you see
happen do people rank all of the
candidates no they do not have to and
relatively few of them do and the more
candidates there are the less people
will rank all of them okay but here's
remember in all rank Choice voting
elections no matter how many can who
ballot wins 90% of the time the person
who is
second on the ballot meaning second in
the first place votes wins
[Music]
99.9% of the
time
99.9% of rank Choice voting elections go
to either the first person who gets the
most votes in the first round or the
person who gets the most votes in the
second
round one tenth of 1% go to the person
who gets the third most
votes that's it if you
mathematically
it
doesn't work that way okay just doesn't
work so does somebody and one of the
criticisms of rank CH voting is well
somebody who's you know's not very
popular doesn't have a lot of people who
really like him him or her but ends up
with you know a lot of votes in the out
rounds it just doesn't happen okay all
right so I want to show if you take my
testimony which is the one says my name
is Phil steel and look at the third page
this is really interesting and I'd be
willing to bet most of you have never
seen this
um this is what's called the cast vote
record this is
produced by the Secretary of State's
office at the top of this page and what
this is
is and uh to answer the question how
does the public find out about what
happened in election right 90,000 voters
for in this District this is November of
2018 this is the one where pin got the
most votes in the first round and lost
in the second round actually lost in the
third round uh but four candidates three
rounds uh golden one in the third round
okay now this is what the secretary of
state provides the public if you ask for
it you can see every voter and how they
voted how how they filled out their
ballot and you'll see number one voter
number one
undervote
they didn't fill out a name in that
column so the first voter here V ranked
Bruce poliquin number one number two and
number
three technically a violation of the
rules which say you can only rank a
candidate
once all right and this is important the
rule say you can only rank a candidate
once this guy voted this person voted
for him three times voted for him three
times he ranked them three times okay
that vote the way the votes are
counted number one is exactly the same
as number
two who ranked Paquin first and didn't
rank anybody else okay voter number
one's ballot was filled out differently
than voter number
two they preferred Bruce poliquin to all
other candidates and that is how the
vote is
counted by the
software all right and you can see the
other on I want I want to address number
six they did not vote that person voter
number six did not vote for anybody in
the congressional district number two
race they probably voted for other
candidates in other races that otherwise
they wouldn't have gone to the polls
right but they didn't have a preference
in Congressional District number one
okay so you can see how these voters
voted now
see in the first round if you look at
the first choices you'll see that
there's four people who voted for
poliquin there's two people who voted
for Golden there's two people who voted
for and there's one person who
voted for Bond now again there's
actually 290,000 voters I just took the
first
10 all right and and I'm showing you how
the vote are counted this is literally
how the votes are counted so there's 4
221 at the end of the first round poin
is
ahead but he doesn't have a
majority he doesn't have
50%
so it goes to a second round and they
drop
Bond Tiffany Bond candidate number 10
that vote is now they look at the second
choice for that person that's golden so
you can see in the second round golden
has gone from two to three and bond is
no longer in the
race all
right uh Paquin is still ahead but he
majority so it goes to the third round
right and now is the least has
only got two votes so those votes are
dropped and
that's and if you look that's person
five who voted for
first and nine who voted for
first and so they go to the second votes
and so that's
poliquin and
uh poliquin gets one of the votes but
number nine voted for Tiffany Bond
second
but she's already out of the race so in
that case they go to the third
choice and that's poin so in the third
round poliquin now has
six votes and golden has three and if it
this was the election for these 10
people Paquin would have
won in the third round he there is no
somebody who
bullets their ballot which is the one
where somebody ask where somebody votes
for the same candidate first second
third fourth or however many there
are that is not counted any differently
than the person who votes for that
person wants and doesn't vote for any
other that person has
one
vote in each round and it's their vote
stays with the person that they voted
for in the first round as long as that
person is still in the race that's the
way rank Choice voting works now I W to
uh I want to just mention that I spent a
lot of
time educating voters about how rank
Choice voting works
and that's what my testimony on the
first two pages of this is about and uh
uh and it's really really
interesting and um so I want to speak
about if you get down to the bottom of
the first page I have three major
observations about that as both an
educator somebody who went out and talk
to people about rank Choice voting and
as a data analyst right the first first
point here at the conceptual
level nobody has any trouble with what
rank Choice voting is all about they
understand that RCV gives you an
opportunity to express your preferences
ah candidate Smith is my first choice
candidate Jones is my second
choice Etc or I don't like any anybody
except candidate
Smith or I like Smith and Jones but I
don't like Herbert and whatever that's
what rank Choice voting gives you the
opportunity to
do and the data fact is that the vast
majority of main voters when given the
opportunity rank candidates the more
candidates on the ballot the more
they'll
rank uh and and and you can see the
actual results of that if you look at
page two in
the testimony of Adam and
myself uh uh he wrote the first part he
couldn't come today and I wrote the
second part with the data um you know 70
70 80% 90% depending on which election
people rank more than one candidate
thank you Mr steel
um when we have pin cards we ask people
to estimate how long they're going to
speak and we're way over your five
minutes okay um and I just want to make
sure because my goal is to try to get
through these rank Choice bills by 1230
or close to there and then break for
lunch to start the afternoon bills
because I think the and I we have an
awful lot of people to testim to testify
and I'm not sure that we're going to be
able to do I will say that I I thought
your that the count thing that you gave
us was very helpful so I just want to
make one other one other point yeah
which is point number two okay and this
is two very quick points one is people
understand conceptually rank Choice
voting very quickly and when given look
ballot they understand the ballot First
Choice second choice third choice it's
easy the data shows on the second point
that the number of people who do not
fill out their ballot in a way that
their votes are counted correctly in the
system is very small 21 of
1% fill out the ballot wrong so that
their votes cannot be
counted and that two10 of 1% is what you
will find in most general elections non
rank Choice voting elections very close
to the same number so people do not have
trouble filling out the Ballance what
people do have trouble with is
understanding how the votes are counted
just like you're trying to figure out
how the votes are counted right and
unless you're taking through through an
example like I took you
through you know you're not really going
to understand it but that's okay because
the software does it
correctly all right and votes do get
counted at least in Maine and I've
looked at the cast vote records of the
third of the three rank Choice voting
Statewide elections uh and as is
documented here in my testimony I thank
you for uh you um if anybody had
questions I'd be happy to answer them
but to the extent that you do have
afterwards so thank you very much
committee members questions for Mr steel
before he retreats to the back room and
during break I'm sure people will be
around if you want to ask questions but
thank you I thought that written
material was very helpful anybody well
set okay um also signed up to speak I
have Austin Matt
matte
he had to
leave um all right and Mr Matt had
handouts for people um on this bill
which I will do during the break um he's
okay also signed up to oh Rick yames had
to had to leave
right yep he's
C Alvin says he has a handout and three
minutes Alvin has been before this
committee before so he knows the timer
is about to
start Alvin if you just want to pass
those out a few if you have a
handout okay I have one hand out here
and all right we're going to put that in
the record you don't have copies I have
I have a copy for you okay all
here we're on
1482 right and I had uh I I did have a
quick question are we only talking about
this one bill or all three of them
together it it's it's easier to just do
it on the bill that we're talking about
I'm going to recognize representative
okay can you wait three minutes I'm I'm
timing him I prom he knows so all right
go uh for the record I'm Alvin C Liv
lden and I am opposed to the bill I
think there are several issues to to be
concerned about on this bill uh in spite
of testimony earlier I still think there
may be a
legal uh challenge that may not pass
dealing with our
constitution requiring uh plurality of
votes for uh Governor counselor and
Senator and uh just as an aside
this
uh committee researchers report on the
second page that uh says state
representatives
are uh to be blur out vote but not in
our constitution it's the
counselor not the state representative
which handout were you referring to
Alvin uh this was one that I saw over
there it's it's uh addressed to you from
uh Christina
Dyer okay um
oh it's it's our it's our committee
researcher work okay thank you on the
second page in the Box the middle
paragraph
Okay
um I think this bill would require
extensive training for voters and
election officials uh I think it was
oversimplified as in previous
testimony um with with uh this bill all
the acuo machines in the state become
obsolete and have to be replaced there's
a fiscal note
that um shows about $4 and a half
million
dollar uh to replace all that but that
fiscal note does not identify the
central processing equipment and the
training and programming that goes with
that um and also just as a and aside
there are two bills come this afternoon
that would eliminate ballot counting
machines and uh for people who are
skeptical of computers and electronic
devices uh this is not the system
because it requires much more computer
processing transfer of data from various
polling places to a central location and
such so I recommendation of itl on this
Bill thank you very much and I'll answer
questions questions for Mr
C I'm seeing none thank you okay you
were very accommodating to my time
request so thank you thank
and
next is what's the name of the next
person
on oh thank you okay sorry right in
front of me um Charlie wheen from
Handover thank you I will be brief I
teach public policy at Dartmouth College
and I'm the founding chair of United
America which is a group that works on
process reforms around the country to
try and promote a healing of our
partisanship since I assume I'm not
under oath if I'm asked if I've ever met
Professor Mirad I will deny
[Laughter]
it I just have four quick points to make
the first is and many of them are going
to put a finer point on things that
you've already heard R Choice vote
better expresses the collective will of
the electorate than first pass the post
and I'm going to give you two not
uncommon examples that I think make that
point the first is a three-way race and
let's call them candidates a b and X
where A and B are relatively mainstream
candidates and in a head-to-head race a
beats B 52 to 48 it's very clear that
this is the candidate preferred by the
state's voters now we introdu cand
introduced candidate X who draws just 5%
of the vote has no chance of getting
elected and the chair used the term
wasted vote I'm going to use the the
term spoiler because it's not just that
folks who vote for X have no chance of
electing X it's that it then distorts
the outcome between a and b and it is
not
oncommon that all of x's votes come from
one candidate or the other because these
even if they're Independents they tend
to be outside of the mainstream so it's
not unreasonable that candidate X might
be a super Progressive candidate who
draws all of his or her votes from the
Democrat or a Libertarian candidate who
Republican but the net effect is if all
5% come from candidate a b now wins
5847 which is not consistent with what
the state's voters want that is a
problem with our current system that is
solved by rank Choice a related problem
is a crowded field particularly in a
primary election or an open municipal
election where you may have six or seven
candidates one of whom maybe has
25% support but no depth beyond that
most voters would prefer perhaps one of
four or five other candidates who are
broadly similar the votes get spread
among those similar candidates and the
candidate with just
25% wins even though that candidate
would have lost a head-to-head race with
many of the other candidates in the
field so in both of those cases the
current system distorts the preferences
of Voters that's number one is this is a
system that better measures what the
electorate wants number two which is
that has been hinted at but I think is
more important and deserves a little
attention is rank Choice voting leads to
more civil
races and the reason should be obvious
which is if I'm running against Russ
whom I've never met right I want those
folks who are going to vote for Russ I
want to be their second choice so I
might say okay he's you know I don't
think you should vote for him but if you
do know that I also care about these
things that he cares about and one
measure of whether Independents are
helped by this rank Choice voting is not
just whether they win more often or even
if they get more a higher percentage of
the vote because they're still losing
it's the degree to which they can tell
the electorate about things they care
about and that mainstream candidates
adopt those ideas perhaps even co-opt
them in the effort of being the second
choice for those voters so it is a way
by which candidates who might not be
able to win can still have their ideas
radiated out into the public and adopted
by the candidates who do win number
three and this is one where I think
since we're looking at United America at
the nation I just want to express that
rank choice is already popular it is
growing quite quickly and it tends to be
popular with voters so you've heard
about Maine you heard a little bit about
Alaska but that was passed by popular
referendum in 2020 all federal and state
elections will be RCV Wyoming Kansas and
Nevada use RCV for presidential
primaries Indiana Virginia and Utah use
it for party conventions it is very
popular at the municipal level I think
23 cities in Utah alone five more passed
it in 2020 by referendum and then of
course famously New York City in 2021
which we haven't talked about so in data
from New York City 95% of New York City
voters described the RCV ballot as
simple to complete 77 said 77% said they
would use it in future elections and I
will give you this written testimony
afterwards there are also some studies
that I've cited that people describe
mayoral races with RCB as more civil
there was a poll in Santa Fe in 2018
where 68% of Voters said that the quote
the tone of their first mayoral election
with RCV was more more positive than
prior mayoral elections and then the
last point is despite the startup costs
which are non-significant or which are
non-trivial it saves
money by preventing or by making
unnecessary runoff elections I think
this is particularly important for the
second Bill you're going to discuss for
municipalities because it is effectively
an instant runoff in New York City
obviously much bigger than any City in
Maine but they did save $20 million by
not having to have a runoff of election
so it's a better way of measuring the
electorates will it it will encourage
more civil elections people like it once
they've done it and it will save money
in the long run thank
you thank you
questions for Mr
wheelen I have a
question you mentioned its
popularity
in state party elections and primaries
and certainly if you look at
the the list of where it's used that's
used isn't the core voter base in those
elections more aligned to begin with
from an ideological standpoint thereby
making any sort of
runoff and I don't think it is the same
as a runoff but making any sort of
ranking more palatable to the ranker
than it would be in a
multi-party or ideological race it could
be it's certainly true with primaries
you're going to see only a truncated
part of the the electorate and that's
why it does make sense but it's also
true that a Municipal elections I would
assume you're seeing kind of a
relatively broad spectrum of what people
might want New York city mayor race it
was mostly about the primary I think to
your point uh I I think because it
solves that spoiler problem with
Independence though I think it's a it's
a logical time to make that leap and in
Maine one of the reasons one of the many
impetuses for the popularity of that
referendum was that they had had an
independent governor and in that
gubernatorial race with three all viable
candidates the first post that first
past the post system really messed up
priorities so it was actually their
general election with a republican an
independent incumbent and a Democrat
that people said I can't use the current
system and make a sane choice in this
election so I I think your point is well
taken but I'm not sure that means that
it's inappropriate then for general
elections thank you any other questions
representative mhan good to meet you yes
representative Morehead is it a is this
a
I I would have thought at first sight
that this is the kind of thing that
liberals like it's just kind of like a
complicated do gooder thing that appeals
to to those of us who are liberals and
uh but listening to your examples I hear
Utah I hear Kansas when I think about
just running it through history I think
wow in in 92 George HW Bush probably
would have beat Clinton because the
spoiler effect of Ross perau wouldn't
have benefited Clinton so it could you
know could benefit Republicans could
Democrats um so I just wanted you invite
you to comment on the partisan aspect of
this this is this a truly nonpartisan
idea it is truly nonpartisan now in any
particular race it may have it may
benefit one party or the other because
it depends on who the independent might
be it depends how the people look in the
field relative to one another but
there's nothing methodologically about
it at all that favors one party or the
other and in fact if you project out our
current partisan environment God
forbid you can certainly imagine a
scenario where if I want to win wearing
team Jersey blue or team jersey red I'm
going to start running Independence you
know who look like you strategically you
know I'm going to fund the guy who is to
the right of you if you're a republican
I'm gonna fund the person who's to the
left of a Democrat I mean our current
system is prone to hacking in that
regard by either party or by anybody who
wants to use try not to use the word
hacking in New Hampshire oh yes yes
thank you try try try uh so it it is not
inherently ideological and I fail to
mention I'm old enough to remember
horsejack so thank you for that
reference but my first job in politics
was writing speeches for the governor of
Maine John mcer and he ran for
re-election in a he's a republican ran
for election with an independent who got
like seven or eight percent now mccon
was reelected but only with like 43% of
the vote and it was the independent
completely messed up both the campaign
the winner MC in that case didn't have
majority support so yes short answer is
it can affect either party depending on
the circumstances and I think that's a
really important consideration thank you
further
questions seeing none thank you very
much also signed up to speak is a
Stephen
burn
bo
b sorry about that standing up and
writing on a
clipboard and you have written test yes
it was emailed last night and I handed
out some hard copies I didn't print one
for everyone I apologize thank you all
right I go quickly to make up time how's
that terrific okay if you look at the
Secretary of States um September one
numbers 37% of registered voters are
Undeclared you hear a lot that us
Undeclared voters are really Republicans
Or democrats well that might have been
true a number of years ago but with the
polarization um of both parties we're
not very happy at all um we want more
and better choices do you know how
frustrating it is is to go make the time
and the effort to go to the primaries
and vote just to find out that the
person that won is somebody that 70% of
us wanted somebody else because the
person with 30% won that's not a
majority when most the most people would
prefer anybody but that candidate my
town in
2022 has three elections you look at the
clerk's budget it's 32,000 yes that's up
a lot historically but I think it's the
same everywhere where that doesn't
include the police details fire details
the DPW setting it up or the fact that
there won't be school that day all right
if we just round down and call it
$10,000 there's 326 polling places in
New Hampshire that's $3.3 million and
that's just what the towns pay or the
cities do you does anyone here know what
the Secretary of State's office pays for
a presidential primary I I don't know
does anyone have that number no continue
please we we should good to have I've
asked a number of times if you get it
and you can get it to me I'd appreciate
it um but I just if a round up call it$
700,000 that gets us to $4 million every
two years for that number now when you
get that number you know you can ignore
the presidential primary it'd be
interesting but for the meals and and um
uh reeven the meals the hotel meals tax
it's let's leave it alone but if you go
back to that 37% of that4 million that's
$1.5
million all right that us Undeclared you
know vote voters are paying for
primaries that just are not working for
us now is the time to fix that problem
we need to get going with rank Choice
voting as soon as we can all right I
brought two books one is called the
political industry um one of the authors
is Michael Porter all right Michael
Porter if you know him is a famous
Harvard business strategy Professor when
asked how to fix some of the problems in
our country rank Choice voting
approaches is what they're putting forth
my book is called consuming government
and the premise of this book is that
we're irresponsible consumers for all
the government we're buying so if we're
spending $1.5 million for primaries that
aren't working for me I'm trying to make
a stink all right I'm you're spending my
money and I'm not happy right because it
doesn't the way the system works does
not work for me um I also put in the
links to the common denominator push out
a newsletter I've also spent a decade um
running our civic league put together a
newsletter that
briefs out in bullet points what's going
in our town I spend a tremendous amount
of time my personal time trying to help
people be educated inform so we can make
better decisions it's a hobby I don't
golf for fish all right there is no one
Panacea for everything all right but the
one of the most important things we can
do quickly is rank Choice voting so
please let's hurry up and get going
thank you very much does anybody have
any
questions EV want a free book I'll take
a free book book you're yeah I'll always
you all right this didn't cost more than
it all right thank you
Lockwood
hi my name is Nathan Lockwood uh thanks
for really great to be here today um I'm
executive director of a national
organization called rank the vote um we
work with uh citizens all across the us
to help them uh provide them with uh
education on how to best uh inform
people in their states about rank Choice
voting and uh I'm here today I'm not uh
with a couple points one I want to make
really quickly uh the important question
was raised about if you did itop during
Choice voting uh what kind of education
would be needed and like any kind of
change that in in elections like
education is very important voter
education educating candidates and
educating um co-workers and election
administrators the good news is uh there
are many national organizations and
state Foundation National and state
organizations and Foundations standing
by ready to help the state of New
Hampshire so the state of New Hampshire
would not have to do this alone you just
got the offer from um communications
director Len cook from the main
Secretary of State uh to help with that
education process at all those different
levels and in fact this process is going
on right now in Alaska which adopted
rank Choice voting by referendum in 2020
and actually uh Professor wand's
organization United America is
participating in that that process so I
just want to let you let you know I'm
sure um um New Hampshire rank Choice
voting can tell you a lot more about
that but um great resources available
today if you were doing this for the
first time back in
2000 good help would be a lot harder to
find doing this in 2020 with all the
momentum behind the issue you're going
to you're going to have more help than
you could
imagine so what I want to talk about uh
real quick is what a unique opportunity
this is for New Hampshire specifically
because New Hampshire is exceptional and
having the most extensive use of multi
member districts in their state
legislature of anywhere in the US and um
this is there's some real benefits that
New Hampshire voters enjoy from this
current system so I want to talk about
some of the good things about the way
you vote now you get greater choice of
candidates and voters can make more than
one selection when you run in one of
those elections as I imagine many of you
have um you're more empowered to run for
something I'm hoping everybody has and
that's why you're here right everybody
ran okay awesome well some may be from s
member districts you have a few but yeah
absolutely so um you can run more likely
to be able to run for something rather
than be perceived as running against a
person because you're you're one of many
running and many being elected you're
not fighting one incumbent for that seat
that's a that's a more positive Dynamic
this type of system you have has
strongly correlated with more
cross-partisan gender equity in
government in the handful of states that
use it and has contributed to New
Hampshire and pat yourself on the back
here leading the country in elected
women so congratulations on that that's
a huge positive thing you got an A the
only state to get an A in 20120 from
represent
women uh but these benefits are just a
beginning of what is possible and there
are currently some drawbacks to the
current system the main problem is this
problem of District sweeps that happens
when you elect these multiple members of
the district the way we do it now where
frequently one or the other party will
win all the seats and supporters of the
other party get none of the seats and
some of these districts are as big as
you know nine nine members being elected
I believe in in the in competitive
districts where you have like New
Hampshire is a very kind of purpley
state there's a lot of Republicans
there's a lot of Democrats you can have
these districts going back and forth
regularly just kind of based on
turnout so rank Choice voting uh offers
a solution to this rank Choice voting
specifically with proportional
representation in these multi
multi-member districts which is
described in the handout that Tiani
offered you offers a solution that could
make New Hampshire government even
better and actually be a model to the
rest of the United States which does not
have the benefits of some of these
multi-member districts right now it may
seem paradoxical that a system with more
competition in Choice can actually yield
more stability in government Civility
and service to the public good the same
system of rank Choice voting I'm talking
about with multi-member districts exists
in the Republic of Ireland they've used
it for over 100 years and it has just
that reputation it's very good for
incumbents who serve their districts
well and very good for replacing those
who don't so proportional representation
means no more sweeps no more throwing
good incumbent babies out with the
partisan bathat so there's more
continuity in the legislature with the
most supported representative staying it
reduces instability in the legislature
due to these irregular turnover from
sweeps in between cycles and the most
important thing though about the system
the most important valuable thing about
proportional RCV which only States like
New Hampshire in a position to realize
right now is that um at any given time
almost every citizen in the district is
likely to be represented by a candidate
they voted for and this is what you see
when you look at the ballots and look at
who's elected in places like Ireland and
other plac there's a few places in the
US that use it as well the other quick
benefit is RCV is also simpler for
voters why because they no longer have
to make tough decisions about bullet
voting their Uncle Jeff is running for
the first time and gosh that want to
make sure he wins but oh my gosh I'm
giving up four out of my five votes to
make sure Jeff wins they no longer have
to worry about that the way the ballots
are counted takes that off the table you
just rank your favorites and put Jeff
first and you're doing everything you
can for
Jeff so there's a growing consensus
amongst many political scientists and
good government groups like Charlie
wheel's United America that by providing
more Choice satisfying each voter with
accurate representation and encouraging
politicians to appeal the people broadly
this system offers the best
possibilities for reducing the worst
aspects of negative partisanship you
know the kind of partisan ranker where
people are more worried about they hate
the other side more than they like their
side so this reduces that and can help
unite Americans around common goals this
is highlighted in a recent report that
just dropped this week from a group
called Protect America which focuses on
solutions to threats to American
democracy and uh it talks about the
adopt successful adoption of this system
is part of the peace process not in the
Republic of Ireland that's used it for
100 years but in Northern Ireland where
there was this sectarian in religious
Strife that uh came to relative end in
the 2000s the violent part of it through
a peace process and they adopted this
voting process specifically because of
these characteristics of helping people
focus on Common Ground so uh I've Al
lastly uh submitted written testimony or
I didn't submit it testimonies written
testimony has been submitted by an
election commissioner in in
Massachusetts with Decades of experience
administering this type of election and
attesting to the ease of running the
elections reporting the results the
accuracy of the results and the high
voter satisfaction so congratulations on
the things that have been working great
in New Hampshire and I encourage you to
learn more and pursue this incredible
opportunity that's going to be great for
New Hampshire and great for the us thank
you thank you very much Mr Lockwood does
questions thank you all right and the
last person I have signed up to speakers
our own representative
Hamet thank you madam chair technically
representative Hamlet you need to go
testify right okay actually I was going
to ask if I can pass on my testimony and
just hand out my the hard
copy yes you certainly may and members
feel free to ask representative H
questions and I am the one that passed
out this chart which I think is
self-explanatory simple explanation of
basically rank chice
right I'm just okay and you help you
have a handout for all of us afterwards
great okay is there anybody else here
who wants to speak on
1482 um representative Terian can you go
me and representative read if you want
1264 because I have a number of people
signed up to speak on 1264 you can just
okay so you can also sign up to sign in
in favor or oppose to um the bills and I
have this will be part of the public
record I have approximately 15 people
signed up of which it appears years the
the
majority um are in favor of rank Choice
voting by eight and I I guess I'm off a
little bit and four opposed and that
will be available in the file record so
with that I'm going to close the hearing
on 1482 and open the hearing on
1264 1264 is a bill establishing rank
Choice voting for State Party primary
elections and municipal elections and
here to introduce the bill is the prime
sponsor representative Reed thank you
madam chair once again for the record
Ellen Reed representing Rockingham 17
these are my bullet point notes on this
testimony six whole lines they're
abbreviated obviously first of all I
have a problem with the title it doesn't
establish necessarily what this entire
bill is everything you just heard about
rank Choice voting all the wonderful
awesome things about it now we're not
making anybody do any of it we're just
allowing towns because we are a Dillan R
state after all we're allowing towns to
adopt it for their municipal election
should the voters of that town choose
and we're allowing State parties to
adopt it for their primaries both the
state level primaries and the
presidential primaries um and that's
that's really it now most of you know
I'm sure all of you know we're at
Dylan's rule state which means we're not
home rule towns can't just do whatever
they want we have to enable them which
is why this is enabling legislation we
have a segment of legislation called
enabling legislation to allow towns to
do things because we literally have to
say that they're allowed before they can
do it um which is why we don't already
have towns that do rank Choice voting
but much like the states our
Laboratories of democracy in our country
towns are and can be uh Laboratories of
democracy within New Hampshire uh many
of the states that have pursued rank
Choice voting further it's started with
towns in the in towns or municipalities
in those States so that's the municipal
level the party side of things parties
are of course private organizations but
they do use the Secretary of State and
the taxpayer money to run their primary
elections um primaries are very
important to our the concept of
democracy or Republic uh very infamously
uh a man by the name of uh Boss Tweed
who was one of the uh kind of morally
dubious uh people in the 1800s in the
tamy hall political machine kind of
famously said that he doesn't care who
does the electing as long as he does the
nominating meaning that it really
doesn't matter if people can can vote in
a general election if the choices in
that election have already been
determined and that is the reason
primaries are so very important and why
we should allow uh for all the reasons
you heard earlier in terms of spoiler
effect effect and having 17 30 whatever
candidates in a in a primary why we
should allow parties if they choose to
uh to Institute rank Choice voting for
their primaries um all of these things
are opt aable in fact the Party primary
um uh option opt in has to be done every
election so literally before every
primary I think it's 90 days before
every primary a party has to tell a
secretary of state that for their
primary they would like to use rank
Choice vote and then the secretary of
state will operate that particular
election via rank Choice voting for
towns obviously they opt in and at any
point just like anything else they do
they can repeal it um just in terms of
examples and this is my last point in
2016 I believe there were 17 candidates
on the presidential primary uh
ticket uh and then about the same number
a little bit more in the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary uh there was much
speculation in both of those as to how
those would have gone had we had rank
Choice voting and a lot of complaining
about spoiler effect and with the
upcoming cd1 primary especially on the
Republican side I understand I think
there's already seven candidates and we
are still several months away from the
deadline to file that certainly There's
real potential for someone to win that
who does not have the majority of the
Republican support having said that I'm
done with my notes I'm happy to take
questions and I would encourage anybody
else who is in support of the bill to
abbreviate their notes or speak briefly
or wave off if they don't have anything
new to
add thank you any questions for
representative
Reed thanks Qui question representative
Mir
Hood
1482 requires rank Choice voting by
in uh Federal and State offices in this
bill um only enables 1264 only enables
there's no requirement whatsoever
there's no requirement whatsoever and in
the big what we call the big Bill the
one you just heard that very lengthy
hearing on for party primaries and for
towns it does not require it either it
is only it enables it as the first stage
of implementation by 2023 and then the
other two stages of implementation have
to do with General State elections so
Municipal both are enabling thank you
all right also signed up to speak on
you thank you madam chairman and members
of the committee my name's Alvin C I
live in lden and I'm uh representing
myself and I'm opposed to this
bill
um one of the things that I noticed in
the bill is
that while the title says it's four
primaries on U page seven lines 4 to 12
it shows this applies to the general
election as well the state general
elections so in that case then the uh
constitutional issues with the Governor
counselors and Senators uh May
apply for Municipal elections this bill
doesn't specify primary or general
election uh but since rank Choice voting
can supposedly handle a crowded ballot
this could eliminate the need for a
primary Municipal nonpartisan election
and this could be a major selling point
for going this route because that would
eliminate the need for a prim primary
election um if cities choose to do the
rank Choice then only those cities would
need to replace their acuo
machines
um and presumably that would be at the
city's expense however if a party
chooses to use the rank choice that
suddenly means that all the acuo
machines in the state are affected and
therefore uh this bill really needs a
fiscal note likely similar to the fiscal
note on House Bill
1482 and again for people who are
skeptical of computers and other
electronic devices uh rank Choice uh
voting requires much more computer use
and equipment and transfer of data I
urge itl on this bill and I'll take
questions thank you any questions for Mr
C
seeing none thanks thank
you also signed up to speak is Tiana
Coleman did you have anything to add on
this
bill welcome thank you um I I'll keep it
brief I just wanted to point out really
clearly that if you pass this
bill um nothing will change unless other
people take action so you're not
changing anything you're just enabling
giving an op in so if you pass this bill
then municipalities are going to have to
go through the process if they want to
use it and pass it themselves and then
opt in and use it if they don't do that
nothing will change if they do they have
that chance and a lot of them would like
to have that chance and I think you
should give them that opportunity same
with primaries if you pass this bill
that doesn't mean there will be rank
Choice voting in primaries only if the
parties want to and if one party wants
to and another party doesn't want to
that's fine they don't have to both use
it um as well as has already been
expressed um just because they opt in
doesn't mean they have to keep doing it
either and a municipality even can
decide because they have to when they
opt in they probably do it by warrant
article or something like that and they
can write it however they want so if
they want to write it to say we're just
going to use it in this particular
primary they could or they could just
say we want to now start using it in all
of our primaries until or unless we
repat kill it so this is a very open
flexible bill it's a very conservative
Bill once again I think representative
Reed kind of said it but I want to
repeat there is the parties have no
right to opt in it's a federally funded
election and the state could say we are
going to have rank Choice voting in
primaries and if you pass that as a bill
then there would be rank Choice voting
in primaries the parties do not have
that right because you know
parties party primaries that are funded
by the state and that are public
elections are governed by the state so
the state legislature can say what they
want to do but in this case this bill is
giving the parties the opportunity to
choose and opt in and they're not
manding mandating it and so this is a a
very conservative Bill allowing parties
to opt in if they want or not want um
it's a side note I do think that 1482
can be read either way and I'm not sure
which which way would is right so just
wanted to say that because you brought
that up um on the one hand it says that
they opt in in 2023 I'm not sure what
happens in 2025 and
2027 because they don't distinguish
between primaries and Generals so it is
possible that in 2027 it's mandated for
all elections and it's only opt in from
2023 till 2025 2027 but that's another
that's a side not all right thank you
any questions I'm not seeing any just
for people coming in we are running way
behind I'm not sure what the signage on
the door is we are still on the morning
bills I anticipate that we will not be
beginning the afternoon bills My Hope Is
by 1:30 um but we'll see where we end up
here the chair did not do a great job of
scheduling this this morning also signed
up to speak on this bill is Nathan
Lockwood we are on Bill
1264 Mr Lockwood
welcome hi Nathan Lockwood executive
director of rank just a real brief on
these uh bill so I just want to
reiterate that the same type of uh voter
candidate and election administrator
education resources that we talked about
being available for the state would also
be available for municipalities as well
and there are a lot of uh Civic
organizations standing by ready to help
out with that process so I think it's a
great opportunity um you know I think uh
Professor Wen referred to uh the use of
rank Choice voting increasingly in party
presidential primaries uh just a couple
quick notes on that very bipartisan the
Democrats used it in a number of their
primaries in 2020 for the presidency is
part of the way to move to a higher
participation primary as opposed to the
caucus system and so there were a lot of
states that did that the other thing I
would mention is New Hampshire might
have some special benefits at least on
the Democratic side where they are
you're very early in the primary cycle
for the presidency and with the
proportional allocation of delegates
that the that that happens in the 15%
threshold there are historically when
there are feels like there was in 2020 a
lot of Voters um don't have their vote
counted towards delegate allocation even
though it's supposed to be proportional
because they vote for someone who
doesn't reach the threshold and rank
Choice voting just solves that problem
last thing I'll say is tons of one of
the things that's most exciting to rank
Choice voting Advocates is the
excitement amongst Republicans right now
for rank Choice voting most notably in
Virginia the Republican party of
Virginia El chose to use rank Choice
voting to nominate their candidates for
Statewide office because of its benefits
and that enabled them to nominate was uh
a winning candidate in uh Glen yunan who
went on to kind of an upset Victory and
what was thought to be a state trending
blue and uh he partic he he was
nominated through a rank Choice buing
process so thanks very uh Utah is also
looking very closely at that and as uh
Professor W mentioned a lot of States
GOP State parties using it for their
state conventions thanks so much thank
you any questions not seeing any um also
signed up to speak on this bill is
Charlotte
welcome thank you good
afternoon um I'm a voter from Brookline
and an eisenh how Republican which means
I have no party I'm speaking in favor of
rank Choice voting today because I want
my vote to count now that I'm retired I
prepare for our glorious first in the
nation primarily by trying to see all
the candidates Republicans Democrats and
Bernie big job of the 50 plus candidates
who ran in 2020 I only managed to meet
and greet
18 those half it doesn't seem believable
with some good ideas and a chance of
winning so who to vote for the best the
likeliest someone good for the country
or good for the people or good for me I
voted in like
53.8% of the other people who voted
which is more than half I didn't pick a
winner and like
41.7% of Voters my candidate didn't even
get a delegate so why bother voting it's
a waste of time and effort but if we'd
run that primary with rank Choice voting
the winner would have been one of my
choices all voters might have said the
same with the rank choice of voting we
could all feel like we've done something
and we could all feel like we'd won
something namely candidates with
majority
support
so uh let's Empower voters by
implementing rank Choice voting in every
election uh thanks any
choice that Miss po just showed us a
shirt about having more Choice than
voting this is hb1
1264 all
right thank you very much for
coming um and Joan Hamlet has signed up
on this
bill uh thank you madam chair once again
most of my points have already been
covered so I'm happy to wave off and
hand out my hard copy instead great
thank
you is there is there a clipboard coming
my
way it's for
me all right we also have a blue signup
sheet for people in favor or opposed and
um there are also about a little more
than 15 people signed up for this bill
um with I'd say five opposed and maybe
114 but this will be part of the public
review is there anybody else who wanted
to testify on hb1
1264 I'm not seeing anyone so I'm going
to close the hearing on 1264 and open
the hearing on cacr
22 um this is a constitutional amendment
providing that all elections in New
Hampshire should be by rank Choice
voting
welcome thank you I was looking for it
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
election law committee for hearing me
today uh my name is representative Tony
Le branch and I represent the town of
amher I'm here to introduce cacr 22
which would make it a constitutional
requirement that all elections in New
Hampshire be by rank Choice voting that
is all this amendment does I would like
to clear up that RCV is already
constitutional and that this is simply
requires that elections be by rank
Choice
voting this would also give the voters
an opportunity to vote on the matter of
RCV as all cacs in New Hampshire must be
voted on by the voters the majority of
the testimony on this bill has already
been heard so I will not be diving into
rank Choice voting instead I will share
how RCV would have affected me in my
election if we had rank Choice voting in
2020 I would not be here today at least
not in this capacity my district is a
purle multi-member district with three
members last election I came in third
place and therefore won my seat here
today yet there were only a there was
only a 74 vote difference between myself
and the fourth place candidate this
meant that Democrats won all three seats
even though my district is closer to a
50-50 split under a rank Choice voting
system you would have expected voters to
rank their candidates first uh their
party's candidates first and this would
have made it so that after two or three
two of the three Republicans being
eliminated it would if we're thinking of
this in a simple way and we assume that
these two candidates uh voters would
have voted uh for another uh Republican
uh that would have meant that a
republican would be occupying the seat
that I am holding today with that I ask
that the committee pass the bill with an
a to pass recommendation and I would
also like to say that I would rather
this past than I be sitting here because
I believe that uh representative
democracy is important and I'd rather
that uh elections be truly
representative of the will of the people
than my personal sitting here today so
this is more important than me and
that's why I'm here today thank you
representative lebranch any questions
for the representative introducing CAC
R22 representative Alexander thank you I
just I just want to add I don't think
it's fair you could speculate on how
voters make decisions in in priv
previous elections like I understand
moving forward but to kind of pin your
like the state of your race on the
voters that previously I don't think is
fair to the voters that's all uh I
understand that we cannot uh accurately
predict how the election would have gone
under rank Choice voting last year as uh
voters did not have the opportunity to
use rank Choice voting but if we are
using uh if we're adding all the votes
up all the Republican votes up and
coales around one candidate it I would
have been eliminated in the second round
uh and that would have meant that a
republican most likely would have
you any other questions
I'm not seeing any thank you
representative also signed up to speak
C thank you madam chairman and members
of committee my name's Alvin C I live in
lden and I'm here representing myself
and I'm opposed to this bill
um this bill uh makes a change only to
first part article
11 but it still leaves in place the
Constitutional requirements in part two
for the Senators the governor and the uh
counselors and as such I think this bill
uh will put a put different articles of
the constitution in conflict with each
other and as such ought to be not passed
uh
also I don't think that the type of meth
or manner of method uh of voting I don't
think should be specified in the
Constitution I I think it might be a a
good case here to create a uh study
committee to study all the articles of
the Constitution and see what would be
needed to allow for changing the manner
how we vote but uh without specifying
what Manner whether it's rank Choice
voting or approval voting or conday
voting or any other type that might come
around that would be something that the
legislature could adopt um and I thank
you for your time and I will answer any
questions thank you and I have your
written
testimony any
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank you and also signed up to speak is
Tiana
Coleman
okay I'm just here in my capacity as
myself today I'm not representing any
organization on this bill um our
organization specifically chose to be
neutral on this bill some people oppose
it some people support it I'm I'm
opposed um as an individual and I just
wanted to say that the reason why I
oppose it is because my own
constitutional philosophy is that a
bill that a constitution should be
flexible and should not go into every
little detail of what you want as you
all know I support rank Choice voting
but I do not believe that it should be
mandated by the Constitution um I don't
believe that our constitution currently
mandates first P the post and I don't
think we should change it to mandate or
you know to now mandate rank Choice
voting I think there are a lot of
different kinds of voting methods that
people could use and they should be able
to use them without having to change the
Constitution every time they might want
to use a different voting method so I I
do not believe we should do that um even
with regards to the plurality provision
as we've discussed I've already said I
believe that it is constitutional but if
we were wanting to have it be 100% sure
no question absolutely for sure um the
route still wouldn't be this particular
Amendment you could do an amendment
that's much simpler that's just a
clarification kind of amendment that
would not mandate rank Choice voting you
do not have to mandate rank Choice
voting in order to have that be 100% for
sure perfect no question so that's
that's my testimony thank you thank you
any questions for Tiana Coleman thank
you for coming up is there anybody else
here to speak on cacr
22 um I have been handed this the signup
sheet and this number I can do in my
head here there have been six people who
have signed up in regards to this bill
one person in favor and five opposed
this will be part of the public record
on CAC R22 I am closing the hearing on
CAC
R22 um this committee will take a break
I want to thank all the members for
staying here for the morning and being
so attentive I want to thank my clerk
who I don't know if you've noticed has
been shaking her hand
periodically um so she certainly needs a
break as do all of us and we will be
back here at 1:30 I apolog olog for the
short lunch break but I want to keep it
dinner so for those of you who are here
for afternoon bills we'll just since
we're behind the we'll start off at one
o'cl with CAC R15 and depending on the
testimony on that we'll move right into
you
morning
by
I
represent
youre
okay
e
for
just
still
for
e
to
SE
right
spe
more
don't
for
want
well you never
know
right
really
yeah
what
pi
been
people
C
it
yeah
I'm
e
before
hear
told
people
it's
something
AG
to
I
you're
all
all right good afternoon everybody this
is the house election law committee it
is a little after 1:30 we are beginning
our afternoon session uh my apologies to
people for the untimeliness and my
thanks to everybody for um being patient
with the
schedule as it is um so our first bill
this afternoon is
cacr 15 relating to election and it
provides that the age to vote in the
primary election would be reduced to 17
for those who will be 18 by the general
election joining us is to introduce the
bill is the prime sponsor representative
Le welcome again thank you madam chair
and hello again house election law
committee uh as we uh know my name is
representative Tony lebranch and I
represent the town of Amherst New
Hampshire uh I come before you today to
introduce cacr 15 uh this legislation
would do what 23 states have already
adopted in some form and that is 11 17y
olds who will be 18 by the date of the
general election to vote in primary
elections it's that simple this is a
common sense and simple modification
that would allow soon to be general
election voters to Cho their pref
preferred candidates in their primary
and the reason that this C is a cicr and
not a bill is because the age
requirement to vote in all elections is
in the united is in the New Hampshire
Constitution and is in part one article
11 of the Constitution and therefore a
constitutional amendment is required to
make this very narrow exemption
and with that I ask the committee pass
the cacr with an a to pass
recommendation thank you thank you um
members you have a memo from Christina
Dyer our researcher in regards to this
issue it was emailed to you before the
meeting and I believe you had a copy of
it at your um desk with the papers this
morning to give you some background on
this because this is not um there's some
history here in the state along with
General history on the request itself
members of the committee does anybody
have any questions for representative
lebranch I'm not seeing any
representative Troian could you grab the
clipboard for
me I do not have anybody else speak up
to speak on cacr 15 is there anybody
else present who would like to speak to
this proposed
Bill I'm not seeing any thank
you
we do have a sheet for people to sign up
to register an opinion if they are not
speaking and I have approximately 11
people signed up in regards to this bill
um with four in favor and seven opposed
um and that sheet will become part of
the public record on this bill finally
is there anybody else on
ca15 seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on CA cr15 and move to
the next item on our agenda this
afternoon which is cacr
19 uh relating to paper ballots and that
all elections should be conducted
through paper ballots and the prime
sponsor is with us here to introduce the
welcome
thank you madam chair thank you members
of election law committee the record my
name is Representative Steve Pierce and
I'm from Rockingham District Six which
is
dairy cacr
19 is extraordinarily simple it's
simple because it's something we're
doing already the difference here though
is that the requirement that ballots be
printed on paper in the state of New
Hampshire is a matter of law it is not
in the
Constitution and as all of us here know
law can be changed quite simply as by
comparison with the Constitutional law
so my proposal here is to move the
requirement of paper balloting from
law for those of us that follow this if
we got a little bit of our uh election
nerd on here the and we all recall that
the state of Iowa recently had developed
a smartphone app in reference to
their their election process that turned
out to be a colossal disaster so we have
story after Story of people trying to
vote on machines and other creative ways
where there's just a slew of problems
and I'll touch on upon a couple of those
real
quick for for those of us
that
that are not entirely sure here let me
be very clear what this what this
proposal does and does not do this
proposal
requires that we continue to vote on
paper this has nothing to do with how we
count
ballots and unfortunately in the media a
lot of times we see an interchange of
the use of voting
machine interchangeably with counting
machine and and let me be clear to to
those watching that there's a
substantial difference between a voting
machine and accounting machine a voting
voting machine would be me walking into
a a booth with a screen in front of me
and seeing two boxes let's say in the
case of a general Joe Biden Donald Trump
as an example of our last federal
election and someone using that screen
to vote that's a voting machine a
counting machine takes a ballot and
simply counts
votes and this bill has absolutely
nothing to do with how we count votes so
I want to make sure that people
understand that this is simply about you
casting your vote
for whoever whoever you choose for a
particular
office when uh Secretary of State
Gardner former now former Secretary of
State Gardener was asked about the
situation in Iowa he had a great quote
he said you can't hack a pencil and I
think that that today is something that
is certainly on the minds of folks after
this last election where various things
were discovered or accused or or
questioned here and the fact is is that
when we vote on paper a lot of these
problems just can't
happen the state of New Hampshire has
been printing ballots the state has
since 1892 again this is a very common
thing that we do in the state we don't
really think much of it simply because
we've been doing it as a matter of law
for a long time so I did have a I did
have a a member asked about about this
potentially being a 28a issue in the
sense that the state is dictating
something but we already do that we're
already requiring this as a matter of
law so this doesn't become a 28 issue
because we're in in essence just moving
this from one section of law to
another so that is the gist of this it
it really as far as the general voting
public is concerned would be seamless
difference thank
you does anybody have any questions for
representative
Pearson representative Barry I just want
to be very clear about this bill so this
bill wouldn't actually change anything
it's just codifying State Statute in uh
in in law in the Constitution and I have
do a followup to that question M chair
correct representative Barry this takes
the the requirement to vote on paper
from statutory law in essence into
constitutional
law and that as you know is a entirely
different level of of um how it's viewed
in the court system and how it's the
ability to change that changes
substantially once it enters the
Constitutional law so the um the
Secretary of State's office the ACU vote
systems are going to reach their end of
life soon and we're going to have to
have some new system soon um by soon I
mean it's relative right it's government
we move the speed of government
um so this would this would require that
any new system we had would have to have
some form of paper receipt copy of The
Ballot or or something like something
along those lines correct
no you use the word receip I'm not sure
I'm not sure that that's what we're
saying here we're we're actually using
the term paper ballot so that means you
have to vote physically on the paper
voting in another Manner and obtaining a
receipt is not a ballot it's a receipt
so there are machines out there my my
parents use these in my native state of
Texas I got to watch them vote when I
went home right before my birthday and
Christmas um where they you know Texas
is a very large State they vote elect
they vote they vote on an electronic
machine and it prints out a copy of
their ballot and then they put their
ballot in when before they leaving they
basically put their ballot in as a paper
I don't a duplicate um I don't know what
you want to I don't want to use the term
receipt um but it's you print it out you
look at it you say yes my printed out
ballot looks like what I did this is the
right thing and then you go you put it
in and that's how they have um basically
gotten to the ability to count votes
electronically with the security of a
paper I don't want to use the term
receipt but let's say copy um so it
would this would this prohibit something
like that I don't believe so because in
that sense what they're what they're
getting out is a ballot and that ballot
can be questioned it can be reviewed it
can be recounted it can be audited
because it's a tangible
vote okay so in contrast to a voting
machine which does not produce a ballot
that is tangible
scrutinized and
review any further
questions all right I'll just say in
followup that I've been to other places
who have the receipt system where you
vote and then you get a little ticket to
verify what was registered and then if
it's wrong then you go back and you
re-enter and redo it but it's so the
system you're talking about in Texas
actually has something that's tabulated
separate from the completion
of what I will refer to as a ballot
correct I couldn't actually see it
because they were voting um but from the
way they described it to me was they
could actually see how they voted
okay all right any further
questions
representatively thank you so I guess I
should address the question to you so in
that circumstance that was described by
representative Barry um is that really
the ballot or is that really a paper
trail for the
ballot and you can probably tell by my
question I'm a lawyer so I'm just trying
to be really clear okay sure okay so so
this is already law in the state of New
Hampshire and as far as I know we don't
we don't do this anywhere okay and that
may and I don't know if the Secretary of
State's office is here they'd be better
to answer that question as to whether
that meets the intent a current law or
not because I don't know but there's a
huge difference between getting a
receipt printed out sticking and going
okay yeah these are who I voted for put
in your pocket and going home versus
having something like representative
Barry described where it prints out a a
a a paper copy of if you will of the
device you used and then you turn that
in there's a substantial difference
there because something that would be
you know akin to a receipt if you bring
it home with you how you can't do
anything with it there's no recounts
there's no nothing so so I think in that
case is those are two very different um
ways of conducting a
vote representative Mir
Hood so you mentioned it doesn't change
anything and the rsas RSA 656 1- a has
the language that this proposed
amendment has it says for purposes of
facilitating the examination of
recounting of votes cast all elction to
be conducted conducted using paper
ballots what problem does this solve why
is that law not good enough the reason
that law is not good enough is because I
don't have faith enough that that law is
going to stay a law has there ever been
a situation in which that law was not
good
enough representative
Mirad what's the question I don't good
enough is not a term that an attorney
would be happy with use of let's leave
it at that I stand
corrected and I thank thank my Council
for straightening that out because I am
certainly not an attorney we did have a
memo I I think I can say somebody pop up
if they have a I am not aware of any
legislative attempt to change that
law but I think the inference that
representative Pearson is asking us to
draw is that it is significantly easier
to do that that then it is correct and
and this was drawn the in consultation
with the Secretary of State's office I I
did not uh come up with this solely on
my own this this was vetted through
their office before it was
filed
okay it's another case of politicians
them all right any other questions for
representative
Pearson all right thank you
representative Pearson oh I'm sorry
representative
growan um thank you madam chair
representor Pearson it does
say that elections shall be conducted
using paper ballots and it seems to me
that that
would create a stretch wouldn't it for
using a machine and then printing a
paper ballot re receipt
so I was going to say I don't see any
that I could argue both sides of that
one in a Flash and the other attorneys
but I mean if you're going to make that
argument Bas based on on the proposal
that's before you now you you can make
that same argument based on current law
right thank you any other
questions thank you representative thank
you madam chair thank you for the
committee's
time I do not have any other pin cards
sorry representative Terian can you see
please thank you my name is Liz torelli
I'm from Newbury New Hampshire and I
compile testimony on this bill and the
one to follow because of a misreading
and I'm going to hold that testimony for
the next bill but I would like to point
out what caused my misreading of this
and perhaps the sponsor might want to
make a
change if you look at section five in
18 um I thought this was part of the
proposed amendment language and it's not
it's really about the process of putting
it on the ballot but it does say if no
cross is made excuse me in either of the
squares the ballot shall not be counted
on this
question
so in my quick re in my reading of it
earlier and then I reread it this
morning because we had a lot of spare
time this morning
sorry um I thought that imposing a cross
rather than the ovals that we fill in
with would lead to a requirement to do
hand counting because X's are much
harder for a machine to count so I Now
understand that was not the intent of
this but that may be a suggestion to the
sponsor to change that language um so
you can put me down as neutral on this
bill I signed in AOS but neutral if that
change is made okay so thank you for
allowing me to make that statement thank
you for pointing that
out any questions for Miss tentarelli
before she goes she's not really going
anywhere but she's going back to her
seat all right is there anybody else
19 all right thank you um I have the
blue sheet here for people who have
registered to speak who I mean
registered a position who do not want to
speak there is one one of these over on
the table for every bill that we hear um
so if you are here on a bill but don't
actually want to come to speak but want
us to know your opinion we ask that you
fill this out and I have here an example
of why we need sometimes to look at
ballots to figure out the intent because
I have a huge scribble Mark here um but
in any case it would appear that I have
um
all a number of people all signed up in
bill so having said that I'm going to
close the public hearing on CAC
r19 and I'm going to open the public
hearing on huilt B16 oh I actually have
to
wait 1064 is scheduled for 2
pm um and I I am not supposed to open
hearings before the scheduled time so we
will be in recess for five minutes thank
you or eight minutes I guess depending
know
e
to
unless
e
St
so
all
so usually they Reserve this over here
there
speaking
[Music]
where
pleas on if everybody if uh you are we I
assume the chair will do it like we did
the redistricting hearings so we'd like
this section over here on my left your
right to be the Mast only section and
we'll try to keep the middle and this
section over here for the unmas folks
and just go ahead and honor that we did
that for we districting and um it worked
sit
saw um once again if you are we're going
to reserve the section to my left for
the masked section only if you're
unmasked can you sit in the center on
the right side um that we did that for
the redistricting hearings and it worked
out really well so I ask everybody just
that
e
also I placed a new signup sheet if
you've already signed up don't worry
about it but I placed a new signup sheet
and new pink cards if you'd like to
register your opinion um in the back in
the Annie room if you have any problems
know
e
probably
is
[Music]
you guys all sign in the blue sheet yet
we all sign blue
sheet you want to speak you have to fill
out the pink slip if you want to
speak and there are many bills today on
the election law that we all need to
support too beside the
1157 there are
already
them
as
you
that
for
on
so we're trying to deal with the AV
issues right now so as soon as I've got
some indication that we're set to go um
or not because I may decide we need to
get going we will get going um as a
preliminary matter uh we have a hearing
this scheduled on 106 4 11:57 and 12:47
all of those hearings will occur in this
room now we're not going to move back
across the hall um there are blue sheets
going around for you to sign up an a a
position on each of the bill make sure
that at the top of the page it has the
bill number that you mean to sign up for
and you testify you're going to check
off whether you're in favor or opposed
to that bill uh the you can do that
electronically online also um and if you
want to speak here today we have pink
cards for you to sign up on um I have
these are all cards for 1064 I apologize
I think I had like two or three cards
for the other bills and I think I've
left them in the L so if we get to those
bills and you have signed up to speak
I'm going to ask your Indulgence to grab
another pink card um and chiao Kelly if
are there still are there still pink
cards out there for people to have there
there still can you check to make sure
just
all right just somebody let me know if
up
that's all right ready to go all right
good afternoon everybody we are ready
ready to go um this is the New Hampshire
house election law committee it is
January paper 13th uh we are here for a
scheduled hearing at at 2 o'clock on HB
1064 I thank everybody here for your
Indulgence in the delay in the start we
have moved this hearing for those of you
watching from our regular committee room
to here reps Hall in the state house for
anybody who's watching who might be
interested in the other other two bills
we have following this HB 1157 and HB
1247 those hearings will occur directly
after the hearing on this bill in this
Hall um in regards to testimony on this
bill we have the prime sponsor a number
of people signed up to speak we have
what are referred to as blue sheets for
those of you in attendance to register
your opinion if you would don't want to
speak if you do want to speak you do the
pin card and get it down to me you can
also for those of you watching online
and those of you hearing you can also
log on to the house home web page and
you can register your position on this
bill or any bill that is considered by
the house in the upcoming session U so
that committee members can take account
of that when they do their deliberations
on the bill this is a public hearing uh
the purpose of this public hearing is to
hear from you we want to do that um so
also understand that I am probably going
to limit um testimony given the amount
of people that I have signed up to make
sure everybody can be heard um to three
four minutes that's pretty much what we
get told as legislators is if you're not
quiet in three minutes nobody's
listening anymore so all right all right
I may have to go back up to the CU all
right all right I I may just move back
it's depending on how this goes because
if you don't mind I prefer to remain
standing so I can make sure I don't miss
anybody or see what's going on um I saw
I'm assuming the hand I saw was because
you couldn't hear me um so we have
resolved that and frankly once this gets
going you're not going to really have to
listen to me anymore so with that um
this is the election law committee I did
not have them bring their name tags with
them to facilitate getting this going um
so without further Ado unless there are
other questions about procedure we're
going to get going and I'm going to
recognize the prime sponsor of this bill
he's here with us today representative
[Applause]
mad committee before you begin
representative just so you know one of
the rules of rep's Hall is that we're
not supposed to get excited or clap or
yell because we're all a very quiet
Demir group um but representative
Allegro did a lot of work you're all
here in support of them I recognize that
so thank you very much for giving him a
clap but for for proceeding I'm going to
ask that you sort of retain that
enthusiasm a little bit because I'd like
to think that we give every speaker the
same attention um and by paying
attention and trying to mute our
responses to ourselves or maybe maybe
our seatmate um we show everybody the
same respect so with that thank you for
waiting representative thank you madam
chair and committee members good
afternoon and thank you for granting me
the time to speak to you today I um am
going to present some data being mindful
of time considerations before I do that
I would like to provide a little bit of
context for this bill I would like to
address some of the criticisms that I
know exist and then I'm going to present
a little data and summarize but first I
do want to point out that it's really
not fair asking an Italian to testify
encumbered so I'll just do my
best well when I talk about this the the
purpose purp of this bill is because
I've known for years and have now uh
confirmed with a simple data analysis
that there are problems with voting
machines when I talk about this to
people they they roll their eyes some of
them let me assure you this is not about
Windham this is not really even about
2020 this is about losing votes votes
being swallowed by
machines so um I also want to point out
before I get rolling here uh when you
question me please set aside etiquette
and be as tough with your questions as
you possibly can I'm prepared to defend
any and all data I present to you and I
want to point out that this data has
been confirmed by an independent
source with the same outcome although a
completely opposite conclusion and again
to provide a little context a few weeks
back a fellow from the Concord Monitor
wanted to um interview me the interview
was not going well so I uh declined
going further
miraculously about two or three weeks
later there was an article in the
conquered times using the exact same
approach that I used to do this study
and um he only did 2020 amazingly he
came out with almost exactly the same
numbers but in his opinion it was okay
to throw out out some thousands of votes
to me not so much so um let me address
some criticisms first because I know the
real criticisms with every bill with
every proposal there are upsides and
downsides one of the commonest things
you'll hear about this particular bill
is that it's going to cost more well
first of all let me tell you that uh I
had an interesting uh interaction with
the U budget office and the input that
they received from the municipal assoc
Association who somehow managed to not
observe that yes there will be
interesting uh there will be some
increased costs with some pole
workers uh but and and by the way that's
so minimal they couldn't even put a
number on it but there will be cost
savings cost
offsets Savings in not having to
purchase machines savings and not have
to pay for machine updates software
updates maintenance and that sort of
thing so the actual fiscal note to this
bill is almost
Irrelevant in my opinion anyway timing
timing is another criticism yes it's
going to take longer to count the votes
now let me point out that onethird of
the towns in New Hampshire already count
by hand 2third do not and they include
of course as expected some of our larger
towns so there's going to be some added
not only difficulty I'll be fair and say
hardship in this it's going to take
extra hours it's going to take a few
extra people I have a uh an acquaintance
on the select board in Littleton and uh
she told me that uh the Inc the cost of
a a stipend for a pole worker is about
$50 for election day so if larger Towns
how to bring on some more people truly
we're just talking about a few hundred
every year every couple of years so yes
it is going to be more difficult and I
know that there are regulations that uh
or there are laws that regulate how long
after The Ballot Box closes uh that
towns have to report their
numbers um I have two things to say to
that number one is that these other
hundred towns manage to do it every year
that's number one number two for the
larger towns where it's going to be more
difficult it may require some
reorganization
and uh last but not least look at our
the current state of our elections in
this country and in the state now we
wait hours Beyond deadlines days
sometimes
weeks right and in all fairness we saw
this play out in the presidential uh uh
primaries in this state and in others uh
we waited weeks for full results to be
reported so and again this is is nothing
that can't be addressed with a simple
amendment to this bill that would modify
existing statutes if
necessary all
right let me give the data and I just
want to present a couple of definitions
to you so first of all here's the basis
for the study that I
did it's almost impossible to know the
accuracy or the Precision and in this
case the terms are almost
interchangeable it's almost impossible
to know the accuracy of Machine versus
hand counting except for one special
case and that's cases where districts
are
recounted because whether they're
initially counted by hand or by Machine
eventually they're recounted by hand of
course the first thing you need to ask
yourself is why do we recount by hand
and not by Machine well the obvious
answer to that is because hand counting
is more accurate to begin with it's
something we know already
so what you're able to do is compare the
original count whether it's by machine
or hand count the same set of ballots
after the recount and see if there's a
difference between the two I call that
difference assuming that the recount is
the gold standard and it is the official
gold standard I call the recounts uh the
the gold standard and everything is
compared to that so when I refer to
error I mean the difference between the
original count and the recount when I
refer to net error I there's actually a
value assigned not only the difference
between them but whether that difference
was a gain of votes or a loss of
votes all
right Excuse me while I just run through
my notes over here for a
second okay now uh let me just uh lay a
little bit more
groundwork when a district goes into a
recount there are usually a few extra
votes picked up uh I found that this
range is anywhere between .2 and. 3% of
the vote and that's primarily because as
we do a recount there are a number of
votes that we uh we spend more time
deducing the voters intent so whereas a
little check next to a bubble might be
thrown out in the original count in the
recount there's a little bit more effort
to Define uh the intent of the voter and
that extra vote is usually picked up so
usually the original count represents a
small under count okay just by
definition or at least for the purpose
of
today
okay now I looked at the years 2016 2018
and 2020 the only reason I didn't go
back further uh well there's a couple of
reasons one is because then you have to
start tracking when these machines were
brought in and and also I don't have a
staff as none of you do and I only have
so much time in a day so in 2016 there
were 14 State Rep districts and one
State Senate District subjected to
recount in 2018 it was 19 in one and in
2020 it was 9 and two and I just
concentrated on State Rep and state
senate
races all
right let's talk about the average error
per race in each year I know that some
of you and some of you who are not in
favor of this bill are going to say but
these are tiny differences all right but
I want to tell you some information that
was relayed to me by the Secretary of
State in a recent conversation I had
with them and it's public information
since uh Mr Gardner was in office and we
all know that's quite some time
1976 there
were
322 races in the state of New Hampshire
32 22 elections that were
decided by 19 or less
votes so when I'm talking small numbers
please put it into context and realize
that in this state especially with our
small State Rep
districts five six votes can make a big
difference all right ready for some
data so in
2016 the average error was. 3% in hand
count towns meaning that the original
count was an undercount of 3% okay so
when they recounted them the candidates
picked up. 3% that's in hand countdowns
0.7% a0 4%
difference sounds small not really I
think those of you here in the no
understand that a0 4% difference is a
significant difference in these races in
2018 the average error was
0.2% in hand count towns and 0.4% in
machine count towns so again couple of
tents of a percent not that big a deal
right maybe maybe not whose vote should
we throw out when we're talking about
that 0.2 or Point 4% in 2020 the average
error was 0.7% in hand count towns and
0.8% in machine count towns again a tiny
error the average error per race over
these three election years was 6 versus
4% anybody running for office here like
to give up 0.2% when they come up for
re-election out of the gate or see that
many votes thrown
out my understanding is that we should
be aiming for every legal vote to be
counted and that we can't afford to
throw out 0.2 or
0.4% now in 2016 the net
error was a difference of
.5% in hand can towns and machine count
towns in other words in hand count towns
there was a plus a plus meaning that the
candidate picked up a tenth of a percent
and in machine countdowns it was 6%
that's a half a percent difference in
2018 it was -.1 and
plus3 and in 2020 it was 0. 2 and 7
again a
0.5% difference if you doubt my numbers
again I want to remind you that this was
confirmed independently by someone who
was not favorable to this
Bill here's an interesting one for you
the frequency of
Errors equal to or greater than a half a
percentage
point I'll summarize these three years
together in the three years all put put
together there were a 100 races now mind
you when I say 100 races I mean you know
you have a district with two towns in it
or two jurisdictions in it and so that's
there
were 100
cases in the past three banial elections
with errors of 0.5% or
greater I find that
unacceptable all
right I'm going to try to rush through
some of this and skip over a little bit
here's an important
Point 13 of those cases were in handc
countdowns
and 87 of them were machine countdowns
now to be fair there are more machine
countdowns right so you would expect
more errors and more big errors in the
machine countdowns but the number is an
over representation of that ratio right
if it's 1/3 to 23 we would expect there
to be twice as many errors but in fact
there was an additional 38% over
representation in machine
countdowns
here's one I like each year there are
major there's no better way to put it
major
screw-ups in machine count
Towns now you know in 2020 it was
Windham and that's what everybody likes
to talk to I'll bet you nobody in this
room knows the case of summersworth Ward
4 in
2016 where the errors for six candidates
you want to listen to what I'm saying
here
10% if that count didn't happen to be
caught up by chance in a recounted
district we would have never known about
it
10% error that's how accurate your
machine counts are I'm going to repeat
what that means the count was made by
machine and then it was recounted and
there was a difference of 10 and
11% in summersworth W 4
I don't know about you i' call that a
screw-up in 2018 there was no huge
screw-up like that but the big one was
Laconia Ward five where it was greater
than a 2% error for four of the eight
candidates in 2020 of course it was
Windam where there was a net difference
of 6% for four of the candidates and by
the way what people don't talk about it
was a there was an average of a 1% error
for the other four candidates that
weren't involved in that whole
screw-ups all right last page of notes
I'm just going to summarize for
you here's the fact the unavoidable fact
is that machine counting leads to more
and bigger errors than hand
counting the average error in machine
counted
towns is always greater than the average
error in hand-counted towns the average
net error for machine counted towns is
always greater than the average net
error in hand counted towns the
frequency of Errors each year is always
greater in machine counted towns than in
handc counted towns the frequency of
larger errors each year is always
greater for machine counted towns and
hand counted
towns and I want to put something to you
here I've told you how many recounts we
had in these few
years 15 20
each banum in this state there are over
a thousand elections that take place US
Senate US House president every four
years uh State reps County Commissioners
dog catchers you name it there're over a
thousand let's just do a little simple
extrapolation that means that there
are
hundreds hundreds of Elections each year
in this state and will never be able to
know which ones they were or how they
might have turned out hundreds of
Elections with errors of this kind of
magnitude
0.5% 1% 4%
10% will'll never know because they
weren't
recounted given these inaccuracies it
means that every election we're
literally throwing out our citizens
votes there's no way to know how many
true somebody might say well but these
have't you know like in in 20120 this
didn't result in any reversals but it
does it does occasionally and again
we'll never know how many reversals
there might have been I'm not going to
sit here and try to describe to you what
if the race was this close or this close
or this close and it was recounted
whether we would have seen the a
reversal but there were two districts
recounted in 2016 and 2018 where there
were rever reversals uh no I'm sorry
they resulted in five position reversals
and in four election reversals when I
say aition AOS reversal somebody that
finished outside of the uh running
flipped with another candidate so it
didn't result in an overturning of that
election but it was still a position
reversal so there were actually Four
election reversals in those two years
years they were all in machine counted
districts none in hand-counted
District so I just want to conclude and
then I'll be very pleased to take any
questions by
saying we're concerned about election
Integrity in this nation and in this
state and we should
be we didn't have to change
rooms because people are confident in
elections in this state
we didn't have to move over here because
everybody's happy with the way things
are
going it's our responsibility and it
should be our desire to count every
vote and
to imbue confidence in our
citizenry that our elections are fair
and free and that their vote is being
counted and I'll end with that and I'd
be very pleased to take any questions
that you have for me thank
you thank you represent ative please
hold your
applause he got one good clap before
does anybody on the committee have any
questions for the representative
representative
Hamlet um thank you madam chair and
thank you uh
representative uh can you tell me how
many voters are in those hand count
towns either an average or the range of
what what's the population of the can
count towns okay it was a little hard
for me to understand you so I'm going to
try to repeat your question I think you
were asking how many voters are in these
different towns in the hand in the hand
counted towns I don't have that number
obviously you know I'll be happy to
concede that the handc counted towns
that are currently in the state are the
smallest jur smaller jurisdictions for
instance you know whatever I it's it's
not important really because there's a
simple fix for this in towns with larger
population
you know that it's just a management
issue to decide okay you six people
count here you six people count here you
know so it's a management issue and by
the way if this had to be phased in over
a year or two uh so that uh
municipalities could react to those
kinds of problems I think that would be
a really fair uh request and amendment
to be made did I answer your question
okay yes thank you very
much further questions from committee
members
representative
Barry I know we're having trouble
hearing um thank you for your testimony
um I have to uh in these situations as
you're aware um I'm one of the loudest
voices for voter Integrity on this
committee I'm not the only one um
there's there's many of us um but you
know when I when I think about this
procedurally um that's when I start
asking questions right um so I looked up
in your election you won by 50 votes
there was 2,000 some odd 275 cast right
and it appears that your um opponent
didn't ask for a recount right so you're
I assume you're a hand count Town 2,000
votes how we no we're a machine count
machine count town so is it possible
that your election was outside of these
margin of
Errors um I'm not I'm not sure what you
mean by outside of the margin of AR well
you gave a you gave an average you're a
machine count town right so oh my
district yeah my district if the if the
error was only 0 2 or Point let me
rephrase that if the difference if the
error was only 2
34% .5% it would not have affected the
outcome of my election
okay but that's this year who knows
about the year before who knows what the
error was the year before there's no way
to know so in in my I have a floal
district I represent question
representative Barry yes I have a I
represent over 28 almost 29,000 people
in South Manchester in the town of
Lichfield um I live in Ward n um which
is a it's becoming Republican but it's a
still a Democrat leaning Ward um and
then I represent w 8 in the town of
Lichfield which both tend to lean
Republican in my election I beat my
opponent um she won ward nine um I beat
the other Democrat running um but I got
second to her in the ward um she was
super excited about losing to me um and
she ran for selectman now for those of
you who don't live in city government uh
in city government a selectman does not
rule over the city the selectman counts
ballots so under your proposal the
person who not a big fan of mine um is
going to be counting my ballots and
that's where I think we need to find
some form of compromise because bluntly
I don't trust her I did not vote for her
for select me by the way um but I think
if you were in my shoes you probably
would also feel the same way would you
not I I I miss the L words I'm sorry so
so you're you're asking me right to have
my previous opponent who I have beaten
count my votes in the next election yes
that's right and and so here's the issue
is that one advantage of this that's not
discussed is that it could allow for I
mean you know you can make every it's a
half full half empty argument the half
full argument is that we can evolve more
citizens in this in this process so all
right all right okay representative
Allegro is going to be excused from the
mic if the Clapping continues so keep
that in mind please it's okay please
these are the regular rules of the house
and so I ask that we abide by them so um
yeah it could provide for more uh
involvement citizens again I understand
this isn't going to be easy getting
people involved in elections although
you might find it different now if you
can judge by what you're seeing today
you might find it different now but
getting people involved in the wearisome
project of counting votes is not going
to be easy so yes we're going to have to
hire some more poll workers or poll
volunteers who get small stipend again
here's the bottom line uh representative
and and it's a it's the toughest part of
this whole thing I willingly admit the
toughest part is the time and the
Manpower but my answer to that is if
this was going to be bloody murder and
and not just a
discomfort the question is still are we
going to make accurate counts in our
votes do we want fast or do we want
accurate so I I very much appreciate
could a compromise be reached um I
suppose I need to think about that and
if anybody in the committee or in the
house has some good ideas I'd be Tickle
Pink to work with you and try to bring
it to something that's less painful but
more accurate honestly so please
do thank you further questions for
representative
O'Brien good afternoon thank you for
that presentation in in our state the
electronic ballot counting machines are
enacted by and purchased by the
municipalities and that's who decides
that they can remain in use so if a
community doesn't want electronic ballot
counting
machines citizens can
apply they can they can petition their
own leaders to to discontinue their use
have you done this in your own community
and has that been effective and do you
think that this this P this situation
that we have now is ineffective well
actually there are two two parts your
question I'm going to answer the second
part first and that is it is my
understanding that people in my district
are indeed introducing a a petition
warrant article and I know it's
happening around the state but to the
first part of your question in the US
Constitution the state legislators have
the power to enact the means and the
timing and so forth of of Elections so
we do have the authority to do it um
this isn't a matter of um
Town um officials being able to able to
overrule a state um election law uh it
would be nice if they all
did um but we'll still face problems in
some of our larger
towns did did I answer your question
hope I'll be happy to take it in a
different form if if I didn't any other
questions from committee members and I'm
sure the representative would be open to
receiving questions individually after
this hearing thank you
representative I have a number thank you
I have a number of pink cards we're
going to ask that speakers um as I said
stay to three minutes we of course give
the sponsor of the bill um great
latitude in presenting the bill so we
Malloy thank you Kathy thank you thank
you uh Madam chair for the opportunity I
uh my name is Dennis Malloy I the state
representative from Rockingham 23 I
represent Greenland and
Newington and uh uh you may have heard
that uh indeed Greenland just recently
had a petitioned Warren article
presented to the voters can you get a
little closer to the mic pleas had a
petition Warren article presented to the
voters and that vote was uh held a week
before Christmas this this year on a
snowy
Saturday and uh we had a turnout of
about six about two-thirds of our
elected uh our registered voters turned
out for that petitioned Warren
article and the the article said to uh
see if the town would eliminate our
machines that vote failed by a 9 to1
vote in a town that that uh Prides
itself on
accuracy
Integrity
our town
clerk Marge Morgan was the former
chair of the Town clerks
Association she is in contact uh in with
every town chair a town clerk in the
state and uh
saw this response in
Greenland and she is getting questions
from many Town chairs about how this
happened and uh what what that
means the I'm a former selectman in
barington New
Hampshire and I my third term in
Greenland the state uh state house in
here so there are a lot of other facts
and figures I could give you but I think
the what I would like to leave you with
this 90% of the
voters of the
66% registered voters in Greenland
rejected this idea
outright so that is uh one one
example and I can only speak on behalf
of green I cannot project that out to
the rest of the state and I don't
pretend to I can also tell
you that our town election officials
have a pretty good handle on uh what
they think the turnout's going to be we
printed 700 ballots another 300 needed
to be printed that day to accommodate
everybody who came to the polls those
300 then need to be counted by hand and
they were that day one warant art one
item on that ballot if you could wrap it
up it took
representative an hour and a half for
those pole workers to count that and to
make sure it was accurate so what does
that mean when we have warant articles
in March where you have multiple
pages of ballots and
candidates and I'll thank you very much
I'll end it with that thank you for your
representative also also signed up to
speak on this bill is Judy Laughner do I
have that right Julie there you are come
here hi I'm Julie lochner I live in
Raymond um after I heard about the
Windom results I checked the machines in
my town in Raymond we have three
machines and to me machine 3 looked very
different than machine 1 and
two um just for an example for the
presidential race in November 2020
machine one had 31% for Biden on machine
one and two and 62 and a
half% on machine number three and that
was the same way down the whole ballot
for machine number three so I did go to
my Elman and I made it clear that I
trust the officials in my town but I had
questions about the machines because of
the way the numbers look and because of
what happened in
Windom and they weren't very interested
they said it was too expensive and it
would take too much time basically so
some of us said well how about if we do
a recount no you can't there's the state
laws against that it's too late well how
about if we on the next election how
about if we hand count and machine count
just to check the machines no you're not
allowed to do that state rules so at
this point this feels like it's our only
recourse that we get rid of the machines
so that the people feel confident that
their votes are counted thank
you thank you all right no applause
please everybody deserves your same
attention and response that's how we try
to treat all of you on the committee
also signed up to speak on this
is
JD burnhard
glasses thank you madam chair and and uh
committee I am a
representative Rockingham Rockingham 16
uh that is Southampton East Kingston and
Kensington um I'm going to take a little
different tact on
this to me this issue is all about
trust trust in our election trust and
election
Integrity there are many many polls
showing that election Integrity is a
major issue in the United States right
now and I'm going to divert to another
area area where we where we need
trust we have in the state a Division of
Weights and measures what do those
people
do 20,000 different devices are under
the divisional weights and
measures um 300 and
3,200 businesses are supervised by
Division of Weights and
measures over 260 people are certified
as testers Checkers inspectors by that
division why are they doing that why am
I why am I talking about that because we
need to have faith that the weight of
the things that we buy the pump that
pumps our gas is pumping one gallon not
less and we've set up a system to ensure
the Integrity of those machines
and
scales and ensure that our economy is
working in a productive and true fair
manner what's in place for our election
counting
machines
nothing we have no chain of custody
requirements for the memory cards or the
or the microchips we have no software
Security reviews
we have no audit
requirements we have no upgraded
security directives we have no testing
against
controls we have no certifications of
the technicians that are responsible for
dealing with these
things it's entirely left to the
organization LHS is the is the company
in New Hampshire and most of New England
deals with these machines it's entirely
left in their hands now there is a very
small guidance document that was written
in
2010 by the Secretary of
State uh in response to the ballot
commission saying you need some guidance
here and it tells a town clerk how to
deal with these
issues we recently had a member of One
of a constituent in one of my towns
Kensington El brandano he is here today
do a view of how well that process is
working in the town of Kensington
representative I'm going to ask that you
try to wrap it up it's been over we'll
do thank you the the the bottom line is
is it did not work at all many many
problems associated with that no militia
intent was identified but big problems
so my focus here is to
focus the issue on trust if you want
trust in this election if people are
going to have trust in the Integrity of
these results you heard the results from
Mark hand count is the highest most
trustworthy way to do election
counting happy to take questions
committee I'm not seeing any thank you
I'm not sure this mic is picking me up
all right the next person I have um here
is rousan
Chester R Us SS n oh
there my new friend helping me organize
taking over your
job I'm gonna put this down thank you I
am
um so I'm coming here today in support
of getting ma excuse me could you state
your name again and I'm sure I said it
wrong so I want to know how to ran
russan Chester it's R Us s a an for the
record um I'm coming here today in
support of getting the machines out of
our state um I
uh some of you folks may not remember
the um Fiasco in the 2000 election um
not in our state but uh in the federal
election that's when the trust in our
election process began to go downhill
and has been increasingly go going
downhill over the years we currently
have 30 towns that will be having
warrant articles on their ballots in
March to get the machines out that's
pretty impressive seeing that we had
less than 24 hours to get those warrant
articles in place um second of all I'd
like to speak a little bit um about the
Greenland
Fiasco um that um representative spoke
about I actually know a number of people
in Greenland who thought they were
voting to get the machine out or they
thought if they voted if they voted to
get the machines out they made the clerk
look bad and they trust their Clerk and
they trust their elected representatives
so the bottom line is Greenland might be
an outlier but as you can see here today
we don't trust too many of our elected
representatives anymore we have gotten
to the point where we have said show me
the proof I don't trust you folks
anymore I have been here every day day
since January 5th I've been either at
Double Tree or here speaking and paying
attention and I am getting everyone
around me to speak and pay attention to
what our elected officials are doing and
what we're allowing to happen not only
in our in our local and state government
but what's happening with our machines
our machines cannot be trusted they
never should have been trusted um and uh
there's been problems for years for
folks that don't have the statistical um
I was trying to look up everyone's Town
that's up here or town or city to see
how many voters you have so you could
get the the figure on the on the average
so the best way to do it is to take your
to take your voter population take um
10% 10% of that voter population and
divide it by half that's how many votes
were wrong just in your C your county or
District
that should make everybody go
what and if it doesn't then shame on all
of us thank you um any questions thank
you anybody on the committee have any
town thank you madam chair and U members
of the committee um my name is Brenda
town I am a bu or I was a business owner
here in the state for for 12 years I
have been a group controller of a
billion doll business I run aund Million
doll business today and I'm on a board
of directors of the largest employee
owned company I'm a mother of four kids
three in the military who are serving
right now and I am a grandmother of
eight and so I'm here to talk from all
of those vectors the first thing I would
like to say is that I was never
politically active but over the past two
years I've kind of had an Awakening and
it's been a gradual process but the
election process was my big Awakening
and it catapulted me into becoming a
participant in um a citizen uh citizens
audit for a Statewide audit for New
Hampshire and through that process I led
the canvasing effort as well as did a
personal evaluation of at least 100 plus
of our Town's uh machine performance
so on the machine performance I will
tell you that when you look town by town
you will find anomalies where at least
uh one if not two or three of the
machines perform out of statistical um a
statistical normaly to what the
registered voter um uh uh profile looks
like so as a citizen who would like to
go further to look at how that could
happen we have no access to root data
which of course are the ballots we have
no access to those the second thing I
would like to say is that from a
canvasing perspective we have found that
on the doors we've knocked at least
anywhere from 10 to 15% of the people
that were voters on our on the day of
the election did not vote or were in
another capacity they voted either
absentee when they should have voted in
person and vice versa so with all of
this I found myself in that same group
of people the same group of people that
uh show up now is 50% who don't trust
our election process and we need to
trust our election process I have sons
that are serving to fight for our right
for having our voices heard and it is
shocking to me that we would allow
machines to R wipe away the voices of
the citizens of New Hampshire whether it
be by accident or by Mal feance as a
business owner and as somebody who ran
large Finance departments the lack of
business controls that happens around
those Mach machines within our state is
astounding to me no business owner would
ever allow a third party to manage their
bank accounts without audit without
visibility into what goes on in the bank
they would want to complete in total
reconciliation of everything that's
going on and we have absolutely no
transparency if you want to know the
absolute count of what went through the
machine you have to have a recount if
you have if you want to make make sure
it ties out without that there is no in
Integrity in the numbers that we as
citizens of New Hampshire can believe in
so we are here today loud and clear to
say we want the machines out we want
hand count and we want to restore the
trust in the vote of New Hampshire thank
you Kelly
Penza Kelly Kelly Penza are you
here anybody know who Kelly is is she
right so it's it's hard to say this in
three minutes I'm just going to really
talk about Windam the Windam audit in s
sp43 um because we spent there's many
many people in this room that spent
hundreds and thousands of hours on that
um and so really if you ever if anybody
read report that came out it showed that
the
machines were a problem foldgate we know
that there was inaccuracies if every
vote is not counted then that's a
problem and Wen made a lot of mistakes
and we know that there's aund and some
odd page report but I'd love everybody
to know because this is an article that
was written by myself and my very good
friend Sarah
iban all of the public officials on the
house election law committee knew knew
in advance that the folds were going to
be a problem and they did nothing about
it the chair of the election house law
committee knew it and did nothing we
could have spent a little bit of extra
money to have no folds in our ballets to
make sure that all our votes were
counted but we didn't want to do that
Miss Penza your testimony is to the
committee thank you very much I'm sorry
your testimony is to the committee I'm
just reminding you thank you okay well
it is to the committee you are the house
election law committee okay so also when
you guys found out about the the folds
were going to be a problem there was a a
meeting this was on May 19th of
2020 all of these people were at this
meeting of course all of the house
election law committee Dave scanland dep
who was the deput um now he's actually
the Secretary of State Bud Fitch legal
counsel Nicholas chongyang many others
except one person that was at this
meeting and that person wasn't Le he
wasn't listed on any member roles or as
a participant but he piped in the
meeting just unexpectedly and what is
his name Jeff sylvestro the president of
LHS which is Dominion voter machines why
is he at our house election law
committee Manor why have we sold our
vote out to an to a third party that's
what we've done and all of these people
are talking about it here that is
unbelievable that you have someone that
is printing our ballots that's counting
our ballots that's got the the the
memory cards it's crazy no one would
ever do that and you guys all knew about
it that means you're all in on it so get
the machines out there's no other way
we're done with this thank you Miss pend
and everybody here will work an election
I'll be there I'll count every single
one we you've got all your election
workers right here this hearing this
hearing will be adjourned for 3 minutes
um and we're going to take a break for
three minutes and it has occurred to me
that I believe there is a rule for rep's
Hall um that no hats are allowed so I'm
going to ask that people remove their
you
e
on
we've uh we've been doing a little push
live
ass
d
all right and I'm going to start up now
so all right we're going to get started
here I said three minutes and as it is I
went over so if everybody wants to quiet
down please um so we can get going
[Music]
please all right and again uh for
purposes of this uh meeting we're trying
to keep the unmasked people in these
sections the masked people over the UN
the masked people over here so if you
don't have a mask on um we're going to
ask that you either move or maybe move
over to the last section over here as
compared to where the mass people are um
just out of respect for their concerns
and we have plenty of seating I'm going
to ask everybody to have a seat um is
Dy Joan up oh okay I just spoke to
you all right come on D all right again
we are the time for speakers is three
minutes I'm I'm giving you a little
Indulgence when I give you that time but
we want the people who gave us a card to
be able to speak and you have written
you
my name is Joan dargy the town clerk in
the S town of Milford all right if you
can get a little closer to the mic um
yeah thank mask a little hard speaking
on behalf of the city and town New
Hampshire City and town clerk
Association and we respectfully request
that you itail this bill we are opposed
to this bill for many reasons machine
counts have been found to be be more
accurate than hand counts as eviden in
almost every recount conducted by the
Secretary of State's office it is
usually the hand count towns that have
the largest discrepancies the machines
we use are the most basic of devices
they are only reading the marks on the
ballot they are not connected to the
internet and the programming is very
basic hand counts would require a
battery of election officials to be on
hand at the end of a 16 to 17-hour day
to have them sit down and count for
another six to 10 hours is Not
Practical um in Milford for example we
have
over in 2020 we had 10,000 ballots on a
a town election will we can have close
to 15,000 ballots that need to be
counted um we would
need we have approximately 200 over 200
volunteers that day we would need
another 150 volunteers to hand count
that night the election budgets for
workers would triple or more finding
election workers would also be very
difficult for many cities and towns
therefore five for leading to a much
longer time to complete the counting
going to hand count would be like
telling the Automobile Association to go
back to building cars manually and
getting rid of the machines machines
have been found over and over in many
disciplines to be far more accurate than
humans why would we want to go back in
time and I I attached an article written
by um recently by David Brooks that
where he did a little study on the
Machine versus hand count accuracy if
you have any
questions thank you does anybody on the
committee have any
questions I'm not seeing any thank you
very much for coming in your written
testimony um I have signed up to speak
Todd
uh good afternoon Albert Todd live in
nashille New
Hampshire um I'll start out by stating
this there be no greater a breakdown in
the trust and diplomacy between the
people and their government than the
violation of their vote and the right
thereof I have poured through our state
constitution multiple times every time I
do so I notice the same principle the
power resides with the people now we
have educated you on the issues and
instructed you on on our will to fix
these issu isues multiple times now each
time we have been met with corruption
and intent on demonstrating power that
no one in this state has given you if
the power resides with the people and
the people have enumerated and
instructed their representatives through
verbal and written correspondence then
the Constitution is quite clear as to
what needs to happen next you are to
enact legislation that is representative
of their will anything less than this is
quite clearly a breach of your oath to
the Constitution and Mal administration
of your office and you should be tried
for treason and at minimum fired for it
we have been more than patient with you
and worked hard to get legislation
passed that is representative of our
will yet even now we have heard words
from some of you that you will only
support this bill if this person or that
person supports that bill I ask you did
they elect you or did your District
elect you is is it the will of the
government that compels your decisions
or is it the will of your constituents
that compels your decisions if it is
anything less than the latter then you
should remove yourself from these
Chambers immediately and open your
office up to someone who understands the
true role of government here in our
Republic there isn't a single person
within this government that has not been
educated regarding the issues on
potential fraud that could be generated
using these machines for crying out loud
Harry hursty your auditor your auditor
made a documentary doc about it called
hacking democracy to deny the potentials
of fraud using these machines would to
deny the credentials of your own auditor
now I strongly implore you to do your
job and ban the use of these machines in
our Republic in order to secure a free
Society for the
posterity of our
Republic thank thank you also signed up
Todd
I just want to make a quick statement um
Greenland used their machines to count
the the special election for to get rid
of their machines so there there's that
I would like to start with a quote made
at the audit by the chief investigator
of the AG's office just because it's
unethical doesn't make it a criminal
violation this quote summarizes the
entire audit and the New Hampshire
government Harry
Hy Harry hsty resets the machine cards
without making a copy and stated it was
the only way we later found out through
the machine manual that he could have
made a copy of the memory card using the
machine itself in doing this he violated
not only state law but also federal law
after obtaining and reviewing the video
Harry hsty resetting the the card
something very particular caught my eye
Harry was using lhs's directions to
reset this
card
could you imagine a business being
audited by the IRS getting directions
from the business they are auditing how
them um when SP sp43 was originally
introduced LHS wasn't even allowed at
the
audit unfortunately it was Barbara
Griffin and this committee who onlined
it and allowed LHS to be at an audit
which was a conflict of interest so are
all three of our
Auditors when you take the four machines
from Windom and you calculate the
overvotes and the undervotes Machine
number two had a five about a 5% larger
increase when Harry Hy reset the cards
and this is before he blew all the
machine off and did his special tricks
it went normal the overvotes and
undervotes for the other four machines
went normal and this was before he
cleaned the machine like he claims
Harry hsty says in a in a an
affidavit um signed under perjury for
the Winsconsin court that these machines
can be manipulated and you would have to
reset them and that clears the memory
card I've sent you guys all that affid
David So when he reset that memory card
it's not a coincidence that the
overvotes and undervotes on machine
normal hacking democracy we've already
gone over that foldgate someone else has
already gone over that we're going to
save the taxpayers in New Hampshire and
astronomical amount of money I have over
$150,000 in in invoices for four states
I mean for four towns in the state of
New Hampshire there's 136 towns that use
these
machines this is not a partisan issue
it's not I'm an
independent I
um so it's time for you guys to stand up
for us and stand up for America because
this is our vote is the most sacred
right that we have my three
grandparents survived the trip from the
Mayflower and survived that first winter
I have two
grandfathers that fought in the American
Revolution I am not going anywhere my
DNA is going to get these machines out
of this town out out of the state whe
whether anybody likes it or not I won't
give up it's not in my DNA now respect
everybody in this room and get these
machines out because you guys know for a
fact that we should not be using these
machines thank you questions from
Todd okay thank you I I also have signed
up to speak Shelly Linsky
look
Shelly
thank you for the
opportunity uh Madam chairman I just
wanted to address uh one of the members
of the committee um the gentleman
Republican I yes I I'm sorry I don't we
don't identify members by their party
the representative has a name and your
comment should be addressed to me
through the committee that's just the
protocol well yes I was addressing it to
you but it was in response to his H his
remarks um and I just wanted to
say
um I just wanted to address his
concern
uh that he stated he would not want his
former Democrat opponent to be counting
his
votes uh I just wanted to say that I've
been involved in
recounts and in hand counting years ago
in my town of miramac and it's
never hand counting is never done in a
vacuum by one
party they have uh safeguards for that
and it's always Democrat Republican and
if there's another party involved there
there's there's always safeguards so his
concern is something that he does not
need to be concerned about and I just
wanted to make that point Thank you
Al also signed up to speak on this is Mr
Grace is it
natch is natch gra still here apparently
bergus good afternoon um Johnny bures
Bedford New Hampshire properties in
multiple towns in New Hampshire several
businesses a little dressed down but I
own a significant insurance agency and I
can put my agents in front of a Walmart
for the day and I know they'll get about
16 sales and a really good day maybe 22
a really bad day maybe 11 but if once in
a while they get 64 something happened
you can't expl it's called an anomaly
when Harry Hy said there was an anomaly
I think moisture or some ridiculous one
in a million in
Windham there's also one in a million in
Bedford in Amherst in Claremont all over
this state that doesn't just happen if I
send an ad out for my real estate
business or my insurance business I'll
get about a one quarter of 1% response
if I have a really colorful ad I might
get a half a percent if I do really good
a tiny bit better than that if I ever
get a 9% response something happened you
can't explain these away listen they
make chocolate and vanilla because we're
not all the same if we all believe we
had Integrity in voting we could if my
if my opponent one of one of vote I
would tip my hat and say see you in four
years I'd buy you a beer or a coffee and
try to talk you into what I think ex Etc
but if we had voting Integrity we'd all
get along great right now we know we
don't because of the machines it's not a
I mean the heroic work of Maryland and
New Hampshire voter Integrity 19 192% of
people voted in water in Waterville
Valley I mean there's something very
very wrong with this great state we can
fix it but that's up to you
guys thank
you
questions from the committee he's
already sat down but anybody have any
questions okay
um
Goss I apologize for the inability to
read your
handwriting it's not the it's not the
first time and the name is harleen
harleen yeah the why is silent they did
that to confuse
everybody
I did not plan to speak today but I
learned something that really upset me
immensely I do Hospital lab work we have
protocols for every machine that we run
if we run a lab test and it is 10% off
if it's even 5% off you can send a
patient from being a normal value to a
bad diagnosis to even a critical value
and when I learned that there is no
quality control on these machines
there's no preven maintenance on these
machines that to me is absolutely
horrifying I can tell you that we have
PMS done on our
machines regularly it's documented
anybody can check it out we have any
kind of issue we get the company in but
every day that we run a test on those
machines we are doing quality control
and in some cases it's three times a day
depending upon the particular particular
test and the particular instrument so
the fact that these machines only have
one company responsible for them and
there's no quality
control that to me is
horrifying because we could kill
somebody with the wrong lab result just
think about that this is not life or
death but this is the death of Freedom
if we don't do something about that
good afternoon I'm Jen Mercer from
Lowden I'm asking you to support hp6
1064 to to require paper ballots and
hand counting for the entire State I
along with the 80
to 100 million voters would like my vote
to count yes Trump won in a historical
Landslide I'm not going to repeat the
information already presented Mark Mark
and the rest of those speaking in
support did a great job I've done my
research on the ability to use
algorithms and adjudications to alter
votes with these machines I've watched
election night as votes mysteriously
switched as counting was shut down for
numerous numerous ridiculous reasons
reasons when Trump was ahead only to
wake up to a changing to abide and lead
or changing in the several days and
weeks that followed as fake ballots were
B in or our counters were processing
ballots that was followed up with
hundreds of hours of going through the
information and the NOA report the Maric
Copa County forensic election audit and
the audit report from New Hampshire if
you don't have time to do your research
then you should at least ask yourself
how does a state flip to Red at the
state level but vote blue at the
national level this makes zero sense
unless cheating was involved reminder
the evidence shows that Trump won we are
in this economic and social mess because
of the cheating that happened it's long
past time that you take action one to
fix 2020 before we lose everything to
communist China in the meantime please
vote to support hb10 64 to remove the
machines thank you thank you for your
Kelly um thank you Madame chair um I
would like to say that um I was at the
wiam audit for 15 days and what I saw is
uh it's a mat
show the switch and
swapping I've tried to pay attention to
machine number two because that's the
questionable one and you know what most
of us couldn't tell which one is number
two and at the the 15th day it's not the
machine that that's supposed to be
number two they switch everything and
the ballot running from Zig over here
run over there over here and over there
zigzag like that they don't run the test
like this so you can follow one pie of B
Ballance no it's like so confusing it's
like a circus in there and Harry Hy say
oh this is a per um a perfect storm no
it's a mess it's not a perfect
storm and I was at the marry Max special
election um billboard one right and they
have a ballot that's prefilled with the
democ on it and I happen to interview
the guy that got that ballot you know
and these all counted by the machine and
and Dair just recently in da special
election about 2:00 The Machine's down
so they had they sto using that machine
so machine do act up and have problems
but we don't have a system in place to
maintain or to you know monitor them so
the best thing is to get get rid of the
machine we know how to count them by
hands and that's the best thing we can
do because most of us don't have trust
in it anymore and I just want to credit
all this to Mr Tom marray and Ken iring
these are the two most dedicated New
Hampshire citizens that worked on this
for months to bring our attention to the
wiam audit and that's why it causes
movement
around the country not just New
Hampshire so New Hampshire is a primary
State Live Free or Die we set the sample
so let's do it right get rid of all of
the machine restore the faith and the
trust of the people to preserve our
freedom it doesn't matter how much it
cost or how long it take we have to if
we have this many people in the room we
should have that many bathroom prepared
for them right if we have a big big city
we need to have the system in place to
count all the ballots so it finished by
12:00 the end don't get lazy and get use
of the machine so we have all this mess
and it cost us so much money but what's
most importantly is C our civil rights
our Liberty and I flee Vietnam as a
political refugees so I know the value
of freedom and democracy and my father
spent seven years in the Vietnamese
communist prison
as a political prisoner as PW we know
and we don't want it here and with us
being lazy by not counting by hand we
lose everything do you all want to be in
prison for seven years no right Miss
Miss Kelly if I have to raise my voice
we probably ought to bring it down I'm
sorry and if you could wrap it up it'ses
yeah so so I'm sorry I get excited you
know I'm I'm I'm so passionate because I
love my freedom I can breathe freedom
the first day I was in this country I
love New Hampshire this is the first and
the only state that I live here I love
New Hampshire and I love to keep it that
way so please vote to support 1064 thank
you appreciate it thank you all
right next to to sign up thank you for
the
enthusiasm um nobody can match it I saw
you at the audit and everything and
thank you for that um also signed up to
hi Lois the young I'm a Brentwood
resident and to be honest with you this
I have voted in every election
presidential election since I was 21
years old that tells you that I'm old
because now it's
18 uh I very Pol I'm very active in town
towns have been and I have never seen
the like of this polling
uh just the pole Watchers two maybe two
to four years ago we didn't have any
pole Watchers in our little towns now in
our little town of Brentwood we had six
to eight we had to turn them away we
didn't have a place to put them all if
that doesn't tell you about integrity I
don't know what does people are watching
and they are looking and they want to
see because they don't trust their
elections and as my predecessor so amply
said our freedom is everything and if
this we don't get rid of these machines
we are not going to ever get another
free
election thank you also signed up to
speak on this bill is Al
branded
Brado thank you very much thank you you
have somebody with you correcting people
for you that's good it's okay just don't
call me late for just don't call me late
for dinner I'll be all right all right
and let me just before before you begin
so I don't I don't forget I have
actually two pink cards filled out by
you for the same bill uh one it's my
mistake I thought it was 1157 so it's
just this bill this is a duplicate okay
thank I just wanted to make sure I don't
miss you um I rise in favor of Bill
House Bill uh
1064 um and let me tell you why um I
signed up as a pole Watcher uh a while
ago and uh I live in a little town in
Kensington I've been there for 33 years
and um went through watched it all
happen actually I did it in the town of
K exer I didn't do it in my town and
watched what happened and I really
started to get involved because I'm like
you know there's something here that I
can't put my finger on I couldn't
understand and the more I did my
homework uh the more concerned I got and
what I'm about to tell you these facts
the selectman in the town of kensing
Kensington to their credit put it on the
website I did a
citizens uh report I went in and
audited uh the Town Clerk and the town
moderator and specifically for the
machines the machines have three
activity logs Canvas Bag data card
microchip on those data logs are witness
signings when a witness Witnesses when
they use the you know when the cards
come in and out the Micro Data comes in
and out all that when there's
maintenance on the machine about 40% %
of the time they didn't have a second
witness 40% of the time the maintenance
person who did the work on the machine
you can't read their name by contract in
the town of Kensington and I'm assuming
that all of them are like this the LHS
contract says that it can be their
representative or somebody they
designate when maintenance is done on
the machine they're supposed to say what
they did not
maintenance most most of almost 90% of
the documents assigned
maintenance I'm saying this is my little
town in Kensington to the gentleman that
talked about Greenland it's not an
emotional thing the town clerk work with
us we have an amazing relationship the
town attorney worked with us this is a
positive experience it was a it was hard
no one wanted to go through it but we
did and we did it right and we came
together on it and you can do it too but
you need to look at those activity
logs but one thing I want to leave you
with and I I urge you to be bold I
really do you can unite us you can
really unite us countries all over the
world Germany Canada Britain all handc
count whole countries do but I'm urging
you all of you to be bold we have a
problem we can work on this together we
can do this together but we got to start
from Ground Zero we got to start over
and if we can start over together we can
do anything and I'm asking you please to
be be bold and act to unite us thank you
thank you for your testimony also signed
tentarelli thank you thank you for this
opportunity to speak my name is Liz
tanelli I'm from Newbury and I
respectfully urge the committee to vote
an expedient to legislate on this bill
uh I had to change my testimony as I
explained on the earlier Bill across the
road uh so I I did a little cross out on
1064 I have included in my testimony
copies of the articles that the sponsor
of the bill referred to David Brooks he
calls himself the granet geek of the
conquered monitor did a study of our
handc counted elections that is our
recounts compare them with the machine
counts in those elections from 2016 2018
and
2020 and found that the machines had an
accurate
99.7% pretty good when we think about
our cities and the huge number of
ballots that need to be
counted I'd like you to think about how
hard it will be to find people to do
that counting in those
cities in 2020 in my role with the
nonpartisan League of Women Voters I was
trying to find bance ballot clerks
around the state to replace some of the
elderly ballot clerks who'd been doing
it for years but because of covid were
concerned for for their health and had
to step down that was not an easy job
imagine now trying to find all those
additional ballot
counters human beings make
mistakes it requires very close
attention to do that kind of B counting
multiple candidates multiple
races to do it for hour upon hour it
can't be the same people who are the
ballot clerks all day
obviously so I ask you to think about
the logistics of this but also about the
proven accuracy in the analysis that
David Brooks did of our hand counts
versus the machine counts and so I have
attached those articles to to this
testimony and I urge you to vote in
expedient to legislate thank
you thank you also signed up to speak on
Spencer
I thank you madam chair for taking my
testimony today uh can you hear me
okay okay lift it up yeah is that better
much okay thank you so my name is Louise
Spencer I live in conquered and I am the
co-founder of at all Grassroots
organization called the Kent Street
Coalition um I am speaking though today
on my own behalf um I'd like to to
congratulate all the people who showed
up today to participate in our democracy
that's always a good thing when we have
people who come and share their
opinions um and I I truly am grateful
that we have engaged um members of the
public I would like to point out however
since several members mentioned how many
people are here today that that I'm
aware of many who did not feel
comfortable coming uh because of the
thinking that it would be in the small
room over in the
lob and that therefore their presence is
not represented here today and I would
just like the committee to
recognize that there are limits on
people's ability right now to show up in
person um the other thing that I would
like to mention is that I think
our much of the distrust of our
elections um has been the result of a
failure of
leadership that myths and about voter
fraud about misfunctioning
machines about um absentee
bullets um these are
there are facts on these things and they
these issues should be corrected by
those who are in position to know better
we have one of the most successful
elections in our country's history this
last round with more people excuse
me that's why I ask that people don't I
not say a word people who agree or
disagree with everything that gets said
in any hearing and if you've been on
this side of the table you know that so
so
um charges about the elections were
brought before many many many courts and
dismissed so I would like to I'm here
today asking our leaders our elected
leaders to do a better job in
confronting some of the mistruths out
there that
inform the the dist Trust of our
elections we're told our elections
aren't safe and therefore people believe
that we have elections that we can be
extremely proud of we have election
hard they're often under it's been a
little over three minutes so if you
could wrap up I'm happy to wrap up I one
thing I'd like to point out I'm glad to
see that people are being able to
Express their opinion today by raising
their hands but I uh I've been
reprimanded for doing that in past
hearings so I'm a little bit surprised
to see that but thank you very much as
as chair of the committee I exercise a
certain amount of discretion on the
conduct but reps Hall's rules I try to
so those of you who come to committee
meetings know that all Comm meetings are
run a little differently depending on
who's at the front of the room so there
you go um also signed up to speak on
this is uh secretary scanland David
scanland I have a pink card for Mr Grace
who has apparently left if anybody else
is here and wants to speak if they could
head up back and grab a pink card or or
get ready to speak because uh secretary
scan and I have as the last speaker on
this bill we do of course have well then
outside
I want to give you the time to speak so
that would be terrific I don't know Shia
Kelly there are there still ping cards
out there there were okay thank you
okay all right secretary scanland thank
you thank you madam chair members of the
committee um David scanland acting
Secretary of State not taking a position
on this bill today uh because it has
always been the position of the
Secretary of State's office that in the
first instance it's the municipalities
that make the decision on whether or not
they're going to use a ballot counting
device or not and ultimately it's the
it's the legislator's uh responsibility
to determine whether uh they can be used
in the state as as a
whole I wanted to comment on this bill
because it is uh indirectly addressing a
much larger issue uh an issue that was
mentioned several times today and that
is the declining lack of confidence uh
in our
elections and I agree with many of the
comments that were made that you know we
have to get a handle on that and we have
to turn it around and we have to make it
this A positive experience uh and I
certainly think that we can do
that our experience has been that when
the voter properly marks a ballot the
uote machine does a pretty good job
counting it there are instances where a
voter won't put their Mark in an oval
and in that instance the machine's not
going to count that vote on the ballot
and that results in what could be
considered an error if you did away with
the machines if we got rid of them
completely I don't believe that the
problem is going to be solved
because there are many many instances
where there are hand counts that have
been done in elections that have been
off to a much greater degree than
machine counts as long as there are
humans involved in the election process
we're going to have errors and when we
do a state election there could easily
be as many as 6,000 people working at
the polling places making sure that that
uh election is conducted and that those
votes are counted
I've been thinking in my own mind how
can we start taking steps to restore
confidence uh in our elections where we
can get back to where we've been you
know 10 years ago and I will add that
really our our voting system hasn't
changed in at least 25 or 30 years uh
but all of a sudden today uh there's a
great deal of scrutiny and concern about
uh what's actually
happening um some of it's based on
misinformation but some of the concerns
are real and and I uh I understand
that I guess one of the things that I
would like to suggest that there are
many ways that we can address this issue
one are Audits and I know that your
committee uh has a number of audit bills
coming up to take a look at um I think
the the the process has to be as
transparent as it can be so that any one
of you can understand the process which
actually begins in June and it it goes
through uh to a couple of weeks after
the election's over while we're
conducting
recounts and that's going to be a goal
of mine you know I'm happy to talk to
you about ideas that uh will make that
successful I know I have had
conversations with Ken iring in the past
and I've certainly appreciated his
comments and and I think he understands
uh what we go through in conducting an
election as well so um as a gentleman
said I think that we can we can turn
this into a positive thing and uh and
Madam chair I'd be happy to answer any
questions all right does anybody on the
committee have any questions for this
secretary Madam chair if I could I I did
have a an item just specific to the to
the bill itself okay and that is that it
talks about using durable paper ballots
and if that language is going to be used
in uh a version of this bill I think the
word durable should be defined I me
right now we're required to keep
ballots by Statute for a period of 22
months after an election uh and then
they can be destroyed but if there's an
intent to keep them longer than that uh
I think that word or that term should be
statute representative Barry um thank
you and Mr SEC congratulations on your
position um in your testimony did I hear
correctly that your office would support
the concept of
audits I I
our our office has uh supported a a
version of audits in the past you know
it all depends on how it takes
place thank you any further questions
members thank you wait I have one
representative prome O'Brien thank you
thank you congratulations on your
position um I have been on both sides of
this issue myself when I saw some
irregularities in the election in my
community uh one thing that was very
helpful was this book of election laws
it goes over the machines and process
and isn't it true that this is available
for free in your office around the
corner for anyone that wants it uh
that's true represent Brian anybody can
stop in and pick up an election law book
hi teres Lawrence Manchester New
Hampshire I don't have any statistics or
anything to bring here I actually really
avoided this realm up until you know
like two years ago like many people um
but I have this this to offer I watched
the election in
November and I watched a live stream of
the front of the building on some random
person's Channel and on my TV and then I
went through my phone and I looked at
mainstream media channels doing a live
stream stream of what was going on there
wasn't a match I've watched people get
torn apart I see a president that looks
like he's doing Tik Tok videos on a
green screen and while I didn't vote I
think the problem is that nobody trusts
the machines and I'm for it I think that
it's silly to just discredit humans as
these flawed things that can't get along
and come to terms with each other and do
things the right way I think it's
dangerous to keep putting everything
onto technology I mean I have a laptop
that I want to turn into a frisbee
technology messes up and then so do
humans but at least we can communicate
and use compassion and really like get a
message across so I support getting rid
of the machines and that's
you also signed up to speak is Ann cop
former R an where are you living now it
says formally thank you madam chair
honorable Ann cop standing before you
former state representative the 2020
election season I'd like to stay stand
in support of this bill 1064 I think the
machines need to go and personal note in
the town of Derry which Our Town clerks
are here today thank you for being here
the election um for 2020 the absentee
ballots we had a total of 26,000
registered voters 18,000 voters voted on
on November 3rd and the absentee voters
were
1836 it's over 10% I personally did a
mailing to those people because the
secretary of state did not and I got
over 300 returned postcards my data is
solid it's still continuing and it's
added in with Greenfield and any of the
other towns that have done their audits
and I think it's important for us to
focus in on the next election because
the definition of insanity is to do the
same thing over and over again expecting
a different result the people here the
good Representatives please respond to
your people your constituents because
they're your bosses when you respond
only to the committee and the the powers
that be in this state which we know most
of the office have been usurped their
power is taken away from the house here
we are volunteers and people here in the
Reps Hall when the representatives can't
even do the people's business in
Representatives Hall that needs to stop
and our reps need to stand up speak for
us or else 2020 November's right around
the corner 22 thank you very much thank
you The Honorable representative nice to
see you where representative cop you you
put down that you're formally of Dar
where are you living now that's right
and I put it down that way on purpose
thank
you
so I'm going to put it down that you
now also signed up to speak is Teresa
grenell
is it theres or Teresa it's theres thank
you my name is theres grenell I'm a
registered nurse and I'm from Lowden I'm
also a foster mom of two little boys I
want to appreciate you guys for letting
us have a public um hearing today I got
started in this with medical Freedom
covid recovered full antibodies and
watching all my co-workers lose their
jobs and thinking I have a republican
governor Republican house Republican Sen
what the heck is going on in my state
I've been a registered Republican since
I was 18 I have voted down party lines I
voted for sinunu I found myself in an
executive council meeting being arrested
because I allegedly said the word amen I
have gotten politically involved in the
last three months when I found out
Marilyn Todd who sat across from me at a
general bulck fundraiser that I had met
two weeks before was also arrested with
me and I found out what she had been
doing with voter integrity and started
to look at what happened in Windam when
last night I saw Dick Tracy the Attorney
General say well just because it's
unethical doesn't mean that it's illegal
when I found out the memory cards once
they leave our town clerks can be
altered and there's no way to back into
how I voted that is not
okay I was in finance for 20 years we
cashed out our drawer The Vault teller
the bank the branch we had to go down to
the penny every night when we
closed when I worked at the hospital the
narcotics we did the count of the
narcotics together under dual control we
had to make sure every tablet was
accounted for I am all for
automation I am not about working harder
I'm about working smarter but when there
is no Integrity you lose the fundamental
piece of our
democracy if we don't have vote
Integrity we have nothing we have lost
it all I did not work seven years with
DCF to save these two boys from a
residential homes and growing up in that
situation I did not dedicate my life and
change my career path to be a nurse to
give up on helping people I did not work
this hard to live in this country where
people like Chia who come from China can
have freedom to stop
now I believe with watermarks I believe
with QR codes I believe with integrity
and these voting machines and us doing
some work we can get back to automation
but right now I think we need to take a
step backwards we need to take a step
back under dual control we need to count
our hand ballots and we had 30 cities in
24 hours get the warn articles in on
Tuesday it was a small Fierce group of
us but we have lost our jobs our
schools our hospitals
our
families and we're not going away and
we're paying attention and we are going
to get our voter Integrity back because
without that we have nothing this
country means too much to us we elected
you you work for us we shouldn't have to
take time off we shouldn't have to get
babysitters we shouldn't have to
sacrifice to micromanage what's going on
with our elected
officials all right that's enough and
I'll wrap up here with understanding
that the New Hampshire GOP our governor
sinunu it's all about pharmaceutical
covid money that has corrupted every
fiber of this country and it's going to
stop until I have not another breath
left in my lungs I will fight for our
you
ibody
Tom thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Tom Murray Windham
New
Hampshire um I rise in in support of
this bill before I begin I would just
like to point out and I'm not sure if
the committee members are aware the last
Friday on January 7th there was an a
there was a dual author by both
Secretary State Gardner and Attorney
General John fora and it regards to the
Windam audit if you haven't already read
this 11-page document I am going to
highly suggest that you actually do so
so I'm going to begin with a
quote from this letter quote windham's
election Night results were not just
imprecise they were fundamentally
flawed this is from our former Secretary
State Bill Gardner and our attorney
General John
fella I appreciate the
acknowledgement of the issues that wind
him in other municipalities throughout
the state has endured during this 2020
election
cycle This truly is about election
bill I
believe with all my
heart that the election officials wanted
to do the right thing nevertheless we
had errors and violations as well of
election laws this committee passes
those laws the fundamental issue there
is no accountability as to what happens
when I violate
them not just by me but by our secretary
of state and our attorney general wind's
monitor I'm sorry but a
monitor that's
it all these errors made and by the way
this is consistent and pervasive
throughout the state all one has to do
is go pull the tally tapes pick a
town sand down I challenge you committee
members to look at
Sandown you will see that in fact
Democrats were on the short end of the
stick just like Republicans were in
Windham in Windham we had the largest
voting discrepancy in the Hampshire
State history
history I'll let that sink in for a
minute and the
cause is the
machines during the audit of s
sp43 we were never able to recreate the
November 3rd election results
never we ran all 10,000 ballots through
machine 1 Machine 2 machine 3 machine 4
we couldn't even get them to line up
another and yet we are going to go
through another election cycle using
these same
machines I don't understand
that Mr Murray if you can at a minimum I
think this is a good start to remove
these
machines and from that point there's a
lot of work that this committee has to
do going forward thank you both for your
time and thank you for allowing me to
share my thoughts thank you Mr
iring thank you chair woman Griffin for
the opportunity to talk and for all the
honorable Representatives on this
committee oh okay how's this okay thank
you chair Warman
Griffin for this opportunity to talk
talk and for the time that I'm going to
take and thank you honorable
Representatives as well um I'm just
going to be
brief which I'm sure would be
appreciated my problem with voting
machines is
that right now we have all of all of the
machines across the state and in fact
across the Northeast five or six
different states they're all programmed
by one company now we're trusting that
that company does their job right we
don't know that they do I'm not
suggesting that anything nefarius is
going on but if they make
mistakes we're trusting that they're not
making mistakes these are our elections
this is all about election Integrity
everybody wants to know that if their
vote is cast that it's going to be
counted and that the people who truly
get the most vote should be serving in
office so that's one of my issues with
the machines uh they could be loaded
with
malware um and we would never know Harry
Hy one of the Auditors for the Windham
audit this past spring uh testified be
before the house election law Committee
in 2007 stating just that with our
machines so that is a
possibility although I'm not suggesting
that anybody would do that again we
don't know and we have no mechanisms no
way to verify and validate that our
machines are set up properly that they
counted the votes properly and that the
end results that are being reported to
the Secretary of State's office are
accurate and the other the other issue
is that if if there are overvotes on the
ballots they right now they get sucked
into the
machine voters votes for specific races
if if there is an issue with the machine
Mal malfunction their votes are
disenfranchised a perfect example was
wiam November 3rd 2020 where we had
hundreds I think it was 420 votes that
were counted as
overvotes and what happened is the
machines malfunctioned they counted
additional votes for the State Rep race
when there were no overvotes and that's
a problem after the audit between
November 3D the margin of discrepancy
between the fourth place Republican in a
four four- seat race and the fifth place
Democrat was 24 votes after a state
recount that grew to 420 votes that's
0.005% margin of loss to 99.6% margin of
loss there were
1,163 votes that were shifted from
election day and then after the recount
that's a lot of votes that were moved
around considering there were only 10,6
ballots cast and that's all due to the
inaccuracy of the machines so with that
I'm going to thank you again I do
support this bill and thank you for your
time does anybody have any questions
representative prom o' Brien thank you
thank you for being here you
too I had a little bit of trouble
hearing your entire testimony I'm
sorry I have a question and it's about
the January 7 report I skimmed a little
bit of it
and uh I read that that only a few
ballots one maybe six ballots something
like that went through the machines
during the testing period that is
supposed to happen to all of the
electronic ballot counting machines
prior to every
election and when those checks are done
is 50 ballots are put in there and
they're put in in every orientation
that's
conceivable so then you can check the
the the tally yourself a citizen can
watch this and what happened in wiam
what I said was there was only like six
ballots that went
through do you think if they had adhered
to state law that is in place right now
that this this these problems that you
had in Windham would not have occurred
that that would have safeguarded the the
election in Windham no not in this case
because what caused the problems were uh
the mail and ballots were folded and the
folds went across the ovals that got
filled in that caused an imperfection in
the ballot it caused the machine to
misread and and think of that uh oval
was being filled in when it wasn't and
that triggered overvotes and that's why
a candidate when people voted for less
than the number allowed the Democratic
candidate which is where the folds
mostly went through her oval uh she
gained votes she actually lost 99 votes
in the recount so she gained 99 votes
due to machine error and um and so that
was a mechanical error that has nothing
to do with the testing you're right the
testing was an issue too they didn't
follow the law but um that wouldn't have
resolved the issue on November
3D follow up I know that you more than
anyone else I can think of you and Mr um
Murray watched this very closely and and
do you know if the if the uh the town
clerks throughout the state were were
advised about the use of a folding
machine do you know if that happened no
you have to ask them okay thank
you further
questions I'm seeing none thank you for
your testimony that is the last person I
have signed up to speak on this bill I
want to thank you all for coming and
participating in the hearing uh we do
have two more hearings for this
committee some of you have signed up for
that um HB
1157 is going to start in 10 minutes and
it will be followed directly by hb1 1247
coming
I'll
e
we
yeah
should
supp
much
greate
just
El
know
don't
e
feeling
yes
e
all
right get going folks take their place I
don't
know
need
I
okay
to
all right good afternoon this is the
house election law we are resuming our
afternoon
hearings I apologize we are running late
um this is now the hearing on 11 HB
1157 relative to electronic ballot
counting devices the prime sponsor of
the bill would Norm Al introduce the
bill to get the bill in front of the
committee procedurally uh representative
to roian had to leave so representative
Hayward has agreed to stand in his place
to introduce the bill welcome
representative Hayward thank you madam
chairman I am as mentioned
representative Pete Hayward from
straford County district one the towns
of Milton and Middleton and HB 1157 is
fairly simple bill it uh
puts into the law that our uh devices
cannot be hooked up to the Internet
that's already the current practice it's
uh but it is not in law and this bill
puts it into law thank any
questions does anybody have any
Hayward you're getting away with it okay
representative Hayward you're set all
Gargano welcome to the election
committee thank you is this on okay yes
it is just get as close to the mic as
you can especially with the mask thank
you madam chair members of the committee
my name is Katie Gargano and I'm a new
face of the Secretary of State's office
nice to meet you all um I'm here to
represent on the
Secretary of State's office that we're
in support of this bill because the
current machines are not connected to
the internet and we don't foresee any of
the machines um in the future to be
approved by the ballot log commission
that would then be connected to the
internet as
well thank you thanks does anybody have
any
questions no we are not moving the bill
just based on that testimony
Representatives I know we are all
getting a little silly here all right
Chester Mike can
you Mike can you help her with the mic
oh no she's got it she's thank you so
much though um my name is ranne Chester
as uh many of the other um committees
have now said I'm a frequent flyer here
at the state house um I will be here on
a regular basis because I feel that I do
need to micromanage my um elected
representatives and that's a shame uh so
I'm just going to I I believe in
transparency I'm just putting it out
there letting you all know that I am
being very very observant of everything
you folks are doing the votes you're
making the votes you're not making as
well as the arguments um that being said
this is 1157 correct yes okay that being
said um I support this bill however I
strongly I strongly oppose um any
electronic devices at all being used in
our ballots or in our election process
um I was in computer programming and um
back in the day when the CPU would be in
this room and that's what the only thing
that would be in this room is the CPU
and the people working on it um and back
in that day the the the um common phrase
was garbage in garbage out the only
thing those machines can do is what a
human is telling them to do and that
human is no longer h face so you don't
know about their integrity and machines
don't have integrity they're not meant
to have integrity um so that being said
um I support this bill because uh I
don't think it should be connected into
the internet the other thing I want to
take um want to point out is that as you
folks all know uh much of our much of um
the hacking that goes on today on the
dark web and some of those other things
are not necessarily connected to the
internet and they still manage to get
our information so just the fact that
the machines are not physically
connected to the internet does not mean
someone's not gaining access to them
they are a computer computers can be
programmed
um out of the area to act and react from
a phone going off in the uh elction room
from uh I mean there are millions and
trillions of ways to activate internet
access without being physically plugged
in so in that in that case I'm saying I
would support this however I think we
need to get rid of the machines all
together thank you any
questions that's my
line I'm getting good at this all right
Lori uh my name is Robert Lori I'm from
the town of Danville
um yeah it's kind of low pick it
up I'm here in speaking in support of
this bill um I don't have a lot of faith
in technology and the internet and I
find that although people are talking
about machines and so forth having very
little error and people
also having comparable small amounts of
error like as in the counting as we
discussed in the earlier
bill I think the problem is there's an
interface
and when you're adding you you add those
errors together it's not like the
machines cancel out the human error or
the human error cancels out the machine
error I think you're adding them
together because for
myself uh I'm not very good with
technology and I'm on several committees
in my town
and we have a very glitchy internet
service
there and our system isn't particularly
secure so when we're using the internet
or we're using that technology we're
adding that human error which were all
susceptible to to the errors in in
technology so I'm actually glad to hear
that with this law we would not never be
connected to the internet because I
think that adds a lot of uh insecurity
to it you all know it's I've been hacked
several times on my computer and on my
phone so it makes it very
accessible to the
outside for people not within our town
so I am here standing in favor of this
film thank
trelli
sorry
yeah I uh chairman Griffin I I handed
that in too early too that's for
1247 but I will say I support this bill
um that our machine should not be uh
connected to the internet should I fill
out another card or will you shift it
over I want to speak for 1247
okay thank you Tom Tom Murray and I am
double checking here it looks like this
on
right everybody else knew that I didn't
there
you uh Tom muray Windam New Hampshire
thank you again um yeah I just wanted to
rise to um support this bill um I don't
believe that our devices should ever be
connected to the internet for various
reasons um
obviously knowing what we know now after
the 2020 election with all the uh
problems that we had throughout the
nation um I was
happy to learn that we were not
connected in fact the wires were cut the
modems were removed from all of our
devices but going forward if we I don't
support machines in general ever I'm I'm
a firm believer in hand counts um
especially as small of a state as we are
um but if there there was ever a uh time
where we were looking at another device
um I don't support those election
machines due to the fact that most of
them have a proprietary code um the ones
we use right now the acub basic machines
have a proprietary code I think I
believe everything should be open source
and I think you're just adding even more
um possibilities um to the uh swaying of
Elections by opening these up to
internet so I do support the bill and I
think it would uh take care of a problem
you well thank you uh Madame chair I um
I bring my credit card here I just want
to show you that I did not know this but
in the past few years I've learned that
if you put your credit card in your
pocket or your purse and you just sit in
the public place the thief can still all
of your
information that's why ever since I only
bring one credit card with a low limit
so without disconnected to anything they
they can get your information so of
course I I'm I'm supporting to get rid
of all of the machine but we cannot chew
the whole cake then we can have to buy
the small piece to finish it if we
cannot um I would like to support this
bill
1157 because
um I watched the um uh recount at the uh
wiam audit for 15 days I was there
straight every day from morning to the
Clos it right and I see that Harry hsty
the gentleman who's in charge of that
audit he was the one that
discover that he can hack everything
without even touching anything in the
80s on the '90s
so now is 2020 something and he's the
one now standing saying that it cannot
be
hacked and not only that the last few
days um of the audit is when they open
the machines so they can check the
hardware inside and stuff like that
there were three
Auditors only he was there the other two
gone only he physically there and you
know what I keep complaining like you
know we are not the expert in this
industry We Don't Know Jack about
machine or the the never my election
machine on
programming and we no expert he's say oh
yeah people are watching through the
zoom now I was there from the first day
observing everything you cannot see
anything even if you in the
room the scanning thing is so blurry you
cannot read anything if you stand in
front of it so at the end of the first
week on Friday that's when they change
to a different machine so you can see a
bit better but the thing is those camera
they pointing all over the places not
where you want them to be and like I
said they zigzag ballot all over the
places so that audit is not an audit
especially not a forensic audit for
certain I guarantee you that so no
connecting Internet to the machine
is the the right thing to do but the
better thing to do is to get rid of all
machines together thank
you anybody have any questions I don't
think so that is the last person I have
signed up to speak on
1157 is there anybody else here who
wants to speak on 1157 thank you um I'm
going to close the public hearing and
that is of course subject to I
understand there are probably lots of
blue sheets out there that I'm going to
need to pick up at the conclusion of
you at this time I'd like to open the
public hearing on 11 excuse
me 1247 relating to folded B ballots the
prime sponsor is uh representative
Moffett and he is here to introduce the
bill to the committee welcome
representative
M thank you madam
bit
uh thank you it's great to be back in
rep's Hall I don't know where everybody
went I was looking forward to speaking
to a crowd but it's not going to happen
apparently uh but anyway uh I have
shared electronic correspondence with
the committee earlier
and uh I do want to just mention that uh
this is election lot issues that were a
little bit personal for me because I was
in a race once it ended in a tie and in
the recount I lost uh one vote off my
total so uh every vote does
count so this bill is intended uh to
reduce the number of Under and Over
reported or Under and Over votes that
seem to occur when folded ballots are
fed through a ballot counting machine
there have been numerous reported
problems with folded ballots as you've
heard in the AC vote machines as you've
heard so well uh in dairy uh in the
November 2020 election I'm told that
they reported
572 overvotes on the seven uh other
machines in use overall there were 848
overvotes or votes lost because of the
machines the AG was asked to investigate
in Dairy I'm told but that did not
happen uh Windom of course as you know
so well there was an audit that showed
that the folded ballots were a problem
in this case attributed to the ballots
not being folded in the correct places
so this bill would have eliminated the
miscount in Windam had this statute been
in place at that time so numerous
moderators have reported having the
machines not accept folded ballots
unless they repeatedly tried to reinsert
the ballots maybe in different you know
orientations and and finally earlier
uh this committee did hear uh plenty of
testimony uh on a bill that would
entirely eliminate the use of ballot
counting machines now this bill while
making more ballots or requiring more
ballots to be handled or handc counted
uh would not be nearly as drastic as as
that
proposal so that's my uh my testimony be
happy to take any questions thank you
representative any
questions representative prudom br Brian
thank you thank you for coming here
today
uh I think that the dairy issue will be
addressed later on so I won't get to
that but do you think it's possible that
these these
um that the the issue is really with the
the fold going through a a target a vote
Target and that if that were to not
happen that this problem would be
eliminated that in that manner as well
okay thank you representative PR I'm
could you repeat that part about the
vote Target do you think if the if there
was other ways to eliminate a a fold
going through a vote Target that would
solve this problem as well such as
education of sure thank you for your
question so I think you're referring to
the way the ballot would be inserted in
the machine sure with a vote Target uh
that is something that I'm sure could
possibly make a difference it to me it
seems really fairly simple to insert the
ballot the machine is usually somebody
standing right there uh so a better vote
Target uh why not U if that could could
help alleviate the way the ballot enters
the machine okay thank you any further
questions thank you represent thank
you Christina
Guilford
Christina Guilford Dair town and school
moderator um I've worked elections for
many many years in March of 20120 I was
elected Town
moderator um 2020 had its challenges
with more absentee ballots than we've
ever seen
before after the November election we
did have about about 800 overvotes on
our sheet we are a Pick 10 town so that
means voters have to count and choose 10
you'll be surprised how difficult that
is um we also had um an Undeclared
candidate so they were picking 10 from
candidates again for someone who may not
be voting a straight ballot that can be
very
difficult so while we do have overvotes
they may not all be from
folds however after seeing the report
out of
Windam I cannot in good conscience put a
folded ballot through these
machines um in fact I have not we have
handc counted the absentees since then
and I know there's a lot of talk about
tossing the
machines well in Derry we had 18,000
voters sitting to figure out how many
people you'd need to hire to count those
ballots in a timely
fashion the Constitution says the
moderator counts the ballots and needs
to do so in
public at the end of the meeting
time so our polls are open from 7:00
a.m. to 8:00 p.m. we would then need to
start
counting and in my mind we would need to
do so that day so we'd need to have them
counted by
midnight that's a lot of
ballots I honestly feel
that putting a straight ballot through
the machine a flat ballot and putting a
folded ballot in the hand count is
perfect
idea many people who vote at home don't
use pen I've seen ballots in crayon I've
seen ballots with a
highlighter you'd be surprised what some
of these absentee ballots come in
looking like and we can fold it
perfectly when we send it out in the
town from the town clerk's office as an
absentee but then the voter gets it home
and they open it up and maybe they don't
send it back right away and they fold it
and then they open it and then they fold
it again and who knows where the folds
end up and knowing now what I know from
Windom you cannot put a folded ballot
Kelly
the folded ballot um I happen to help um
can I ring here and Inter tery group to
do the uh special election in
Danville and I I make it my duty to go
and observe them as much as I could
after the election November
and the Observer have to stand so far
away from where they open these fente
ballot where they come in in okay and
when so I complained so they finally
allow me to stand
near and as they open the ballot and
read the name I wrote it down and they
miscounted but they didn't know so I was
like recalculating my name and I go
through the names and then the moderator
came over and asked me is there anything
wrong I'm like yeah my number is off uh
your number is off I have more so they
recounted it and yeah so two big issues
ues right here yes human do make mistake
machine make bigger mistakes okay and
the process to count the balance absente
balance should be a separate process
instead of putting in through the
machine because there should be as many
Observer there in the due process
because only the two people here only
those two know if they make mistake or
not had I not there nobody know it was
off so it's important that these folded
Mach uh ballot and absentee ballots
should be count all separately and by
the way that was the only one that I was
able to be that close to observe the
absentee ballots the rest they are so
far away I could not see
anything so I support this bill and but
the better thing is to get rid of all
the machine thank you so much any
question any questions no thank
sorry I'm not as tall as Mike is
um thank you I'm Alvin C I'm uh from
lden and I'm representing myself and I'm
in favor of this bill uh I did want to
follow up on a question that represent
impr Brian had asked about the
machines um Alvin can you get a little
closer to the mic thanks the tip it up a
little more perfect the um Windam audit
definitely showed that with folds
through the voting targets that that is
a
problem however there are many uh
reports of machines and and we just
heard about uh Dairy where there the
machine that they use for absentee
ballots shows far higher number of
overvotes in that report now the report
doesn't show what office had the
overvote it just gives a total uh there
there's another way that there might be
an overvote
problem because the rollers that take
the paper and feed it through the
machine are not at the same place where
the uh glass rods are that has the
optical
sensors that when that fold goes through
the roller it may make the paper bounce
at the sensor which may be an inch or
two away from where the actual U fold is
we we don't know that information so
we're only guessing is what might happen
so and uh as as a followup to that
that's why this bill will uh help
alleviate the problem I have noticed
after the last general election through
a number of blog sites and and other
places reports of various discrepancies
between one machine and another that
should have had the same number of
votes uh machines
that um were used exclusively for
absentee ballots my town aladen has just
uses one machine so all the absentee
votes go through the same machine and
there's no way of knowing other than
looking at the top and saying that oh
yeah were 100 or 200 or so overvotes but
we don't know where they are and the
only option for the candidates is to ask
for a
recount uh I'll take any questions if
you have any do committee members have
any
Chester
once
again folks I'm in support of this bill
um I um again want to restate I would
rather get the machines out of our state
however I understand that a lot of
people are saying well that's a lot of
work and that's a lot of money and
that's a lot of time I don't care the
bottom line is when I went to the Double
Tree on January 5th and six and I heard
a representative say well I don't want
to have to be here on Friday so can we
just table
this that's unacceptable and this is the
same type of unacceptable
response we have we have we uh as the
people of New Hampshire and you as our
elected representatives have the
responsibility to put the power of the
people back into the hands of the people
um some of you may not remember the 2000
election where we had a Democratic
president C presidential candidate for
what a week 12 days and then all of a
sudden o hanging
chars that was a machine issue they
solved
it and now there's another machine issue
and another machine issue Harry hery one
of the things he said in that audit and
I was not at that audit but I saw it
live and 90% of the time watching it
being a former computer progam
programmer being someone that understood
what he was doing I just sat there like
oh my god did he just really do that did
he just really say that what when did he
sell out because in 2005 he was very
much against voting machines and he
demonstrated to a number of people how
exactly how voting machines can be
manipulated and controlled by nefarious
entities now is that what happened or
was it clearly just a mistake of the
machine I don't know it's not my
job but I want to bring that to your
attention um
2016 2016 the first person to ever I
remember ever talking about election
election
fraud was Hillary Rodman Clinton she was
very very clear in 2016 that that
election had been stolen from her bottom
line so this is definitely not a
partisan issue isue if the Democrats in
2016 were saying the election was stolen
and the Republicans in 2020 saying the
election was stolen maybe it was really
stolen both times I don't know not my
job
lastly there's no such thing as a
perfect
storm any storm is not perfect that was
another quote out of Harry Hershey's
mouth so we had the fos and then we had
this and then we had Windom not
following the law and we had so we had
all these different things that just
lined up perfectly and created a perfect
storm I'm sorry these are our elections
these are our lives we can't afford a
storm we can't afford even one aspect of
a perfect
storm thank you for taking my comments
anyone have any questions or comments
back at
me I'm not seeing any thank you okay
iring hi thank you again for the
opportunity to talk um I'm going to be
very very
quick um I just want to reiterate that
I'd prefer that we at at this point in
time get rid of the machines as opposed
to addressing the
issue but um as I pointed out before in
my previous testimony and I don't know
if it's worthwhile to go through again
because it's a different bill for the
record uh but you know all of my reasons
that I brought up before are applicable
here uh the machines are not always
accurate and in the case of the Windam
November 3rd election it's because some
ballots were folded across one of the
ovals um predominantly one oval it did
cross over other ovals as well but
predominantly for one candidate that one
candidate gained 99 votes and in the
instance that it was a straight
Republican ticket and the Democrat whose
oval was crossed over with one of the
folds in the ballots it triggered an
overvote you can see by the results of
the
machines that it was quite significant
and that's what triggered uh the
difference between 24 votes for the
losing margin of the leading Democrat to
420 votes after the recount so you know
with that I think it's pretty clear that
uh it'd be much more safer much more
accurate to hand count um mail and
ballots and I think that pretty much
you
are there any questions from the from
the committee no uh the next person is
Joseph
trelli thank you and I appreciate the
opportunity to speak to the committee my
name is Joe Terell I live in Hampton New
Hampshire we are recent uh we ex we we
fled Exile in Minnesota and Governor
Mount say Tim Waltz for the Liberties of
New Hampshire and I'm not expecting a
lot of this stuff when I come
here um I spent a number of years
covering
World
News uh overseas 76 countries I have
been involved in the coverage of many
elections in the 70s 80s and 90s the
last one was the East German election
when there was an East
Germany I've spent three Winters in m
go and absentee ballots to me mean a
lot and as a result of what happened in
2020 with the flurry to invite people to
have absentee ballots because of the
situation absentee ballots used to
require a reason and a notary in the
places where I used to live I voted in
1984 election on an absentee ballot and
delivered it to the American Embassy in
Rome to work its way to
Florida many of our military vote
absentee many of the people that are
Homebound and can't get out many of the
people that may be in traveling
situations that they can't get back like
I was for many many years can't get back
to have an absentee ballot thrown out
because it was misread by modern
technology Optical and I am a technology
guy to have an optical Reed throw that
out reminds me of a phrase that is
attributed to and I'm going to say this
name in this Hall Joseph
Stalin it's not who
votes it's who counts and I'm going to
say what counts the
votes that that determines the winner
okay spent a lot of time in a lot of
places watching a lot of really horrible
things in and getting it back for you to
watch it home because I'm out
there and to watch how we treat absy
ballots regular ballots with
machines why are those other compan
countries forcing hand ballots because
it's a it's a it's sacred and we're
ignoring it and when you think of the
military that are out serving us to have
their absentee ballots come in because
there's a fold that's not in the right
place as it was sent out and have an
optical scan or misread it and count it
as an
overvote no so I'd like for 1064 to go
through so that 1247 doesn't have to be
dealt with okay thank you very much for
your time thank you any
Penza So based upon the last bill you
know what I feel about in regards with
folds and fold gate and
sp43 and as I stated
previously this election law uh house
committee knew that folds were going to
be a problem did nothing this bill
should have actually been enacted before
votes were counted in 2020 but it wasn't
what a
shame I voted in Ry and I don't live in
Rye anymore but I was a pole Watcher and
so was my husband
they have never seen the amount of
absentee ballots that came in it almost
exceeded the amount of people that voted
in person and as Brenda there was a
woman that came up town was talking
about we were part of the people that
have canvased Rye so I'm just going to
tell you about one house there were five
votes in that one house only two were
valid those are the two people that
lived there the last three votes that
had come come in in the 2020 election
were the last three people that lived in
that house that don't live in that house
anymore and how did they all vote
absentee during that whole ele there's
only two machines in Rye one of those
machines was off the charts when it
comes to overvotes not of anything was
looked at of course I talked to the town
moderator I reported everything that I
had to the AG as well and my husband
reported all of that as well and to um
the New Hampshire GOP it fell on deaf
ears
nothing so we have a this bill is is
perfect and I would love all of these
things to be of course hand counted but
I don't want machines anymore at all we
can make it happen we can do it you have
other countries we're little old New
Hampshire we can do it Canada can do it
New Hampshire can do it it's not that
big of a deal to be able to be able to
get this done so I really wish that this
was introduced I wish it was applied uh
I wish that we had some more safeguards
in Ry for example they weren't even
matching
signatures I heard about that from many
other towns and so if you want to talk
about foldgate this was a problem I know
for a fact sand as we talked about
Sandown was a problem in Milford it was
a problem um in Waterville Valley and I
can go on and on so just if you look at
Ry alone that was over 100% voter
turnout because of those absentee
ballots that's statistically impossible
if you look at their last three
presidential elections Federal elections
they had barely 70% vote they were lucky
they were high 60s at one point that's
30% fraud let's not be the first in the
nation for fraud thanks thank you does
anybody have any
questions I'm not seeing any that is the
last speaker that I have signed up to
speak on this bill is there anybody else
present in the hall who wanted to give
testimony on this bill to the committee
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on House
Bill 124
1247 and that concludes the election law
committee's business for today I want to
thank you all for participating um we
will be meeting as a committee on
different bills with more public
hearings next week commencing on
Wednesday have a safe drive home
coming and and and somebody let me know
please
sir